[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
it's the playing hall
of the 2022 feed a candidates it was
that was a nice pair of sunglasses where
java was wearing a seawalk bike you know
he's his future's so bright he's got
shades on uh and it is just bright
outside that's a guy who's got a bright
future as we know
we are live in madrid
here with us now
is uh is another
another guy who's got a really bright
future and it just got brighter joining
us here for the candidates right uh well
as my flight descended in madrid it
really started to dawn on me i'm here
commentating the candidates it's still
weird to say it i'm 100 feet from fabie
and jan and i'm like two feet away from
danny and robert i could not ask for
anything better it's a great honor to be
here and i will do my very best well i'm
sure you will and we it's you know that
the the honor is all ours and for the
fans um i would i say that to robert too
not just you robert hi i know you're
there too hey dan it's not like we just
you know
don't so much distance between yeah i
drove a wedge between you
and i'm already causing all this chaos
well um
welcome in everybody to round eight of
the of the 2022 feed a candidates that
is the results from round seven we're
doing a bit of a uh jam-packed preview
show here just to quickly address that
obviously there's been some technical
difficulties going on with chess.com
servers we're working hard to get that
back up so bear with us for those of you
who are wondering what's going on we're
gonna we're gonna do a jam-packed
accelerated pregame show right there we
see we know what the two big results
were uh guys on on saturday napomneshi
and karwana win again for the third
round uh the third time here at the
candidates those two guys get w's on the
same day robert where are we at with
these two and and what what do you want
to say about what we saw saturday yeah i
think a lot of people were blaming rich
report for playing on but you have to
give janna palsy credit he came in with
great preparation if he secured a draw
in less than 20 moves that's a job well
done yeah and he benefited from his
opponent deciding not to make that draw
that's not his problem he wins again
he's five and a half out of seven plus
four is the best score anybody has ever
had through the first half of a
candidate tournament but he's being
chased by someone who also has an
incredible score if you told bobby he'd
be five of seven he probably would have
taken it he said as much your thoughts
on what you've been viewing as a fan now
a commentator on what the american
fabiano carbona has brought to madrid
yeah imagine telling him he's got five
out of seven and then you're not gonna
be leading yeah
they said of the third world champion
alexander alakine that you had to beat
him three times in the opening the
middle game in the end game and i think
that applies to all of the players in
the candidates they are unbelievably
resilient and that is what fabi has been
doing he's been beating people in all
three stages of the game and we saw that
really come out in his last game against
her chabot i mean that end game was
incredible he's staying sharp for the
entire game and when fabi is like this
when all the pieces are in place he's
terrifying to play against yeah well and
now now he's gonna maybe prepare you're
already already making alekhine
references
we knew we were bringing this guy in the
studio for a reason um
but uh no seriously great way to put it
now now he's gonna have to go up against
okay nakamura and beat someone again in
all three stages if he expects to earn
the full point we've got an exciting set
of of games here ahead for us in round
eight let's just start right at that
featured matchup has thrown over there
to you hikaru gets the white pieces he
lost as black uh in in round one of the
candidates your thoughts on how
aggressive nakamura will be uh knowing
that he's
he's in third place if it's it's now or
never if he's going to get a w right
yeah and hikara has shown extensive
preparation but i didn't find that his
preparation had that much bite dingley
wren a couple rounds ago played a
perfect game he was able to withstand
that pressure and so for five minute
caruana after a really long exhausting
game he himself said that he's happy to
have the black piece of such a tiring
game because the onus isn't the player
with the first move and we'll see what
uh excuse me caro has in store for
fabiano but fabinho doesn't look like a
guy who's particularly worried yeah no
he seems seems calm and collected maybe
got a good night's sleep it's easy to
sleep well when you're winning games and
but i'm excited to see what hikaru does
i know that at this point look there's
no way we can all deny the fact that
this is a this is a two-horse race at
this point i mean fabi bobby uh was
careful with his words but he said not
to speculate too much it's almost a
statistical certainty that either him or
nipon mishi that guy right there are
going to win the candidates but that
doesn't mean the other players aren't
playing for something in fact danya
let's remember the storyline
second place might matter in this event
so maybe there's no statistical way to
leapfrog both these guys but if someone
caught fire and did get second place
your thoughts on whether the players are
thinking about this well they absolutely
are we all know what magnus said it's
going through the players minds they
don't have any additional intel they're
as clueless about whether magnus was
trolling as we are but they've got to
assume that he wasn't and if you're
hikaru uh or you're somebody in the
second half of the tournament uh second
half of the tournament standing such as
ali reza you've got to be doing your
absolute best given the circumstances
given this very tantalizing possibility
that second place might amount to
something yeah
and i i you know i don't think magnus
was trolling it doesn't mean he's not
allowed to change his mind who knows
what could happen right but i think that
the players are obviously everybody came
in to win the event um hicarus said in
studio yesterday right robert that it's
the only tournament that even if you get
second you typically feel like the worst
thing in the world happened but maybe
not here in madrid and and maybe we're
talking about that uh in a few months to
come so all right
right now we're going to be talking
about the first moves on the board we
expect e4 from hikaru and indeed we get
it you think we'll see that quick berlin
draw that they're known to play in the
rapture
you mean the most exciting draw on chess
as commentated by danny wrench and dania
neridisky in our rcc right don't you
bring it up because there's knight f3
there's 96 no petrov there will be no
petra
um
oh it should be five okay i'm gonna
blame i don't know who i'm gonna blame
and i'm gonna blame one of us
we officially will not have the most
exciting draw in chess i i don't think
fabiano has to berlin as a regular part
of his repertoire in the same way that
hikaru players like wesley so
i guess mbl do anyway anyway
nbo normally on the white side of the
berlin though um anyway
castles from hikaru and we actually do
have our our bird's eye view up with uh
three of the four games here
wow a lot of e4s
yeah
and is that a
apparently dude by the way apparently
that wasn't a relay error like duda was
actually
oh sorry report actually was thinking
about his move yeah it's a complicated
position
indeed there's 20 options look at that
jacket by the way that's how you recover
from a game that you want to forget he
has showed up and stuff i want that
jacket
i've already said it and i will continue
saying every organizer should invite
richard report to every single
tournament yeah his fashion his fashion
will play yeah like the guy is just an
absolute legend and it was unfortunate
what happened yesterday but sometimes
you need that right you need to give
yourself a confidence boost
and he's been dressing very classily
every single day and yep no exception
speaking of dressing classy yeah you're
done you're looking good over here thank
you danny i selected my outfit with
great care
you know i needed to impress yeah my
illustrious co-hosts but we're still
doing this we're still doing no
what would also look okay robert you
look okay uh no anyway all right so back
to a guy who doesn't look okay uh he
looks great in that red suit richard
report um
okay so
you know what he's thinking
the storyline surrounding report
everyone knows it obviously he
he came into yesterday's
game versus john dapanashi hoping to
slow down the leader hoping to spoil uh
yon's plans right with the white pieces
hoping to also break his own draw streak
remember at the time we were talking
ahead in that game that he had drawn six
games robert despite having played some
of the most exciting chess i'm sorry but
i can't look at his game when look at
the bottom left of our screen yeah where
fabiano caruana has given up two minor
pieces for rook he's captured on f2 this
is theory so uh this has been played
before but i'm sorry danny to you know
yeah switch away from a really exciting
petrov a third move for white because
that game is a material imbalance and we
love to see that kind of fight yeah i uh
wonder wonder who will surprise who
first they're both i mean looking at the
two americans just absolutely bliss
blitzing out moves here
uh
donya your thoughts on the choice from
hikaru to go into this line certainly
it's going to be a three result position
at the very least oh absolutely this is
a lot to swallow now i'm not as
surprised by the open rue lopez which
has always been a very underrated weapon
it doesn't get the same coverage doesn't
get the same
for the same attention that you know the
berlin gets or the classical main line
gets but it hasn't been refuted and
i think the current theoretical status
is that white basically doesn't have an
advantage now i'm not sure where this
line stands theoretically i i've seen it
in super tournaments the last few years
robert denny maybe you can clarify my
memory a little bit
uh i feel like i saw it in the world cup
a couple of times i have no idea what's
going on in this position it's so
complicated and if we just take stock
for a second right black has two rooks
white only has one but white has a
knight and a dark square bishop for that
rook and two pawns for black so that
material imbalance is about seven to
seven i mean we count minor pieces at
three or three and a half depending on
the occasion and the rook and two pawns
is seven so but i guess i have multiple
questions that and they're not
rhetorical it's like
who benefits from a long forcing
variation we're already 16 moves deep we
saw hikarn nakamura show 25 moves of
preparation against dingley wren yeah so
who benefits from this long string of
preparation is it
hikaru or is it fabiano
i'm gonna let donny answer it i don't
know well
first dan madrid you're already asking
me these impossible questions
well before
i address the question just one comment
because i think a lot of people look at
this position their first reaction might
be what is this black is much better
look at those pawns on e5 and d5 the
important thing to point out is that
those center pawns as tantalizing as
they appear it's very hard to push them
because if you push the e pawn then you
create a hole on d4 and the d4 square
itself is very very well defended by
white's pieces so
uh let's you know
clarify that this position is really
unclear and probably the engine
evaluation is somewhere around equality
now now i'm going to get to your
impossible question who benefits from
this i feel like
the open ruy from from fabi is a clear
sign that he's playing for a win because
there are variations white can play
against the open road that lead to
very dry equality but fabi knows that
hikaru being in third place is not going
to go for them so from a psychological
standpoint a very bold uh and a very
daring choice and we'll see if it pans
out and it's it's not a choice he is
making for the first time for the record
the last time bobby played this line was
just just a month ago in early may
against mbl at the super bet in romania
uh in that game we had a 15 king to g1
and and uh here we we see we're still
following that in fact um but it looks
like black's 16th move bishop f5 was the
new one so offering the light square
bishop trade and i mean it's such a
fascinating rich position because one of
the things that happens in this material
imbalance with rook against minor pieces
the minor pieces they need to team up
together right there two of them that's
the real edge one rook versus two minor
pieces but how is that knight on f1
where is it going to go probably gonna
go over to g3 right hop out attack that
bishop on f5 there's already pressure on
the d5 pawn hikaru makes this mcqueen e1
he slides his queen over so his rook can
take the queen's place and put pressure
in the center and that's what you were
alluding to done is that blacks central
pawns you can't really push them very
easily and if they start getting
targeted you may have to push one or the
other and then that can create new
weaknesses so the pieces need to find
those squares and pushing e5 to e4 from
black's perspective as daniel said gives
the d4 square only white has the dark
square bishop so you don't want to hand
over the dark squares but that's i guess
now
look at this
did you see that look from your car
right there yeah
i don't know what yeah you ain't gonna
surprise me with that move
almost rolled his eyes uh
obviously
we know that hikaru's facial expressions
are often the topic of conversation
about his games and other people's games
he walks by and lets people know very
quickly how he feels but what i wanted
to say is robert you pointed out bishop
five was a new move compared to how the
mbl fabiano game win at the super bet
but it didn't slow down hikaru instantly
played bishop b3 has relocated the queen
to f2 without hesitation
knight to b7 already played so these
guys are 19 moves in everybody hey karu
has literally only taken enough taken
enough time to physically move the
pieces
it's not so many times this has happened
in the tournament let's not forget
borussia against nakamura preparation
ultimately didn't achieve the desired
result but that was a good 25 moves and
we haven't seen this amount of
preparation since like the early 2000s
the golden age of you know these 40 move
night or draws this is really
fascinating yeah and can we just talk
about how knight a5 typically in any
spanish to go after the light square
bishop but here's the cover the c5
square yeah and the reason everyone is
because white was threatening to move
the bishop to c5 a skewer of the queen
of brook so the knight is actually on a
defensive route not to win the bishop
which
this is an interesting position it
clears the path for the c pawn though
right the d5 pawn would have been a
quick target but now black always has
the move c6 yeah and if you really give
black time i'm not going to c6 i'm going
to c5 and then c4 and yeah i'm going to
push all those pawns in the center right
you don't want to push them too soon but
if you can by the way
he does want to push them too soon
apparently apparently bobby wants them
right now uh okay
and look at the car he he knows exactly
what's up he just gave that look daddy
apparently we were still in that game by
the way 19 queen of two was still
following the game between mbl and
caruana wow so we're going to keep
updated by the way shout out to the team
uh helping us have the stats and data we
would normally have if we were at home
and pulling up game databases ourselves
but we're sitting on a couch and uh
enjoying ourselves here in madrid so we
don't we don't have it and our team is
helping us with the with these uh
game references
carl hasn't said it a couple of times
here he's clearly remembering his file
yeah
and i wonder what he's going to do
because c4
i wouldn't necessarily call it a threat
but it is something that needs to be
addressed
and it's like he brought his knight out
to g3 okay that i mean that's pretty
logical right and fabi probably needs to
respond to that by moving his bishop
wow what a game this has been already 21
moves of preparation
and we'll see who gets phased first and
bobby has not responded instantly so
that indicates perhaps that he's out of
his preparation or what i'd like to tell
people right is slow down and pretend
like you don't know what's going on it's
already too late they're top 10 players
in the world like you're not going to
fool anybody but sometimes actually
slowing down is a good psychological
tool
because that way you kind of give your
opponent this false sense of confidence
and any sort of subjective
feeling typically is not good for your
chest
because you want to remain objective so
if you can make your opponent feel
like they have
everything under control and you're
uncertain i feel like that could be a
psychological ploy
yeah and it's more convincing when it
happens in the 21st move
than when it happens on the third
yeah okay
there's that coffee
yeah he's sipping that coffee or water
he's a bit of a magician as we've seen
he trades and changes
back and forth but it's interesting
psychologically that
you think even at the top level slowing
down being a little deliberate in your
approach robert it's maybe sends a
message i mean even these guys are you
know they're humans and they're they're
thinking a little bit about well is he
still in prep is he not here hikaru has
uh has yet to slow down and bobby is the
first person taking a think i have a
story on that note yeah uh this was told
to me by my old coach
there was a big open tournament and uh
grand master mikhail gurvich was playing
a game sort of noted opening expert
and at one point this is around move 20.
i don't remember who he was playing but
uh gurvich left the board
and went into this incredibly long think
and he thought for an hour he was gone
from the board for like 45 minutes when
he came back
uh he played a very strong move
so his opponent figured that he was you
know meditating outside
and uh he had exited his preparation in
reality he was still in his preparation
she just got locked in the bathroom
stall
so
he finally came out you could make that
very strong move
that is hilarious oh gosh well i think
fabiono he that seems like sincere
calculation seems like perhaps his
analysis at home has come to an end but
i'm also interested in the top right we
have to be right it's yonder palm and
she's game against dingley wren but i
feel like i'm watching a david paravian
rapid chess championship game because
remind me
i mean donya and i have commented so
many of these that stems from a scotch
and you don't see the scotch at the
highest level um i know danny i i you
looked right at me as you said that no
but you must be thrilled i i am thrilled
i'm always excited when there may be a
variation that isn't just bad for white
it's an opening of your own heart yeah
and it actually is a very solid approach
right so um unlike the game between
fabiano hikaru where there's material
imbalance which inherently carries risk
in the position in the top right hand
side screen you see white's pieces all
aimed towards the king side not a single
weak pawn i mean that b2 pawn was under
attack but the knight came back to d1 to
protect the pawn and no pins on that
knight so i think that yonder pompsie
he's not playing just to draw but he's
certainly trying to eliminate or highly
reduce losing chances yep
i want to clarify something i said
earlier for the more studious of fans
who are
following the candidates not just for
the the bad jokes and the and the
stories about getting locked in bathroom
stalls uh but for those following the uh
the theory is uh
the well now it's now it's not relevant
because we switch boards but i wanted to
make a point that in in the fabiano game
i was confused about the stats so
you were right that bishop five was new
in that game from caruana in that game
there was actually was queen d6 that was
new but why i was confused is because
fabiano also has experience on the white
side of this game a game from this year
in 2022 where he played against jordan
von forest as well and so confusing
again but officially the move c5 by
caruana was the first novelty on the
board by fabi so even though hikaru
responded without too much of a think
that is officially the new move so all
right now we can move on to yonder palm
rishi's scotch versus dingley run
because i do want to look at it
especially because it is an opening
after my own heart as robert said so h6
now on the board and white has a choice
to trade into the end game with bishop
takes f6 an endgame where white has a
better structure but black has the
bishop here
uh or
keep the pin with but you have to be
very careful in some of these positions
if you back up because black will strike
g5 if you let them
in fact we're going to see the end game
following the david paravian school
and
he grabs the queen now an interesting
wrinkle
uh in regards to the sound game that
knight on d1 i might be missing the mark
here but
i don't remember this maneuver being all
that common napo plays the move i think
he played b3
and the point is to free up that knight
and that knight is going to head
probably for f5 but you're absolutely
right robert it's very very clear to me
that
it's more important for nepo not to lose
this game
than to win it i mean he'd like to win
it but
i don't see ding losing the send game
i'm going to say that right here and
right now right but
as we're discussing the good news for
yon is he could play for two results
right if ding just plays good stable
chess
then
ding will make a draw and like you said
you don't see them losing the game but
there's no chance young palm tree loses
this game or i would i mean i can't bet
i don't bet but i would be willing to
bet quite a hefty sum of money that
gianna pompeo does not lose because it's
an end game where he is the better
structure as we were talking there's no
weaknesses and wow
that's not a move you see every day no
this is actually a fascinating endgame
and
f5 is he trying to push the i think he's
trying to push the pawn to f4 and force
y10 because jan could play knight e3
and then after f4 the knight would jump
into f5 and we could see an opposite
colored bishop end game
jan responds without hesitation note
that it was you almost had to bring the
knight there now because if black got
that pawn to f4 while the knight was
still on d1 that actually
might be very bad for white so i think
we're going to see the obstacle bishop
ending and unfortunately for dingley ren
if he was hoping for more of a fight
we'll look at this we're going very
quickly into a position that
is not going to yield very many winning
chances for either player whoa you don't
think this has already occurred in
one of ding's games
yeah from the 2019 world cup which is
qualified for the previous candidates
but i mean when we look at this position
it's not actually just like a dead draw
because black has these double isolated
f-pawns and the c6 d5 pawns are on light
squares which means that white can kind
of chase those pawns up the board and i
think people would think let's put our
pawns in the opposite color of our enemy
bishop but as soon as you do that you
open up all diagonals the bishop becomes
a powerful piece the bishop on d6
staring into its own pawn not quite
necessarily as good or doesn't have the
same prospects as that bishop on f5 so
white slightly better of course the
position remains in the balance it's i
should say is balanced not remains in
the balance but uh
everything remains in the balance
exactly it is a position where look at
this even after trading off the double
isolated pawn you still are going to be
left with split pawns in the king side
so white should be slightly better
so you mentioned the game that ding
played previously this game is actually
still following that love session versus
dingley run battle from the world cup in
2019 the tournament that qualified tamer
over jabba into the candidates beating
dingley ren in that final so what little
chess historical three years ago yeah it
feels like three lifetimes ago with what
has happened
i mean seriously right it's just bananas
but
g3 played dingley run comes back almost
looked like he was about to instantly
respond
quickly looks up at nepo there maybe
trying to gauge
where nepo is coming from i mean if
you're if you're
so let's talk about the tournament
standings right we know that this means
that yonda pomnishi with the half point
lead over fabiano caruana
came in with the white piece i'm not
saying he's just
playing for a draw robert but he's
certainly playing not to lose in in in a
game like this right yeah
and it does look very equal so we should
say that very clearly um and as we look
at the settings here he's in first place
but he plays five minute car one with
the black pieces next round so if he
believes i mean think about this he wins
the tournament if they both keep their
separation and he doesn't lose the
fabiano so he must very adamantly
believe that he's not going to lose the
fabiano he's confident himself in which
case forced fabiano to win elsewhere and
favan has the black piece against ikaro
nakamura so yon's by looking at those
pairings like yeah i don't really think
that he's going to beat a car with black
then i don't think he's going to beat me
so i will keep my half point lead going
into the last five rounds of the event
so i can understand it from jan's
perspective and i also think that in a
situation like this you should never
just assume your opponent is playing for
a draw i actually played gregory
kaidanov who is you know a fantastic
player
often said like the best player to never
have won a u.s championship and the
person who told me that story about the
bathroom but go on i told you by the
bathroom it all comes together my story
with gregory is we played a game and i
was doing well in the tournament as is
around robin and so i didn't really need
to win but i just played a position and
he said after the game he realized a
little bit too late that i wasn't
playing to make a draw i was just
playing to get a position and it was one
where i was pretty comfortable so you
never want to assume your opponent is
playing for result because then you take
your mind off the entire board and as i
keep saying you need to remain objective
you can't just sleep on the position
can't get complacent you always have to
be calculating so i mean dingle runs not
doing that clearly he's spending quite a
bit of time even though he's the one
who's played this position before so
he's making sure he does not fall asleep
at the board not literally but in terms
of jan's winning chances
well said and we'll see whether jan
really wants to fight for a win or not
we'll check back in with this in a
little bit but let's head back out and
uh remind everybody that we have four
games going on here
in round eight from madrid
ali reza ferrugia over there
focused in he's got a battle with tame
over java
for us to be viewing here today and uh
an interesting
kind of italian structure and then we've
got this trade on e6
yeah and early bishop e6 yeah in the
sense that you know you normally see
this move after black is already castled
now you could transpose to
a more common position if both sides
castle but white has some options here i
mean there's
more stuff on the menu you could play
queen b3 and target that on early
full disclosure
i don't understand these positions at
all and
you know a lot of players don't
i mean this is a position that that must
be interested because there are so many
move orders here
you know anybody will tell you it's
almost impossible to memorize the theory
right so which is why you pick out the
contours or the outlines the semi-open
f-file can be great for the black work
once you castle
a7 helping you that bishop 187 is
chilling back there right the open
diagonal that with the f7 pawn out of
the way queen e8 to g6 or h5 a knight h5
maneuver so we can see that black has
gained some benefits for the cost of the
double pawns which you know they seem
like they're hard to get to but
oftentimes white just starts putting
pressure like you said with a queen b3
you can push on the queen side because
you already have your pawn out on b4 so
i tend to think that in the long run
white should have an advantage
structurally speaking but in the short
term you have to parry off all these
threats down the king's side
by the way bishop takes e6 on move 10
was a novelty by olympus perugia
she's thinking it doesn't seem
intentional i was going to say i don't
think it's
um but whoops
but it was it was a novelty as far as
the official move order goes um
farrugia as as a fan obviously a lot of
people have you know been just wanting
wanting foruji to catch fire right so
many people rooting for him salivating
at the idea of a world championship
match between the rising superstar who's
breaking records in magnus carlson but
for from your perspective one of the uh
conversations we've been having what has
been your take on on ferocious form
maybe you know just some things that
haven't seemed to be going right for him
at this point
well
first of all you know i'm sure that
farouza himself is his own worst critic
so there's going to be the monday
morning quarterbacks to say that he did
this wrong you did that wrong i think
alirez is aware that he's not playing as
well as he would have hoped
and you know knowing him knowing his
approach he went into this tournament
wanting to win it believing that he
could win it you could tell from the
very first rounds that something just
wasn't clicking
and you know i always talk about this uh
when i stream it's usually when
something goes wrong at this level
it's not usually one thing right it's a
compilation of a million little details
maybe some of the opening preparation
didn't go his way maybe it was a little
bit too passive
uh the game against cecaro for example
that was some really impressive prep but
the line is very jarg to begin with and
maybe he underestimated his opponent's
ability to improvise on the spot so
there's a lot of things
you know that that might have went wrong
to a very small extent but taken
together
you know they've produced what has so
far been a disappointing result without
question right
interesting and that's it's a good thing
for i think people remember right it's
uh not only for the monday morning
quarterbacks but usually there's more
than meets the eye right and none of us
know all all the things but right and
it's and i really want to have it's not
just one thing right you can't just
point his tactics are bad because that's
often what people want to hear it's
never like that right
well we see him thinking here and one of
the things that of
the many things as you've said has kind
of been his his clock management right
there's been some questionable moments
where you just wonder at some point if
he's if he's in his own head um think
overthinking things but okay it's very
early to go back to that
storyline here right now he's maybe just
assessing a structure that he knows is
about to have a lot of flexibility in
life but not a single pawn having been
traded on the board so all right we'll
let we'll let the youngster think about
it as we back up and maybe head over to
the really i guess the one other game we
haven't looked at yet is report duda um
again we started by looking at the
jacket so i felt like we had already
looked at i mean that jacket might be
all we need to talk about for the day
that thing i think we need to talk about
that pawn on b3 but that's secondary i
do that too
all right
it looks like a normal position where
like the dgt board messed up and the
pawns on b3 rather than b2 yeah exactly
yeah how did the pawn get there
he decided to put it there i think he
moved it from b2 but i'm not sure
i appreciate that
that would be that would be the
hypothesis
but why
uh
he played the move 8b3
a guy that um
has had some openings
opening questions is that the
politically correct way to say it i
don't know there's no politics involved
there's no politics at all to say that
report is not known for the depth of his
opening preparation he is the first to
admit that and i think b3 was just to
stop black from continuing to push over
there and that seems like the only
explanation i can come up with yeah he's
not being kettling his bishop i i think
that's safe
to uh deduce yeah he um played h3 to
stop a piece from going to g4 and he can
fianchetto at some point but
i think he's just trying to make moves
and that's kind of his style we're
talking about
on one hand you say oh this person
doesn't play the most challenging
openings they're not a theoretician
but that means that they can also just
dabble with anything right they just
play and they're trying to get positions
like this they want you two knights
turned king's indian attack
and when you get a position where you're
it's neutral territory report likely
feels like he can outplay anybody and he
did that to ali reza faruja early in the
event he didn't win the game but in the
end game where already decided to seek
activity rather than play passively
report had what was in a winning
advantage according to the evaluation
bar it's something that he probably
should have won so he's shown he's
capable of outplaying people just from a
neutral position one where neither side
has preparation and i think that's
clearly what he's aiming for is just to
get a game because yesterday he didn't
get a game right he was playing his
opponent was using preparation based on
engine prep so now he's like let's just
let's just play let's figure this out
over the board now that we see this
position we suddenly realize we actually
have two games with the four knights in
the same round not quite the legendary
grand swiss
moment with uh players playing deeply
into theory right next to each other uh
but if we if we back up to the bird's
eye view we now know that we have a four
nights in of course the aldi reza
ferrugia game versus tamar bajaba as
well as
this
now king's indian attack from before
nights in report duda so
anyway not doesn't happen all the time
right wait no it's not
well a nepo oh the netball game yeah
that was the fourth scotch
gotcha i almost believed you there for a
second
i mean we still have four nights on the
board you know java perugia that's what
you meant
yeah
and we have some interesting favorite
hasn't moved right yeah so he's
definitely not faking
at this point no i mean this would be
quite the uh quite the dedicated
faking thinking for 15 minutes
no i think fabiano in the bottom
left-hand side of our screens here his
game against takara nakamura
you know he's he's frozen because he's
calculating and it's still early in the
round so it's a good time to start
thinking especially when you've already
played 20 plus moves you know you're
nearing the time patrol but yeah you do
not want to go wrong right now that's
for sure
yeah yeah he's deep in thinking again
even though he was the one who played
the first novelty hikaru's immediate
response
has fabi taken taken to think here
knight to g3 was the move after fabiano
pushed the c5 pawn the c7 pawn to c5
but he's got the favi perch going right
i feel like this isn't like a fabi who
feels surprised right or even maybe
maybe not confident about his position
but i think it's more like robert said
calculating really ensuring that he's
going to take this game down the path
that he wants
yeah i mean he believes given his form
that he can surmount as he himself said
difficult challenges right and right now
he has one of those
challenges where he has to figure out
where and whether to move that bishop on
five bishop g4 bishop g6 this might not
seem
uh like it impacts the position but
you've got to understand at this level
one little inaccuracy and you might lose
all of your winning chances for the rest
of the game so abby senses the gravity
of the moment and he would rather take
a little bit longer and err on the side
of caution
yeah
all right well i i think we're actually
going to throw to a break uh sooner
rather than later here to
fix and align some of the things that
have been going on here for us behind
the scenes in madrid and with chess.com
servers so again for those of you
who maybe had trouble with that this
morning we apologize but things are back
online we're super excited about the
action that is going to occur here in
madrid a lot like the live action
occurring in el retiro a park where
people gather to play giant chess blitz
chess all kinds of stuff don't go
anywhere chess.com coverage of round
eight for the 2022 feeding candidates is
only just beginning
chess kid is fun
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kit is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
although saddled with the lowest rating
in the field jan schistov duda has been
playing well heading into the candidates
the 24 year old from poland also brings
a solid record against magnus carlsen
should duda manage to win it all here in
madrid and challenge for the world title
the second youngest player in the field
defeat a world cup to secure his bid
here at the candidates
i think he must have resigned yep
it's over yawn fist of duda beats magnus
with black in the tiebreaker what a
performance
duda enters the candidates with some
steam recently taking both the oslo
esports cup and the grand chess tour in
poland
his success against carlson makes duda a
pretty interesting story to watch
especially should he get through madrid
amongst his triumphs duda stopped
carlson's 120
game undefeated streak two years ago in
norway
he also beat carlson in his world cup
victory that punched his ticket to spain
with some momentum and big match
experience duda is looking to become the
first player from poland to challenge
for the world chess championship
time will tell if he can pull it off
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my is
[Music]
[Applause]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here is almost as old as
the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess
continues to thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
[Music]
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
[Music]
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back in madrid round eight of
the 2022 feeding candidates doing a
quick reset here grand master robert
hess on the end grand master daniel
niraditsky
danny ranchier we are super excited
we've got all four games in progress and
plenty of chess ahead for those of you
who've been with us from the wee hours
this morning we appreciate your patience
as uh we've we've been
working through some some big stuff huge
shout out to the crew working super hard
to get not just chess.com servers back
online but the amount of awesome things
they just pulled together given the
massive technical crashes we had super
super happy and proud of them so again
uh thank you for being with us lucky for
you some of you were tuning in you're
like i know what he's talking about
looks like we got a great day ahead good
for you we do
all right uh we're back where we
normally are boys and uh
i think we should go we got we gotta
head back to that game right there right
the nakamura battle versus fabiano
caruana
is a position robert what did you call
it the break it's not a three result
position it's a seven result position go
ahead yeah it feels like any both
players could lose at the same time both
legs can win i have no idea what maybe
they get in a fight
look at this right black has these four
pawns along the fifth rank right so very
advanced pawns restricting white's
pieces but we still have that dynamic
that we were discussing earlier there's
a knight and a dark square bishop for
white for a rook and two of those pawns
the d and e pods so of course the bishop
on d3 is currently under attack we
expect flavano will not just blunder it
and he should probably protect it with
one of his pawns whether that's e4 c4
not the easiest question to answer so
you know fabinho has difficult questions
ahead for him and it carol look at his
clock yeah
all of a sudden it's a 30 minute lead
yeah that's no laughing matter yeah i
mean another 20 minutes and fabio will
have burned through
half of his time the only good thing
donnie i guess they have made a lot of
moves right so how do you how do you
think about the way you manage your time
from here you played 22 moves you've got
an hour and 23 minutes if you're fobby
dania are you already thinking about
time pressure are you just thinking
about
executing on this complicated position
yeah i think that for me
that moment starts to come when you hit
half of your time remaining
um of course because there's no
increment the first 60 moves i think uh
the players are probably quite a bit
more paranoid about their clock
management and probably for good reason
but right now there's as robert pointed
out this huge decision do you play c4 or
do you play e4 and those situations when
you have two tempting candidate moves
are among the hardest
challenges to solve at the chessboard
yeah
to to also set the macro for everyone
here donya because we obviously had a
lot going on at the beginning of the
show we weren't able to analyze so much
the opening this is a
theoretical battle it was until
fabiano's novelty i'm just going to show
it on the board real quick which was
this move 20 c5
but then
hey carlo responds right away and we've
got an imbalance of two miners versus a
rook so just how complicated is this
this battle we're about to see
well tremendously complicated and on
every dimension material wise you have a
rook and two pawns
for two pieces from a purely
materialistic standpoint it's like half
an extra material point for the side of
the rook right the thing is when you
have four minor pieces against two in
the middle game the minor pieces often
prevail simply due to their
power when they're well coordinated and
just due to their shear ability
uh but in this specific situation there
is a very small wrinkle pretty
insignificant uh black has four pawns
basically in the center it's not really
important or anything and all of them
could essentially be pushed at any time
basically so that's dominated
complicated slightly complicates the
scenario you may be wondering what the
knight is doing on b7
it is uh like the appendix it's
vestigial it used to be performing a
very important duty of
defending the c5 pawn so
for me an appeal of the move c4 is that
it would open up a little perch for the
knight
on c5 so that would be uh a plus of the
move c4 a plus of the move e4
is that it would chase the knight away
from f3 and the knight doesn't have that
d4 square so
it would create quite an uncomfortable
dilemma i think for that night but
you know robert i don't know if i if i
describe this dilemma accurately
yeah you know you mentioned append
appendices already on the show so that's
a pretty impressive but no it's just a
dynamic that i think is difficult to
figure out right you for fabiano he
probably feels like he's in his general
ballpark of preparation for hikaru it's
very clear that he's still there or he
thinks he's still there
because it's there's sometimes when you
get a novelty
you may just play it the same way you
would play against a different move not
necessarily recognizing differences and
it's not to you know say anything
negative about the players but you just
always get in this mindset where i'm 25
moves deep not recognizing that actually
my opponent might have misstepped or
played something new well let's i mean
robert is alluding to something i'm just
going to dive right into talking about
it because it was mentioned live on the
broadcast
by raunak sadhwani meaning our chess.com
india coverage said that he thought
there's a possibility here that both
players might be doing exactly what
roberts just talked about perhaps
confusing a little bit of their prep and
i'm going to show the line here so ranox
said that after c5
the the sharper maybe more challenging
line for ricardo was bishop to g5
and after bishop g5 rook dde8 there's
this crazy move rook takes e5 oh my
lands and bishop f4 yeah and after rook
takes e5 bishop of f4
and that this is
this is actually the best way for white
to play for an advantage and again there
these players may have super computers
at home that ran for longer i don't know
but i think round rock is on to
something here because even a move like
rook to e8 can be met by 95
rookie 5
and here you can just add more pressure
to the pin with queen g3 so
so rounduck is saying that's the
possibility and that because the the
point is that the move the move knight
to g3
is actually the best move for white not
on c5
but on rook to e8
that's when knight g3 is the mainland so
the fact that hikaru immediately
responded to c5 with knight g3
i don't know it's a fun line and
certainly this idea of bishop g5 danya
does seem like it was very dangerous
because
is there a concrete way to deny
roundup's findings here this looks like
just a really straightforward line and
there's a really cute uh finale if you
go to the end of that line after bishop
f4 kind of a darkly ironic detail for
black is if black goes rookie too which
looks like a very creative way of
getting out of the pin yeah you might
think oh well if queen takes c2 then
black simply takes on f4 but you don't
stop there because at the end white
takes on d5 and forks that very same
knight on b7 which is starting to cause
black problems in uh the real game as
well apparently this is why you don't
need your appendix robert right there
exactly
exactly well that appendix will be
removed
it actually seems like black needs it in
this yeah
anyway so interesting stuff there right
and who knows but i think robert you
were talking about it we also saw
not the exact same thing but we saw a
player maybe play too fast and confuse
lines against hikaru in a different game
right yonder pomeshi i hear it's not
necessary fabi who played too fast or
confused lines but maybe hikaru missed
his chance and we were complimenting
yondapanji yesterday at the end of you
know that whole variation when richard
decided to play on when the queen took
on f8 what john did was slow down and
think do i take with the king or the
bishop on fade yeah it didn't seem to
matter in that position but it clearly
matters in this game today yeah so when
players are in their preparation they
like to just blitz out the moves but
again it's one of these situations where
you you probably thought he was with
this preparation he trusted fabiano to
still be making the computer optimal
moves and when fabiano actually
misstepped
his car wasn't able to capitalize
because he was playing so quickly so now
we're in a position that's really
complicated i just want to throw out one
more thing is we're talking about c4
we're i want e4's way to keep the bishop
on d3 one other move that is coming to
my mind is bishop to c4 because i really
like the placement of black's pawns and
i would kind of consider pushing my
d-pawn as well so bishop c4 is maybe the
most flexible approach from just
deciding which pawn you eventually want
to move but i like this move too because
then
if you take you're taking with the b
pawn right and then you still have d4
coming in a lot of positions right and
you know it's not the end of the story
but i'm just trying to get a pawn mass
and get them rolling
upon mass as uh our weatherman would say
if he was on the telestrator there's a
pawn storm moving in through the mid the
midwest
uh yeah and through the east coast under
the west coast
you're in madrid uh a potential pawn
storm on board here uh for fabiano
caruana
oh man
well uh bobby is thinking he's down
more than a half an hour on the clock
right now he's been thinking for 15
minutes on just this move
let's back up and take a look at the
other three games in progress his
uh his tournament leader i say hi i was
about to say like uh the person he's
chasing his king yonda pam mushi not
playing uh quite as uh quite as fighting
chess over there versus dingley wren uh
this is a game that they put it mildly
okay for for with all due respect it
seems very clear that yon came to the
board here today if not wanting a draw
donya uh
at least
at least not not disappointed with the
draw either yeah i think we should call
a spade a spade and now at the same time
you know
i don't like to automatically begrudge
a player this kind of play because there
might be a ton of considerations
that you know
kind of hide behind the surface and one
of those
i was thinking about during the break is
let's not forget that this is the first
game of the second half of the
tournament the first day of the rest of
your life
and you know jan has been susceptible to
nerves in the past
and i think it may be important to him
maybe even more important more
significant than to the other players to
not lose that first game
of the second half robert i feel like
you weren't that convinced by my
argument so i will let you have the
floor here and
you know uh smash this to bits no i i
think it's a fair point of course right
and uh jan apology has the lead i was
already mentioning earlier that he
believes that he can withstand the
fabiano carwanas pressure when he gets
black and fabiano but it's so early in
the tournament with respect to those two
players not everyone else is far behind
so that's going to be a struggle for
them you know mathematically speaking
they're not eliminated but they're
getting close but with respect to five
minute car one i just don't feel like
you can just call it a day and say yeah
you know i'll keep my half point lead at
all times and i think that kind of
mailing it in especially when you're
coming off victories like jan is he
seemed like he
kind of
shakily drew a game and was worse he
just won a couple games so he should be
feeling great he has four wins and three
draws so i don't think there's any
reason to like
press that panic button in advance well
let me ask you is there another reason
for this let's not forget that it's not
just that he's starting the first day of
the rest of his life in the second half
the game tomorrow may be the most
important game he has left in the entire
second half of the tournament he faces
the man chasing him fabiano caruana with
the black pieces
i i'm not saying he doesn't have a team
of seconds right now working somewhere
in madrid we won't call up the hotel
you're staying at right
but is there something to maybe at least
being more well-rested maybe having a
little bit extra time psychologically
had to see how that
day that game circled on his calendar
and maybe maybe he's already thinking
about that robert
but he beat dingley around with the
white pieces and the candidates that
started in 2020 right it's not like he
has never beaten ding he can't beat ding
right he's proven that he can he had a
really nice game so why not try that's
the thing is i you know i can't fault
him he is the leader and the points
you're making are great ones that he
wants to be as well-rested as possible
he doesn't want to stress i mean he's
about to make straight by the way yeah
that's basically this is yes
this is a draw for sure and so i i can't
fault him and his team they probably
know what's best for yon he did win the
last candidate so i trust their strategy
how to win the candidates uh but at the
same time you have the white pieces and
the form he's shown in this tournament
is one where if he's not taking
unnecessary risks there's difference
between forcing a draw and getting a
position where you're not really at risk
like what yon just of duda did against
hikari yesterday that was just really
nice play out of the opening where he
was playing either to win if a car
stumbled or as a car played well make a
draw so i feel like that would have been
more appropriate if you will for today's
game but i don't fault the team at all
they have a strategy i guess it is a
marathon not a sprint
right i last question i'll ask on this
before we move on from this game and
frankly maybe never come back
i think the players are about somebody
about you
anyway um they're about to repeat is
there any risk in a loss of momentum
donna so let's say that robert's right
and then he should have played for a win
not just because he was white but
because he's been playing well
if if that latter part is true because
you're playing well
and now you basically throw in the towel
on a game
[Laughter]
because ding i think ding was just
trying to shake hands and say all right
all right we get that it's a drug but
yeah like no no no no
what are you doing yeah no he just
offered it he's like we need to repeat
to make it official there it is
but okay i think you're asking the right
question and here's an interesting point
danny to consider yeah if young loses
tomorrow to fabi
in and of itself
that result let's say fabby draws today
if napo loses tomorrow
shout out to you anish anish we know
you're at home we love you what's up
anish say hi to dan say hi to daniel for
me
so go ahead
so
if he loses the fabulou tomorrow in and
of itself it wouldn't be a disastrous
result he don't he'd still be in second
place he'd only be trailing half a point
the same situation that fabi's in right
now
but i think in the context of today's
draw he would really eat you know he
would really
scold himself for taking this draw
retroactively so one of the dangers of
playing like he did today
is that if he has a disappointing result
tomorrow
he might blame
the decision that he made today if that
makes sense yeah
it totally makes sense exactly what i
was thinking might be the story then of
course we still have so much other chess
to talk about fabiano still has his own
mess of a situation to figure out versus
sakura nakamura by the way he has played
c4 as the choice to protect the bishop
on d3 um
and if you're just tuning in there's
already been a lot of storyline in that
game it's really kind of the marquee
matchup of today the last time the two
americans will face off here in madrid
uh but also was there deep and confused
prep deep and confused title of my
autobiography um
robert we're gonna we're gonna head back
over to this game again because i'm not
sure that uh
that there's any game that's more
exciting or more important than this
right here
and fabi's decision to push c4 yes and
after c4 the bishop on b3 is obviously
under attack while the bishop one d3 is
defended and what a car is trying to
figure out is do i want to trade light
square bishops because that bishop on d3
is a thorn in his side right it is
covering many important squares the rook
can never go back to f1 it covers the f5
square if you ever had ideas of bringing
a knight in that direction
but at the same time dania made this
point earlier that when you have this
imbalance of rook against couple minor
pieces that uh trading minor pieces that
could open up more files it can open up
more possibilities for the rooks so
actually keeping the bishop on the board
with bishop to d1 does make a lot of
sense
but it's kind of an awkward move to play
because bishop c2 that forces the
bishops off and after i think the trade
um maybe in some of where the knight is
coming to c5 and that knight's coming
into d3 so you've gotten rid of one
annoying piece on d3 and here comes the
next yeah makes sense and bishop to d1
i think you'd rather have the bishop
here than the knight absolutely but yes
oh 100 but at the same time it's a thorn
as you pointed out robert bishop d1 what
would that potentially be meant by black
has the pawns but i want to go back to a
point ganya made earlier which is
they're really great right now where
they stand they're they're sort of like
whips keeping back the lions right that
are the minor pieces they're they're
they're keeping them where they stand
but every time you push them you open up
more opportunities for those pieces more
squares more holes
so so what's your plan here is black
yeah i mean another thing that should be
pointed out is if you play knight c5
here and you think let me get to e4
uh then i think there's after knight c5
there's knight takes e5 so yes the pawns
are
well defended but the queen isn't the
greatest defender it can easily get
overload and here you not only lose the
pawn you also lose the rook that's the
cherry on top
so the night on b7 is is actually quite
a serious problem for black it has no
no job and so the the burden of the
position is transferred onto the heavy
pieces but the heavy pieces can be
pretty easily targeted by whites minor
pieces bishop g5 knight takes c5 is a
recurring theme in these positions and
white could even consider a timely b2b4
in order to cement
that c5 square and further tie down the
black knight so it's kind of just hard
to make a move here or black i love that
idea because i was just about to suggest
rook to e8 for black to defend e5
because if white is to make you know a
passing move now maybe you can go for
dania's idea of knight c5 since 95 could
be met by rook takes e5 but then maybe
b4 is actually a really nice idea
because it keeps the knight out of that
square note everybody just because you
can on passant doesn't always mean you
should although wait a second yes it
does
is is there okay no it's too much
white's getting a lot cause even on this
actually wait i can maybe win my piece
back yeah knight takes e4 oh that's a
nice move
and then bishop takes b3 and uh okay
you're just coming to life here yeah and
if de you can take the queen on d6 and
thereby free yourself from the fork
yeah okay
so b4 that's a that's a nice idea danya
it keeps that that keeps that horse a
donkey
thank you danny
that's very very nice of you to say
it's funny though because b4 it's a
really nice move keeping that knight
stuck in place or pawn three squares
away for a night dominates it this is a
really good example of that but what's
white's plan right we can appreciate
some of the ideas in white's position or
at least some of the pieces but what is
the actual plan because the bishop on d1
doesn't really look like it's going
anywhere if its future is just a trade
for the bishop on d3
maybe that's fine but doesn't look you
know threatening and so can black just
sort of sit on the position like fabiano
the the pawn structure in the center
everything is looking good so maybe he
just doesn't need to touch anything just
shuffle his pieces it's really hard for
humans to do that but i think anyone in
this tournament is capable of realizing
that i should just sit and wait
it's fabiano because the position does
look good but as soon as you push a pawn
you leave a square behind so i think
that probably don't believe in this
position we have my camera right there
he doesn't look like a guy who is
particularly stressed out right now
okay
interesting well
if anyone can sit on the position it's
probably fabiano fabiano gave his
thoughts on whether he thinks anyone
else has a chance to catch him in yondu
pamishi he was very careful in his words
but he joined us in studio yesterday and
we want to check in on his thoughts
after his epic victory versus tame over
job off last night
i mean i don't want to
you know say anything too speculative
but it seems like nearly
nearly 100 chance that one of us will
win the tournament right um
because yeah i
two points lead
uh for the rest of the field
um it's kind of difficult to to surmount
that
so but again i guess crazier things have
happened yeah in the history of chess
but yeah it does it does feel like um
like pretty much two horse race
interesting stuff there right i mean
he's
he he's not letting himself get ahead of
himself but he's right right i mean
right now it is a two horse race and if
he gets a win here in this mess of a
position where hicaro has just as many
winning chances as he does he would
actually be tying yon for first here in
madrid so
that's a crazy thought and then they're
if only they'd be playing tomorrow
oh my god it's almost like it was
scripted what did the kids say scripted
yeah if only they had that battle
totally they had their battle in this
place oh believe they were tied we'll
see
yeah yeah doesn't want that script go
ahead
well jan is welcoming the next game
right because he just put this one aside
and i wonder what fabiano thinks about
that because we asked fabiano yesterday
you know when richard lost did you feel
emotional did it impact your play and he
said well i thought that you know
essentially richard went kind of just
couldn't believe what richard did but it
didn't impact the way he was playing and
so i wonder if today's a different story
or if it's more the same where he looks
he sees jan makes a quick draw that may
actually give him some relief because
john had the white pieces so going into
today the worst nightmare is jan makes
use of the first move advantage and wins
against dingley round like he did in the
previous candidates with the white
pieces and like he beat dingleren in
round one of this very tournament so now
he doesn't have to worry about it like
okay i can make the draw
and still be in the same
spot i was coming into today and that's
probably actually a relieving feeling
yeah that's interesting any any chance
it also makes you a little more
aggressive because you want that tied
that tied score headed into tomorrow's
battle danya yeah i mean i'll put it
this way he's focusing 99.9 of his
efforts on this position but i'm sure
he's aware of how the young game
finished and right again these these
players are semi-human i don't want to
call them fully human
so these thoughts do creep into your
mind whether you like it or not you know
if i win then all of a sudden it's tight
i got white against jan tomorrow maybe
he's not so confident
you know all of this stuff starts
entering your mind and it can absolutely
you know make you more inclined to take
risks but robert you pointed this out
earlier
fabi is known for his objectivity i mean
he plays the position
all the time and that's honestly what
makes him really tough to play he's i've
got a concrete line that might actually
back up what you're saying that maybe he
was willing to push for more let's let's
analyze real quick because the e4 move
that uh was also an option
for fabiano
in this position might have led to a
really forcing line here with e4 knight
to g5 let's bring up our analysis board
as soon as we can here guys
we've got
knight to g5 knight to a5
knight 5 takes e4
bishop takes e4
knight takes e4 knight takes b3
and after a takes b3 d takes e4 the game
is petering out super quickly
to maybe a drawn rook end game i think
there weren't enough captures
consecutively yeah
takes takes takes take sticks i mean i'm
not a car i'm not hit karu but uh but i
did did do a line there with a lot of a
lot of captures and okay i don't know
that this is the case but it's a pretty
straightforward line on e4
and if you want more you do want to keep
some life to this position maybe that's
partly why he went for the c4 but after
e4 then i can also go to h4 which where
it aims for the f5 square okay and
that's not to claim that white is
suddenly better it just is a different
position so i i feel pretty confident
that fabiano wasn't saying oh i have
this position where i can essentially
force a draw let me not go for that i
think he was looking at the alternatives
and be like well i don't actually see
exactly how i equalize or maybe i don't
like giving those knights access to f5
just yet because the bishop one d3 is
cut off from that square because the
pawn e4 is in the way so i think that's
more likely the case that he just wasn't
certain about how to evaluate this
position okay
all right well we'll see we're all
speculating right now uh we're all we're
all going to back up real quick and take
a look there are three other games as we
said uh still going here in this round
yonder palm rishi if you're just tuning
in
drew his game very quickly despite
having the white pieces versus dingley
wren so he'll finish his candidates
battle versus china's number one one and
a half out of two not a bad score he
would have taken that coming in a big
part of why he's leading but still will
yan look back at a wasted opportunity
with the white pieces
at this point we can only speculate uh
where you want to go guys report duda
and for rouge over jabba for both do a
check-in um maybe maybe even a detailed
one we really haven't given those games
too much time yet um so while hikaru
thinks
all right you're not gonna choose i'm
gonna choose for you we're going to
report duda here we go look at that
jacket i knew you're going to be oh he's
wearing a red jacket i mean look at it
he's a rock star this guy
seriously they're only on move 11
which is kind of interesting
yeah rapport is uh
using his time hopefully wisely probably
remembering his deep opening prep
yep
non-existent preparation you draw the
sarcasm window above my head right there
i got you no i totally didn't detect
this that was yeah this position though
is really actually quite interesting not
because i believe in the current
position but white has put the king on
h2 right okay and in putting the king on
h2 that makes you think that f4 is
coming or some kind of side pawn push
eventually wants is what rapport wants
so
i'm into it from like the outline of the
position but i also think that duda is
doing everything like perfectly he just
put his pieces in the center he can
just continue to do so but i just don't
think that black has this plan four
moves down the line i feel like white is
thinking about moving tonight playing f4
things like that so at least i have one
plan and i'm not sure i see
a clear-cut plan for black yeah but i
don't know if i fully agree with that
because i think after rookie 8 well if
you move your knight from f3 then i
think black might be able to strike in
the center with d5
um
if you play bishop takes d4 i'm just
showing your line sorry go ahead yeah
and i i mean i didn't calculate that
seriously now after e takes d492 it can
be very tempting to go after the d4 pawn
um and my idea here was just to go queen
b6 and protect that pawn black can also
consider d5 even in this position and uh
i've played these types of openings a
lot in blitz from the white side
and
when the center opens up like this yeah
things get really uncomfortable
especially with the weakness of the dark
squares on the queen side really
exacerbating the situation at the same
time i get what you're saying robert uh
in the sense that white can play almost
a waiting move
like
i don't even know
a4 or something and it's it's not so
easy for black to improve
interesting but it is nice to see that
with the rook coming to e8
black is already thinking about d5
because the moment that pawn has support
suddenly this advances on the agenda
right that also hands over the b5 square
so it's like one of those things that
you have to be pretty careful about in
these positions because if you're
playing take back on d5 with the pawn
then the hands over the b5 square
precisely because the pawn's on a5 and
can't go back to a6 so there's like
these little nuances that play a huge
role in such a position and yeah i i
don't know
exactly what white's move is and maybe i
was being overly optimistic with white's
chances and you know how to proceed from
here but i guess just having the notion
of f4 feels like some kind of legitimate
try whereas d5 does feel a little bit
harder to get in but that is clearly
black's plan right you put upon c6
you're very likely to follow up with d5
and maybe some more queen side expansion
with b5 as well
all right well you said there's a lot of
little things in this position that play
a huge role richard report may end up
having played a huge role in yonda
pomerici's chances to win the candidates
not the huge role that he would have
written up for himself if he was casting
himself as a star in that movie he looks
like a movie star with his red jacket
and we of course love to see him back in
action already but let's uh show
everybody the interview that richard
report gave dina bell and kaya despite
despite his very heavy feelings
understandably so yesterday
i don't know i guess i should throw away
my computer because i'm pretty sure the
line is bishop g6 instead of bishop h3
queen takes a seven then bishop hd it's
a draw
so i figured i should be better here
because okay it was not so i should play
on but i played so badly
even afterwards i'm probably just worse
so i guess you know
i kind of treat myself i was trying to
figure this out like how to defend
afterwards but
i got really upset about this that i
played on
no one knows for what reason exactly and
positions clearly seems to interest i
guess there was better ways to play
because i don't think white is losing on
the spot yet but
i'm just started to play
i started to miss very strange things
i guess this happens yeah
again we said it yesterday
it was tough to watch but also awesome
you know that he's just so honest
because you love to see players when
they're honest not just when things are
going their way right when when you're
at you know at your worst at times right
and you're heartbroken with yourself and
i'm sure he
thankfully his wife is here with him in
madrid we've seen her and i'm sure you
know that was a tough a tough night but
uh
it's awesome when you see someone just
be honest and where where the the truth
on their sleeve like that yeah i guess
it goes with that saying it's better to
ask for forgiveness than permission yeah
because nobody else in the event would
have permitted him to play on there
can i do this guys
richard let's not and he's like he
clearly feels really badly yeah and he's
a sports person right he's a competitor
he wants to win right that was very
clear by his decision to play on so he
definitely feels badly that he lost the
game but i think more so that the way it
happened like i i really believe that
ultimately he feels badly for fabiano
and just the term as a whole but he
shouldn't like he was competing like he
did something that was a bad decision
nobody's going to deny that he's the
first to admit it but i don't think that
he should feel ashamed i don't think
that he should you know feel like your
chest isn't for him anymore it was just
a bad game and i think that he should
forgive himself and he's playing another
interesting game
well you probably shouldn't feel bad at
all i agree with you and and donya i'm
sure you do too and and what are your
thoughts on how every organizer should
be inviting this guy just because
despite
the fact that that is now viewed
rightfully so as a train wreck that
didn't go well and it may be a huge
thing that helps young palm when she win
the candidates it still just shows a lot
about who this guy is and his character
and the fire he brings exactly as both
of you are implying if we're you know
our biggest criticism is that he decided
to play for a win in a position where he
shouldn't and not a theoretical director
that says a lot about him in a in a
positive way that's the only thing we
can point out and richard has been like
this his entire chess career i mean if
you trace back uh his his career six or
seven
uh to six or seven years ago and his
openings were a lot crazier what he
plays now is very toned down i mean he
used to play c4 on g4 i mean he pushed
every single pawn on the first move and
uh and that's barely even an
exaggeration so richard has done a lot
of work to sort of reign himself in but
that lion
uh or that tiger you know choose the
fearsome animal yeah that's at the
center of
of his play style
uh is it makes him such a treat to watch
um and i think the the real litmus test
of whether somebody is fun to watch is
whether you still enjoy watching them
when they're when they're not in their
best form yeah i think for report
you know do you enjoy watching him when
he's having not so great of a tournament
i absolutely do and we still want to see
him come back even when he's not
performing at the level
uh that he expects of himself yeah
no totally well said and uh
i think that we're gonna see yet another
fight in this game he just played this
flexible a3 move and it's a move that is
designed guys to keep the tension right
uh it's not it's not a move like you
were maybe saying with a4 which would
even deny b5 that black could do now
this is this is an ultimate ultimately
very flexible hey i named the right pawn
you didn't have the right font and even
opens up weird ideas like b4 in some
positions where suddenly the a file
tactically
might have consequences if black doesn't
complete his development here so anyway
this is interesting and again
as we said the
the storyline surrounding report while
it is a heartbreaking one if you're if
you're sitting in his corner right now
ultimately i think we all have said it a
million times he is great for chess and
uh
and we'll see what kind of chess he's
able to play play here in the back half
and it's the opposite of a forcing game
right yeah zero piece have been traded
yeah not a single piece and that's why
the players have spent so much time and
richard in particular he's the one
trying to mix things up but dude has
spent half an hour himself it's only a
move 12. so clearly the players they
have no
at-home knowledge of this position they
are just going to figure out all over
the board yeah
you're going to drink some he's going to
take on f3 and then on e3
just like that two pieces will come up
finally
knight takes f3 check but
okay let's back up and uh get to the
only game that really hasn't been given
any attention so far that is ali reza
ferrugia's battle versus taymor bajaba a
very traditional looking italian over
there we've seen positions like this at
the top level a lot over the last few
years and uh
flexible offers interesting chances for
both sides
and uh
let's dive right in
this this is an interesting spot because
white is tactically trying to be very
aware of the potential dangers black has
on the f-file
i don't know enough about these italians
to comment here i wish we had a guy who
was with us in utah i think we all wish
we had fabiano carwana sitting next to
us right now well
this is reminiscent of a different world
championship the game that magnus
carlsen won against sergey karjakin
where we had a dynamic just like this
where there's pressure down the king
side but a worse pawn structure because
of the double pawn so it's clear that
the job of aiming for the f-file in
particular this knight on f3 is a little
bit loose so if you're not careful there
could be a night sacrifice on either g2
or even h3 in some positions but for now
everything's under control
for
alireza he can bring his rook from a2
towards the center i don't think you
want to start playing on the queen side
just yet right i think it'd be a rush
decision where
white's rooks are not connected there's
not as much coordination so if you start
playing on the queen set opening of
files it's black who is probably going
to reap the benefits
and piggybacking off of what you said
about the knight on f3 you often see the
move knight f3 to g1
in such positions and that prepares g3
ultimately white does want to push that
knight off of f4 the problem with that
is that black could immediately strike
with d5
and if you fall asleep i mean white's
center is not that well defended black
is really only two moves away i mean
rook a d8 is an idea and d5 d4
carving out an incredible outpost for
the knight is a very serious positional
threat black could even play that in
response to g3 yeah so right away yeah
yeah because if you take your you're
taking with check
and
maybe maybe the house is uh is crumbling
for white it's interesting because
the structure we've seen a lot sometimes
you still see other pieces on the board
we know that there was a bishop on this
diagonal that at some point was traded
for white's dark square bishop uh but
and we we know that the other bishops
left the board on e6
just looking at this position and you
can see the trade but the fact that
black already has the knight on f4
am i wrong again not being an italian
expert just playing one on tv sometimes
it feels like the type of position we
commentate a lot on guys but it feels
like black is like a move ahead or
something then you normally see am i
wrong about that maybe we should back up
and see how it
yeah i just i'm not sure it's about it
does kind of feel that way yeah but i
think it's not so much about the moves
unless you're finding some tactic that
will lead black to gain some material or
some kind of advantage because white has
stabilized right and rijaba's last move
is a curious one it was king to h8
and what could that possibly indicate
well perhaps he wants to play g5 at some
point bring a rook to g8 the next rook
over to the king side as well so he may
be all in on a king-side attack and we
just saw ali reza hesitate he was about
to make a move and then he paused but
one thing that white can do that is just
so frustrating is putting this knight on
e3 out to g4 because that stops d5
before you can even make it work because
e5 pawn is going to be under attack by
all the knights and in order to kick the
knight from g4 you have to make them
play h5 but that gives white the g5
square so the knight is able to move
right back and as you see the evaluation
is going up in white's favor and that's
what chess is about it's not just about
attacking pieces it's about controlling
squares and so a little pawn move can
have huge consequences and so knight g4
it just kind of
pushes the question back to rajab here
is well what are you going to do about
my now stable knights i guess the reason
i say that is because as you were
talking about not wanting to open the
queen side right now right now you
definitely can't do that because the
pawn is pinned right so the first move
that came to my mind was oh sometimes
you put the queen on b3 in these
italians so that you can then prepare
for b5 but obviously in this case the d3
pawn is hanging so i was listening to
you both talk about it right didn't just
come out with that opinion out of
nowhere but i was thinking that the more
you talked about white's inability to
expand on the queen side the fact that
you can't easily bring pieces over and
that black seems like black is
threatening to maybe play d5 robert's
knight g4 is a very good move so that
kind of convinced me otherwise but it
just felt like black is like already has
what he wants in these structures which
is a night poking at the king side
threats you can also bring the other
night over in some cases depending on
how it happens so anyway don your
thoughts on what we anticipate all the
reza to go for here no i i understand
what you're saying i i think the blacks
i mean two more has to be pretty happy
with the result of the opening it's a
pretty clearly defined position
uh still complex but uh you know black
has a fair share of improving moves and
d5 is an idea
and we talked about alireza's time
management way too early to talk about
time pressure but you know 107 and he's
showing no moving it's become it's
become a pattern and the position still
hasn't
uh you know
there's still a tremendous amount of
potential for things to get super
tactical i mean even in that line that
we were looking at with g3 d5 i mean
you're going to have to invest a lot of
time calculating so
if i'm alireza i'm thinking about making
a a decision within the next you know
five minutes before my clock hits it's
an hour he almost grabbed the night i
think he was going to play the move the
robber would suggest to be honest i mean
i think that he was
he was wanting knight g4 robert um or at
least he was going for that knight
whether it was going to g4 or or
c4 i don't think you're going in that
direction i think you can't afford to
bring all your pieces away from your
king so i mean knight g4a just stops
black's main move right black wants to
play d5 at some point not always that
easy because the rook on e1 will open up
if you ever take on d5 with your e4 pawn
so you might actually lose a pawn in
some variation and play d5 too soon but
knight g4 just kind of says like you
know your main plan now that's gone what
are you gonna do can i ask a foolish
question yeah knight g4 knight takes h3
could that be
a small concern i know it doesn't work
but
i want to see exactly why knight h3 king
takes h3 queen h5
now if you block with a knight i have g5
right so bl white plays king g3 and then
i thought maybe rook f4
but i suppose that black's attack
reaches a dead end after the knight from
g4 just moves back but i mean
you have to make totally sure of this
yeah maybe that's why he hesitated it
would be the second game in a row this
would happen where rajab has opponents
king one check away from mate but he's
losing but it's not bug house yeah
exactly h1 is coming next yeah and the
king slips back toward h2 and g1 yeah
ali reza gets up for a quick walk got to
stretch those legs after the uh
i think he had there
but he does indeed play robert's idea of
knight g4 for some reason that king went
to h8 it was a mysterious king move
maybe we'll see
roger's plan here in a minute in terms
of what exactly his intentions are
um i don't think he even he knows
exactly what his intentions are i think
he's figuring that out he's like well i
don't have a lot to do here put my king
on each one and ask questions later i'm
only half kidding
i mean i could see him shuffling his
pieces back before because knight g4
doesn't actually carry a threat right
yeah it just stops black's idea playing
d5 so i could see a position where you
just go king g8 king a change go back to
george what's next yeah well what is
white's plan i i i'm masking that
genuinely because it's not very easy to
play move d4
because once black takes with the e5
pawn and if you take with the c pawn
then b4 is loose right and in general
opening up the position in many ways is
gonna be bad for white so if you move
your rook away from a2 over to d2 and
then try to play b5 i still don't think
that's a good idea just because you're
not losing a pawn doesn't mean that
suddenly
thank you for opening the a file hey i
want more of that yeah you've developed
my rook in its starting place thank you
very much so i actually don't
exactly know what white's ideas maybe
you're knight g1
at some point and then try to play g3
and it's a slow approach um but even if
those moves happen yeah the night just
moves back from the end of the world and
it's like okay so keep proving to me how
you're going to play for an advantage uh
you have these like little individual
ideas but no concrete plan to actually
play for more
yeah is this is this a game that suits
faroosh's style
oh you're asking a good question because
what is for style
farouza's style i would say is one where
he is chan it's not necessarily all just
like calculations and crazy sacrifices
but it's a position where you have that
possibility in fact the game yesterday
is dingley wren when he was black we
were saying that actually was up his
alley and he did hold without any issue
but before pieces got traded it was like
that's a flexible approach where he
could find plans here this is like slow
maneuvering that's not that comfortable
because he often likes to play for a win
he's used to winning right
that sounds funny but okay in this
tournament yanupong she hit five under
caruana they're winning a ton of games
but if you think about the last year and
a half or however long who's won the
most games not named magnus carlson i'm
guessing it's farouza because you don't
get from 2700 to 2800 in a few months
without winning a ton of your games he
went eight out of nine at the european
team it's possible because maybe maggots
didn't even play as much heading to the
world championship the perugia won more
classical games last year than anybody
we'd have to look at that i feel like
people didn't make big enough of a deal
of varus's climb from 27 to 2800 yeah i
mean that was one of the greatest runs
we've been chasing him well he broke
records along the way obviously right he
became the youngest player ever to crash
through the 2800 elo barrier uh by the
way
regardless of my question about style
apparently this game was still following
regular lines of play knight to g4 is
the first novelty knight g1 had been
played a few times previously well the
novelty you heard here first
of robert
2022 right
hot takes over here robert has coming up
with novel ideas and he doesn't even
know he's a poet and he don't know it
all right um roger's going to be
thinking for a minute uh we'll we'll
back this up no he's not commentator's
curse 97 played the moment i say
the moment i say he'll be thinking for a
minute but either way we take a look at
our bird's eye view that game in the
upper right corner has already finished
everyone yonder pom nashie drew his game
against england didn't really bring a
lot of gunpowder to the table today and
uh we will speculate whether or not that
was a good idea throughout the rest of
today's show and ultimately maybe get
the answer to it in the clash that's
occurring tomorrow if you had other
plans for monday it's time to call in
sick cancel that dentist appointment we
know the world will go back to work but
why don't you just stay home on monday
no matter where you are and watch
uh fabiana carwana take the white pieces
versus yonder pandashi
and although we still have a lot of
chess ahead today so
on that note i think it's time to head
back to fabi's game
right yeah good thing we've seen
two very important moves two very
important moves been played and right as
we get there good timing no commentators
curse there hikaru moves right as we
bring the board up
and
let's see what he did we don't see what
he did yet on the there it is bishop to
f uh-huh
so attacking so first of all it's
important to point out he did play
bishop b3 to d1
which we sort of expected and fabby made
a move along
hess's recommendation i think which is
just make a small improving movement
ask
white what his plan is and i think we
know what fabi's plan is because he has
a rook and an open file he can bring his
second rook to the open file and the
point of bishop f2 was to put pressure
on e5 but rook f7 actually defends the
pawn and i people often think my pawn e5
is under attack i need to play rook e7
right if i touch that rook on d7 of
course i'm going to e7 let's show how
rook f7 defends with offense sorry
robert oh for sure if you take with the
rook on e5 there's only one piece
defending that rook it's the knight and
you just remove the defender and win the
piece so that's quite clear loose pieces
drop off you take with a knight well
that knight was doing an important job
closing the f-file you get that queen
for those two rooks but you also got the
bishop so black would be a head material
and completely winning so rook to f7
actually is the active way of defending
this e5 pawn and maybe that will become
an issue later but e4 now becomes a
threat because you're just trying to get
rid of that knight and don't forget that
bishop on d3 is aiming at the f1 square
there is a future where there could be
checkmate threats down the f-file yeah
e4 is not only a serious start it's hard
to defend against it i mean you could
move your bishop back to e3 but it just
came from there
i suppose you could defend the bishop on
f2 with the crazy knight i almost don't
want to say the square don't say that
you say
okay it's a good idea because it frees
the g3 square
and then
and then that h1 to f2 robert robert was
about to yell that it's actually not a
bad idea because it opens up g3 and if
that bishop should arrive on that square
e5 is really hard to defend and then the
knight coming to f2 actually hits the
bishop on d3 so actually the optimal
relocation might indeed be
changing bishop and knight swapping
places but there is one huge problem
okay one square when black plays e4 and
you play bishop g well actually bishop
g3 is not possible because i just moved
my queen right and then you've worked up
one checkmate no exactly i just want to
show that the knight is pinned that's
exactly what i meant that there are
checkmate possibilities so after that
i've shown you problems like
exaggerating however i mean
from time to time the community team
yells at me and says hey people like to
see checkmate on the board show it more
often okay stop yelling chad i hear you
sorry sorry robert so put the bishop
back on f2 and move the knight to d4
okay so the bishop is defended there but
what exactly is white's next move
because you can't move the bishop
there's still checkmate and i guess you
can tell like h3
and then bishop g3 because you've given
your king some lift via h2 it's just
really awkward positioning yeah well now
you can even bring the knight into c5
which is a plan we've been talking about
for a while and if h3 is
played
knight takes bishop on d3 that's what
you're really right you want to take
your own face knight takes own peace
that's one of the few variants that the
alpha zero papers didn't consider
self-capture
i've actually always thought about that
like because how many times do we have
chess games where you imagine and
fantasize if i could take my own pawn
out of the way here i'd crush all crash
through the diagonal yeah self-capture
just sounds like a vacation just you
know just self-catch right anyway so
that's a fun idea but not possible in
chess everybody any any hooters all
right
ikaru plays bishop to i want to draw our
attention to the other major storyline
in this game which is not on the board
but on the clocks because we still see
hikaru playing significantly faster than
fabiano
caruana has taken 22 minutes
before he played bishop d3
21 minutes before he played c4 and then
12 minutes before he just played rook d7
so he's he's definitely on his own even
if hikaru
is
bluffing or still in prep i mean who
knows at this point
yeah i mean the second candidate move
here is rookie seven so it's not like
he's wasting his time
i think he sees rook df7 net h1 and he's
trying to
figure out whether giving up that
monster d4 square and that's not
something you do lightly and that white
knight which comes to d4 is
a piece that is going to survive the
apocalypse so you got to make sure that
your pressure down the f4 is worth it
because if you decide that it isn't
worth it you have a perfectly acceptable
candid move yeah in rookie 7 a little
bit passive yes but it keeps the status
quo
right
there's no way i would could play i
would have to like play rook f7 e4 it
just looks good i agree right it's just
one of those positions that you know you
almost want to play it by feel and even
though you're completely correct in
something we talked about earlier
whenever you start pushing these nice
pawns in the center you leave squares
behind you give your opponent uh places
for in this case the knight going to d4
but once just because of knights on d4
that's a good square that doesn't mean
that black is suddenly in trouble right
it's like i give you one thing but i
also get something for it so it seems
like a fair trade-off we're not removing
pieces from the board but we're giving
each other files and squares
yeah
yeah my only devil's advocate view on on
that is
is
is fabi looking at the fact that jan
already drew his game is there a worry
fab he has that this game can get away
from him at this point given how fast
the car was playing the prep we know
this is as you said robert a seven
result position meaning any player could
lose here i mean is there is there
something to being a little bit timid
before you go all in on yeah intuitively
it feels like f7 should be good but
there's there's a lot of tactics on
board here
yeah i mean i guess he's also kind of
thinking that if he plays recap seven
he's going to be able to play the next
couple of moves fast because if he plays
rook f7 we're gonna see knight h1 e4 and
the knight c5
quickly and that's already going to be
move
what 27
so perhaps bobby actually isn't
you know that worried about his clock
and he thinks that if the position
clarifies then he'll be able to play
relatively quickly and relatively
accurately okay okay
i had to ask for a friend i mean i
obviously knew you were gonna answer
that way i just wanna ask for everyone
else um
but this is this is a really weird
looking position i mean it's one of
those equal looking eval bar ones where
the eval bar is evil because it is not
truly indicative of what a mess this is
or how hard the position is to play
i want to play h3 and go for your idea
robert to to play bishop g3 and slowly
coordinate here my biggest question was
let's say let's go knight e6 to trade
off your best piece so how is white
gonna attack anything i can understand
why the evaluation bar says white is
slightly better and i won't dispute that
but with that bishop just firmly
entrenched on d3 yeah like the d5 pawn
which would be a weakness if you cleared
the d-file that would immediately be a
target yeah you can't get there great
point so i'm just like looking at this
position like all right i can again i
can get why the engine says white is
better but i think from a practical
point of view when you look at this
you're like um how are you gonna do
anything whatsoever your minor pieces
haven't coordinated and it's really
difficult to because of blacks control
the f-file yeah
i wonder if you would prefer workout
seven or over rookie seven robbers i'm
not clear on where you stand on that
i wonder if there's so
i agree although the only thing i get
worried about whenever i'm playing a
rook versus minor pieces is that
should the inevitable coordination come
i don't know if i can get away with this
and then bishop g3 and knight of two
it's what i want to do bishop b3 knight
f2
i feel like should the inevitable
coordination come these squares that
aren't access are holes and my knight
thrives in those types of battles right
so i know it's a fantasy but bishop g3
knight f2 the knight uses g4 to route to
e3 at some point right i'm i'm playing
the slow game here if i'm nakamura right
because the long term
aspects of the minor pieces outplaying
the rooks should these pawns get stuck
if they lose their ability to go forward
that's when the miners will thrive
they'll maneuver they'll poke they'll
prob they'll prob the probe
well you didn't prod or probably
i've been i've been probing all day go
ahead danya no no i uh
i think you explained it very well
i i
agree with you robert that i i would
have expected fabi to play rook f7
faster i mean my hand would have played
that move
before my brain would have been able to
say let's think it through yeah but i
guess that's one of those things we keep
coming back to about fabiano is that
even when he probably senses that there
is an accurate move or something that
he's more comfortable with it's
something he doesn't trust his intuition
he just wants to verify because the
biggest mistake you can make is playing
unnecessarily quickly and then getting a
worse position so i mean rook e7 right
that's the alternative just defending
the pawn directly i think there is
something to the notion that people
believe that when we
keep the status quo and we just defend
like that's playing it safe but in
reality that actually could put you in
more danger because then you might be
playing into hikaru's hands yeah by just
keeping everything as is hikaru gets to
continue with his plan and then what's
black's plan in return at least with the
open file you're like i always have that
and that's not just like oh yay cool i
have a file no it's like really there
are some threats involved that restricts
white's pieces so i'm not sure which is
actually better from like the engine
objective point of view i think both
have their merits but i just think that
just broadly speaking that we often
think that there's a way to play safe
but it actually can often be more
dangerous than it would appear we saw
that last feature chat just let you know
caught that
question whether or not we think bobby's
still happy that he's playing black i
think he i think he still is and again
robert's point earlier that uh the fact
that yon drew with white
uh maybe makes him feel even more at
ease as long as this one doesn't get
away from him so uh interesting comment
from the the the wag rock rack
i
i don't always go to the school for kids
who read good or not good when i'm
reading usernames
i've been known to put the emphasis on
the wrong syllable from time to time
anyway um
chat stay involved with us get get get
comments going we'll try to feature some
of your best ones throughout the day
we appreciate it we appreciate all the
subscribers coming in and wherever
you're tuning in from
it uh it's going to be a good one if
you're just tuning in let's back up to
the bird's eye view and remind you that
we already have a result in the books
again yonda pomnishi doesn't fight with
the white pieces has a bigger plan in
mind we see fabiano does put the rook on
the f-file so he uh he's ready for the
fight
unlike uh his co-tournament leader and i
say that knowing yawn is it was up at
half a point but basically we're talking
about a two horse race here in madrid at
this time
hikaru a bit of a scowl coming back
there not
maybe
maybe a little surprised might he have
i don't think he missed f7 is that a
possibility at all
that it
escaped his mind that black could defend
him directly yeah he seems because and
i'm only saying that because because of
his facial facial reactions i you know
debated right i mean he's going to play
night h1 it's a very awkward move yeah
it's not
common that you put your own knight in
the corner
except in like the same mission in some
position i'm not convinced he's going to
play nh1 i think he might go back to e3
really yeah that's the other option is
to just repeat moves and say sorry
because at least then f1 is well
defended
interesting yeah it's a
really difficult question for him right
now because part of the reason why i
think he will play knight h1 of course
he's both these players are capable of
seeing knight once not about that i
think they both have it on the horizon
um but i feel like hikaru came in today
wanting to win
and so if you play bishop e3 now you're
repeating moves and it doesn't mean
he'll continue repeating if fabi would
just put his rook back to d7 which i
don't believe he should um but it's very
difficult in general to put a piece back
from the square it just came from so
i think
i i really do believe playing nightshade
but i also agree that it looks so
awkward and uncomfortable and you're
facing all this pressure on the f-file
but then the question is what did did he
just absolutely miss rook f7 that
happens to all the best players in the
world that would be the
the real curveball because that would
mean what you're saying is he thought
rook of seven wasn't possible because he
thought he was winning the e5 fund right
i mean but that there's no way he would
make
a misstep like that um
so but but judging by his facial
reaction right and he does there was
definitely a surprise there right he
didn't just nod his head and write the
move down because we should ask this man
who is the number one car facebook it's
hard right because
translating
streamer hikara the online chess player
versus hikaru the
you know very well dressed sporting his
his championship rings from his u.s
championship victory this is okay wait
that that hold on
showing
signs if a car or not got more number
14.
oh sure wasn't ever 13 a.m no 13 your
expertise might be waning very rare
anyway the catalog of different emotions
from mr nakamura
is uh something we we often draw
attention to here um i think he's about
to move
yeah yep nope okay so he's all right
robert yeah he had two no touche hickor
nakamura plays moves like night inch one
yeah he does
and safety third has always been
nakamura's rule
it is a compliment him though because he
finds these really resourceful creative
ideas putting your knight on h1 right
most of the time in knights on h1 is
because you allowed a pawn to attack
your knight and nowhere else to go and
it gets trapped in the corner right
that's yeah the sad truth but here
nitrogen has a clear purpose it frees
the g3 square for the bishop which puts
pressure on e5 allows the knight to then
go to f2 where it attacks this bishop on
g4 and also might go from human d3 and
also might go to g4 later as you're
pointing out in some variations so the
knight will find a better square it
wasn't doing all that much on g3 so it's
really nice rerouting by hikaru and now
it's fabiano on the clock and look we
got to stop from db smiley you know i
want to
say something funny about this is like
we're not too far from
the possibility that this was a fisher
random chess game at this point speaking
of a night on h1 actually you know it
was a bishop on each one that we
commentate on i'm sorry we love mr
peters fiddler
the original one of the best chess
commentators and chess players in the
play on the planet but we have this
incredible incredible loss uh from the
2019 fisher random world chess
championship where a piece on each one
never entered the game and that night
just reminds me of that game that was a
really sad that was that was so sad but
wesley wasn't so sad about it yeah
wesley was not so sad about it on his
way to not just qualifying to the live
final in austin norway but becoming the
first ever fisher random world chess
championship how's that for a quick
highlight just uh google it there may or
may not be future events coming there i
can't i don't think i can say anything
about that at this time so
anyway um
all right knight h1 played
fobby back on the clock
i mean he's gonna play e4
the question is when
although my previous prediction didn't
exactly age well
i wonder if he's just struggling to
believe that white's position can be
like pretty not just okay but pretty
good if not better when you have a pawn
e4 bishop on d3 rooks in the f file
i just feel like everything about
black's position is pretty ideal
right if you're going to give
up a couple-minute pieces for a rook
having a fully open file where both of
your rooks are barreling down
in theory that sounds amazing now hikaru
has his pieces in position to withstand
the pressure but like
everything on the surface looks great
for fabiano so i i can't imagine that
he's displeased with the position but i
also can think that maybe he's in
disbelief that all of this has happened
and yet still he's struggling to find
like the next plan after he's gone but
maybe there's
maybe there's some concrete x's and o's
that back up your uh your psychological
point because the uh the
the the way to describe that same
scenario from the opposite side of the
coin is maybe
because everything is so optimal right
now robert he's afraid to change it
right because we talked about e4 and
let's analyze this again to show
everybody the lines we're looking at so
if e4 is played right and the knight
moves to d4 as daniel said it survives
the apocalypse here and eventually we
get these positions where white slowly
wiggles out again the only way you ever
lose this is black and i'm not saying
that's going to happen but the only way
you ever lose is if somehow these pieces
just start staring into thin air and
it's white who has all the means to
improve the position eventually you
start poking at pawns and so what i'm
getting to is is there a concrete option
here besides e4 and one of them might be
rook f5 maybe hikaru didn't come in to
this game okay with a draw because this
is his last chance right to win with
white robert but you could play rook f5
and see whether or not nakamura is
interested in repeating moves here
rook five is the other move that sits on
the structure
right instead of playing e4
donya
i agree with the idea that fabi probably
part of fabi
is
frustrated at the fact that after e4 and
i d4 there is no tactic there's no
because if you could play queen h4 uh
that would be a move to consider that
bishop is literally paralyzed this is
going to show if you could do this right
i mean it wouldn't actually be that
great but you get what i'm saying yep
another thing that came to my mind after
knight c5 h3
there's a move which looks incredibly
tempting that's e3
which is a classic device you carve out
a particular square like oh that's a
pawn
well that's me i know i i'm doing it for
the fans you know danya no i thought you
missed it okay one's a pretty hard one
but but the problem is my boy's queen
takes e3 and after knight e4
in giving up the e4 pawn you've also
relinquished your control of the f3
square and now it is bishop f3 and these
variations
he's calculating them quickly but
they're very frustrating yeah and he has
to change his mindset right he's got to
go from
i am looking for the killer kill shot
mode to it's just a complicated position
and i'm going to play something slow
mode and that change of mentality can be
hard if you've set yourself up with
expectations about how good you think
your position is yeah
go ahead robert i'm sure you want to
weigh in but again that i think that's a
really good point right is before you
commit to this you got to feel
good about that right because you cannot
take that move back and
if you lack a concrete punch it might be
white who's out maneuvering you in the
long run right i don't i'm some reason
i'm getting a feeling that we might see
this at least one time
to see if hikaru wants more than a draw
with knight to g3 given his position
given that bobby gets white versus
yonder pomnishi in the tournament
tomorrow
you could invite that idea
to just find out what exactly hikaru
wants to play for um
all right well
we still have a lot that the players are
playing for here in round eight we're
going to back up leave you with the
snapshot of where we stand three games
in progress yonda panmashi
has already drawn his game versus
dingley wren we're going to take a very
very quick break but before we do want
to remind everybody that while the
players are playing here in madrid you
can also play every weekend in our
global championship qualifiers saturday
and sunday
through july 31st they are occurring
every weekend you can go to go.just.com
cgc2022 join our non-titled open
qualifiers so you can play with the best
players in the world for cash prizes
starting with our play in stage uh
really at this point in just uh just a
few weeks i guess a month we transition
and all eyes will be on who is going to
qualify for the live final in toronto
for the first ever global championship
get verified play in the events win cash
prizes and and have fun all right
fabiano's on the clock we are on the
clock with a very quick break don't go
anywhere chess.com's coverage of round
date for the feed a candidates here in
madrid continues when we return
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the routine is uh
the most big and important park in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a maybe best one in
madrid
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
considered by most as the rising
superstar in chess ali reza faruja makes
his candidates debut here in madrid
the only teenager in the tournament
furuja is the youngest player ever to
break the 2800 rating barrier
born in iran but representing france
perugia strikes fear in his opponents
with his array of surprising tactical
shots
alireza qualified for the candidates by
taking first place in the fide grand
swiss he also followed up that
performance with a strong finish at the
european team chess championship
coming in with heavy expectations
farouza has a more than reasonable
opportunity here to become the youngest
winner in candidates tournament history
with that the teen prodigy would take
one step closer to potentially knocking
magnus carlsen off his championship
perch
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game old as the
game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess
championship the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
shout out to the the team coming up with
every possible
way to
to just add life to the candidates here
that was
first of all when was the last time
anybody ever mixed an x-files theme song
with anything from a chess tournament
i don't know we usually leave julian
anderson alone so yeah
i mean what happened to her career what
do you think she was in uh
the hannibal show
and then she right and then she's uh the
mom in uh sex education
welcome to madrid everybody robert has
pop culture extraordinary
this is another thing
excited on that one uh anyway a shout
out to the team seriously that video had
me
l-m-r-o-f-l-m-a owing is that what the
kids say um and it was it was great to
see the uh the switcheroo from mikhail
nakamura hopefully fiji doesn't find him
for that all right um
we've got three games going here
reporting duda is is getting it's good
it's spicy you're getting spicy right i
think that would be a fun one to switch
over to not too much has changed in the
ali reza ferrugia team or rajab off
queens and knights and rooks
parade over there um
but i think the i think the report duda
has enough life to justify switching
away from what is definitely the marquee
matchup we will not go too far before
going back to caruana and nakamura don't
worry everyone
but let's uh let's talk about this
position here donya your first thoughts
as we glimpse a king side that has come
to life for report well i just spent
most of my time counting the pawns
and i came to the
great insight that black is in fact
currently
down upon it yeah it doesn't meet the
eye very well it almost looks like black
is up upon after queen takes g5 so the
big decision to be made here
is which piece should take on g5 queen
takes g5 or knight takes c5 queen takes
is the more sort of conservative solid
option
uh knight takes g5 could really pay off
uh but but could also backfire because
that open g file
uh could cause storm clouds to gather
around black's king you're showing the
move h4 kicking the knight away then
rook g1 and bishop h3
uh so my guess is that uh jkd will
probably take with the queen okay and i
feel like black you know if anyone is
better here it's probably black now
after queen takes g5 the last thing i'll
say and you know either you can jump in
and correct me why does not have to
trade queen so queen f2
or queen f3 would be in line with report
style
but apparently
that's really really bad and i guess
it's because of the rook lift rookie 8
to e6 i thought you're gonna say it's
because the rook was already guarding it
but yes you're right oh that rook comes
in so quickly that knight from mage 7
can jump in to g5
and i guess uh the threats against
white's king become unstoppable really
quickly and what i'm going to do is have
us go back a few moves because white
started pushing these pawns and yeah i
guess we've already shown it now but
white
pushed the pawns right white was if we
just go back two moves
right here like this already looks like
a position where white may create some
threats you have the semi-open f file
and what rapport did by bringing his
queen over to g3 he's aiming for
doubling the rooks and the f files going
for an attack and look at duda's
calculation here h5
putting pressure on g4 and after g5 it
looks like the knight has to move and if
the knight moves then white plays h4
protects that pawn over there on g5 and
has a nice space advantage with the
semi-open file so the move by duda that
move h4 himself that's really precise
that's a great move because he
recognized that once the queen takes the
pawn which is pretty much forced the
knight comes to him and he wins the pawn
right back and now his king feels quite
safe
brilliant such a nice little thematic
idea it's one of those ones that call it
a knowledge nugget for chat you want to
put that in your pocket and don't forget
it because when you're calculating these
these forced lines like this someone's
attacking your minor piece and your
first instinct is often to defend it
when a pawn is threatening to capture a
knight but this is an in-between move
right a little sufficient zug that's
super key because it disrupts white's
ideal structure from happening and this
is a very common theme to take advantage
of a pawn like this right in front of a
queen that's sort of pinned and on that
on that note wrong again yeah judah
wants more than just an end game
he's already already shown a willingness
to fight despite also a lot of draws
here he plays knight takes g5 because he
wants to keep the queens on the board
and maybe he likes uh donya's idea of
the rook lift
a little too much to uh to let the
ladies exchange what do you think donya
i'm a little surprised so white is going
to play h4 i don't really doubt that
although my track record has been spotty
today i'm predicting let's see if i can
redeem myself not h7 is going to happen
and then the question is which move does
white start with you can start with rook
g1 but again there's that pesky rook
lift
what you can do to try to be more clever
is start with bishop h3 and the cool
thing is that after bishop h takes h3
you can play rook g1 here that would be
a very good move in a bullet game but it
also is a pretty good move in a
classical game it forces black to play
uh g6 now apart from weakening the king
this also has the effect of taking the
sting out of the rook lift because
you know there's no there there there's
nowhere to lift the rook anymore black
is still doing well but
i don't know i i don't know if i fully
agree with the eval part here i feel
like white's got his share of chances
okay
yeah i think knight takes g5 the move
that duda just played he's willing
to lose
to increase his chances to win because
if the queens were traded on g5 black is
in no danger whatsoever you feel very
comfortable you're the better pawn
structure i mean there's no risk here
but
the risk is that your winning chances
also have been diminished because now we
have an endgame and you're slightly
better pawn structure doesn't really
really mean all that much uh for the
time being so knight takes g5 initially
without the queen trade it's a pretty
courageous decision because that line we
were just looking at that dania
disagreed with the eval bar when white
pushes h4 takes over the g file this is
not a position where rapport and duda
are like oh yeah black is .5 better
right you look at this position like
okay
while you have some serious attacking
chances it looks like black is able to
ward off all the threats and if you
could successfully avoid checkmate and a
big attack then black should be better
because of the better pawn structure but
it's not very clear
one way or the other like who's getting
there first so i think that it's just a
really sharp battle between these two i
have to give credit to both i mean
they're playing an entertaining game and
now the king side is open
you we have to praise that rook on a7 i
mean that piece is doing such a
marvelous job of defending the king all
the way from the queen side yeah
yeah i like it yeah definitely a game
that's going to give us a fight
which means we get to see that red
jacket a little longer i love that good
jacket dude's got style he just has
style
i
yeah i think he reserved that red jacket
after like a painful loss to cheer
himself up yeah yeah it uh just brings
uh
brings the fashion to the to the playing
hall every single day there
and uh right now he's
trying to figure out how to bring the
heat along the g file because that's uh
that's got to be the whole key to his
idea of advancing on the king side
i mean he can't really delay age four
because rookie six this rook lift is
gonna hurt yeah he's gotta see that
because rook g1
comes over here you got problems yeah
and and as diane saying rook g1 is
tempting so that you can move your
bishop and just go for checkmate down
the g file but rookie six rook g6 ideas
are not fun to deal with so i think
report has to play h4 otherwise
everything i just said about it not
being very clear no it becomes
abundantly clear who's driving can i
show a line really quickly yeah let's
show it guys uh so after road you want
rookie six you might say well i don't
get why this work lift is so good well i
can play h4 now and if i
have my finger on the pulse of the
position rook h6 here it's incredibly
strong why is it so strong what if white
moves the bishop back let's say to h1
well there's a tactic rook takes h4
check and then knight f3 check opens up
the attack on the queen and wins the
queen so
everything is very concrete in these
positions these players they're not
reasoning in terms of general
assumptions and rules
they're calculating variations and on
that note we have h4 and my first
correct move prediction of the day well
it should show as well that the reason
the knight is going to h7 all our lines
and not e6 is for the same reasons that
even though the knight is well placed on
e6 and this is possible it feels like
keeping not just that score open for the
rook but this diagonal open for the
bishop is a lot more the spirit of the
position for black yeah rather
sorry go ahead i was just going one step
further with what you're saying to
illustrate that like bishop h3 now and
this knight
is kind of
vulnerable to being captured somewhere
like white's next one was rook g1 with
threats down the g file and if you ever
played g6 and white plays h5 like
already white's coming straight out of
the king so the knight on h7 actually
helps shield the black king and can't be
attacked yeah
all right and we saw judah played it
very quickly
and
very quickly we're gonna acknowledge
that we just crossed 800 000 followers
on twitch.tv slash chess that means so
much
obviously uh
it's just awesome thank you so much
everybody out there hitting that follow
button if somehow you're watching and
haven't hit the follow button join the
party there's 800 000 other people
who've done it so apparently that's
where the cool kids hang uh but
seriously jokes aside uh on onward to a
million is uh is the goal and to
infinity and beyond as they say but uh
thank you again so much and thank you
again for the uh chat playing along we
got twee 87 saying forget chess report
wins on style he does win on style
red signals aggression that is for sure
it also means stop
in the name of love oh sorry okay that
was the wrong show report looks like a
men's magazine model
you just made another reference though
that's my cue to stay silent
he does he does he looks good gq called
they want their chess player on the
cover of the magazine they found him
right there
bad salmon if you think that's a salmon
color
so i think someone in chat said that
it's not it's salmon moon just never
heard of something being described as
salmon color i think i might adopt that
no no i i wear colored shorts or what
all the frat boys wear i i worry
i've hung around fab boys that's true i
wore a salmon colored shirt to the
opening ceremony
oh it's i'm glad i wasn't there
yeah dude got styled the bell and kaya
we know that
shout out to dina she'll be interviewing
report later on today in that suit so
she can comment maybe on his style and
that it's all it's all we're talking
about they're like they're trying to get
danny to talk about chess and all he can
talk about is your suits
i think every time we've looked at his
game you've mentioned the suit
no i'm not saying that in a well look
he's running he stands out in a room
of suits that are black and blue which
there's
that's great i'm wearing a blue suit
right but what it is
it's great bishop takes h3 now played by
the way you could throw in your little
rookie one great bullet actually that's
a huge that's a hugely important moment
because it's uh what a chance to catch
your opponent in a pre-move with rook g1
a and b you're progressing i actually
think judah might have missed that move
because if king takes h3 black would
have had rookie six let's let's follow
doodles
yeah that's actually really
it wasn't just a bullet reference by
donya he's onto something if if you take
it any other way i think king or queen
there's a rookie six well queen takes h3
takes your eyes off the g7 fun
i think judah might have missed this
move yeah look at the eyes of duda he
maybe maybe did this is a really
important inner mizzo because by
threatening checkmate and forcing g6
donya called it his point was again now
the rook lift is out the window
regardless of how you take back black's
aggressive chances have gotten smaller i
see you robert go ahead i'm gonna give
dude a little more credit i think right
now he doesn't seem that shocked but
he's calculating do i have to play g6
maybe i can push my f pawn maybe i'll go
f5
because you have to take my bishop back
next move and now my rook defends g7 and
if you take with the king maybe there's
opportunity for black to strike with f4
i'm giving up pawns because your king's
on h3 like i'm going for checkmate
myself you attacked me first you
threatened the first mate but who gets
the last laugh it might be black
we
are going to have an interesting game
over here it may not be the same stakes
that yonda pandashi and fabiana karwan
are playing for ladies and gentlemen but
this is
i love that idea robert i i think giving
him credit was exactly what was due
because f5 it's funny there was another
move f5 that uh someone found really
only once the position was in front of
them and that was fabiano caruana as
black after all the rest of peru's
exchange sacrifice in the catalan it's
possible that dude is pausing here he's
like wait a second i don't have to just
play g6
what about f5 i put the rook there for a
reason
yeah i mean queen f6 is also possible
but you don't necessarily want to use
the queen as the primary defender of the
g7 upon that's not a very efficient use
of your resources and yeah you're
walking into potential or kf1 so
agree with robert f5 is definitely
whether or not he started you on that's
actually a moot point yeah because he's
obviously aware of the possibility of f5
yeah you don't want this because of this
as as dania said and the queen is she's
not at her best when her only job is
defending a pawn from checkmate so
boy would i love to see a five
i want it so bad
so bad yeah and uh just to add one more
move to our list of candidates oh that
sounds weird when
the video candidates but you can play
bishop g4 for some reason you want the
queen on g4 i don't think you
necessarily do but you can decide okay
first i'll play g6 but first i'll drag
your queen up that's not very useful
here but in other positions it could be
where you just interpose with the piece
that's going to be captured next no
matter what yep
okay absolutely well dude is on the
clock
we're gonna back this thing up and uh
first thing we're gonna do is check all
the clocks of the other boards and see
if anything massively has changed and
indeed that was the one i had circled in
my head was what's going on on bobby's
clock he's down to a half an hour
to an hour and almost 20 minutes for
nakamura
but it's hikaru who's thinking
on this one hey buddy
i just looked over here
yeah well we have that situation
where that bishop on f2 is tied down
and ikaro is trying to free up his minor
pieces
and fabi is trying to put pressure
that's on the lower left he's played
queen
d6 to g6 just sort of improving his
position and tossing the ball back into
white's court
again
note
to self everyone if this bishop moves
the game is over there's checkmate on f1
that's what happens when you have a
bishop on d3 so
right now obviously these players are
not blundering and that's just a tactic
to keep in mind
but it's it's a critical in fact the
other thing that the queen on g6 does is
not just spy things on the king's side
donya but it opens up the d6 square for
the night which go we were so obsessed
with this
there's this idea of bringing the knight
to f5 i'm so glad when i make these two
happy i said d6 and they both nodded
there's this low self-esteem
international master over here he was so
proud of himself all right gm
gm norm just for spotting knight d6 yep
you guys are so kind by the authority
vested
so we were talking about h3 as a move to
free up the h2 square for the king so
there's no
checkmate here and i'm just wondering
like with the queen on g6 that stops
your knight f2 ideas like it takes this
bishop g3 king h2 knight f2 so it takes
a bit of time so i actually really do
like the queen sliding over to g6 it
just makes white's plans slower yeah and
now you can go for this and it's not to
say that it's just better than knight c5
but it has a plan of getting to f5
because the reason i liked it is not
just for the trade but donya's e3 might
be coming to the board in some of those
spots
yeah absolutely it's already something
to to consider the one plus
of h3 is that it does create a square on
g4 which you could use as a springboard
for the d1 bishop
the thread of bishop e6
causes a little bit of discomfort for
black
and by closing down the g file you're
also increasing the likelihood that
bishop g3 will work
so black could consider meeting h3 with
h5
committal yes but i'm controlling
squares on the king side and preparing
to meet you know knight g3 also with
or or later bishop gt3 with h4 that just
adds another tactical wrinkle to the
equation yep and
you just covered g4 so white's main idea
of bishop g3 knight f2 knight g4 that
danny was pointing out earlier that's no
longer available so
it seems very difficult to actually team
up on this h5 pawn how would you do that
you played knight g3 you can't play
knight g3 when your bishop one f2 is
loose so
this actually is a situation where
it feels like h5
essentially playing against your
opponent's plans
is the right way to go rather than
multitasking right h5 is a very direct
move just stopping a piece from going to
g4 and it seems to work out
marvelously icaru is deep in thought or
he wouldn't be looking deep
deep up to the ceiling there it's not
just the art
in the beautiful palacio de santonia
that his eyes are viewing he's likely
looking at a position that is not in
front of him at all trying to figure
this thing out i just beth armand's not
i just thought of something else as well
knight d6 protects the e8 square one of
the flaws of this e3 move that donnie
was pointing out before was that the
queen could take and keep everything
together rookie you might have rookie
eight and some critical variations like
it's just a slight difference but
actually if we you go for a similar line
let's say like
i don't know how to make this work but
let's go but it i'm just going to make
them randomly just to show
robert's idea we
again another random move doesn't matter
the point is that
e in fact e3 might even be possible
e3 had purposes to free the e4 square
for the knight on either c5 or d6 uh in
addition to the fact that the bishop
can't take it without things getting
real nasty over here but now there's
ideas of brook to e8 and a lot of
positions where the knight was on d6 and
it wasn't before so again black is
trying to build up
the forces right this isn't a a position
that that possesses a concrete knockout
not yet but it's one of those spots
where you're trying to get everything on
the right square
so that when the opportunity exists
you can strike
um and hikaru is
ah
yeah i agree
all right
he's calculating with his ear yep that
doesn't want to do
and bobbing the head from side to side
except he's not listening to music this
time
he's uh calculating variations and
this guy's on a roll
uh okay get that guy diamond membership
best comment of the day so far
ikaro having trouble focusing without
the ability to draw arrows on the board
that is uh
that's a funny one agreed um
well if this game doesn't go well for
hikaru he might he might
wish he could draw arrows on the board
earlier in the game guys i'm gonna i'm
gonna take an opportunity to show a
little more detail about that crazy
moment we had earlier uh and maybe maybe
it'll ultimately have been what hikaru's
best chances were to win well he's been
spending 17 minutes in this move so it
feels like it's the perfect time danny
to show what he could have thought about
earlier
to the batcave we go hi everybody we're
back at the telestrator it's me danny
hey guys you're still miked up by the
way you can also oh hi
you can see okay hi everybody um all
right so if you're just tuning in
obviously we have a great battle uh in
store for us today hikara nakamura with
the white pieces trying to win to keep
pace maybe with fabiano cardone and
yonda pandashi but for fabi just as much
at stake even more but
this game had a really interesting
moment earlier where
the players were rapidly blitzing out
moves nobody was thinking at all and we
would assume that preparation brought to
the table by both players was the reason
why however
according to analysis again credit to
roundok sadwani doing commentary for us
over on our chess.com india channel he
was the first to spot it now been
confirmed
rook dd8
is apparently black's best choice here
according to the engine we're not going
to dive into what prep they might have
had there but fabiano blitzed out c5
hikaru in turn immediately responded
with knight to g3 which by the way the
reason this theory has real credit is
because knight g3 is the best move
against rook dd8 however against c5
there was a huge opportunity here of
bishop to g5 which only works precisely
because this rook is still on d8 what's
the tactic
if black defends the pawn now white was
winning with this crazy move rook takes
e5 rook takes e5 and bishop f4
even rook to e8 is met by a knight
capture and then queen to g3 and black's
position is completely collapsing so
hikaru didn't take any time and will it
be proven in hindsight that he actually
just played too fast and missed it
because
there were the only other option for
black was this move c4 which also leads
to this crazy variation we had here with
bishop takes d8 c takes b3 this is this
is where it gets a little nutty and
unfair because on b takes a2 rook a1
bishop b1 apparently white is just
better at the end of a line where your
rook is trapped because of bishop g3 and
this is the part where we say well
thanks for the telestrator dan
but it seems like an engine line that
none of you understand you wouldn't be
wrong about that guys you got an opinion
about this position here
thanks for the illustration dan what
seems like a line out of it
okay
but seriously jokes aside it's quite
possible we'll find out in the end that
uh after c5 that it that it was actually
a mistake and then a car might have
missed a chance so anyway fun stuff hope
you enjoyed the breakdown and uh
we're gonna we're gonna let this one
continue as actually hey car was still
on the clock is he not at the board
anymore or we just switched camera views
we switched camera abuse he's still
there
well it also you know with that guy no
wait no he's not it's his turn so he
had this conversation the other day he's
going to yell at me i'm sorry i use the
telestrator
okay
uh by the way there
should we talk about the rule that we
finally clarified go for it okay
so you are not allowed to leave what is
considered the playing area the word
area is in
sort of you know highlighted there
because the playing area apparently can
be defined differently depending on the
circumstances of the venue but
traditionally the playing area is the
playing hall and like the players break
room there's like a small little vip
area of refreshments you're not allowed
to leave that area including to go to
the restroom without informing the
arbiter so what we don't know earlier in
the tournament is when john got up and
left do you remember that moment where
he just got up suddenly and left yeah
whether he went to the western we also
don't know we assumed that he hadn't
informed the arbiter maybe along the way
he could have it was off camera but just
to clarify the rules 100
a player is not allowed to leave when it
is their turn
they are not allowed to leave the
playing area as defined by the arbiter
in this case the playing hall itself and
the the small refreshments area without
letting the arbiter know why they're
getting up and possibly being escorted
into the restroom if it's if it is their
turn
robert i mean i said you know it feels
like kindergarten yeah um you know go to
the bathroom if the bathroom is in a
secluded area where nobody else can go
this feels so unnecessary but if the
bathroom isn't a place where somebody
else can walk through that's where you
would need that kind of security because
otherwise you could get a well-timed
bathroom break without you know anybody
being there they always have people
there people near our bathroom like
there's always people monitoring you
know the area i mean okay like even if
it is a private bathroom you can
understand why the arbor would need to
know i mean i hate to use this reference
you ever seen the godfather yeah okay it
obviously wouldn't be a weapon in there
but a cell phone someone goes in palacio
de centonia at night tapes their phone
underneath the toilet
even actually puts it in a ziploc bag
fills it with water imagine if that
actually happened i mean now you're
using a phone to get engine moves
we know that certain players
well they're not grandmasters anymore
have used phones and bathrooms during
chess he developed a raw system to do
that yeah exactly and so this has
happened i just it's so hard for me to
entertain it during this event with no
none of the players would do that but
there's a reason the rules are in place
that's the only point in because because
hikaru made us talk about it coming up
here to yell at me so you're blaming him
for something now he really he got up he
got up when it was his turn you know now
he really will come yell at you so you
better be prepared
to get in between this right now don't
you have to say something so that we
stopped saying something this is this is
what i came to madrid
exactly all right
well um i actually had a question for
you okay when you were going through
that telestrator line which i hadn't
seen before do you think there's any
chance fabian actually prepared that
because
what the eval bar seemed to be showing
was only a slight advantage for white
and it was so ridiculous to even play
that position do you think that team
karwana said you know what this looks
like a reasonable practical try because
it's actually not that bad for black to
begin with and
i mean it looks like white could lose
that position in just two moves let's
look at that because anyone who followed
fabiano carwana's commentary with us
during the world championship in
november covering the match of nepal
mishi versus carlson in dubai then you
know that one of the really interesting
insights
takeaways that we had
from fabi's presence with us
was that
the the idea he said dania was that
top grand masters are often often
looking for spots where their opponent
thinks they got them but really debated
and they got you right and even even to
the point of going for positions that
objectively they know are a little bit
worse but they think there's some tricky
ideas they think maybe there's a chance
for them to go wrong and that's an
interesting line because the whole point
of bishop g5 we obviously know where
dde8 is not the move we already know
because of rook takes e5 but that line
that we just saw with c4
captures
captures here
the bishop coming back to h4 takes a2
with the threat by the way of bishop b1
to get a queen so the only move is rook
a1
and then bishop b1 yeah how do you
evaluate this if you've ever seen them
exactly so it's possible that this was
prep based on what robert was saying
that maybe there was something even
deeper here that he was hoping to catch
a car on and even if objectively white
is a little better there's a possibility
maybe that bobby has a has an idea so
that's an interesting i don't know i
mean obviously neither one of us does
know but it is an interesting anecdote
because of what bobby said about top
level prep these days
being about opportunities like that
where your opponent thinks that it was
better for them but you went just a
little deeper and you saw just how
obscure or hard it might be to play a
position yeah that position just looks
ridiculous right if you just showed
somebody who had done zero preparation
they'd be like what is this it looks
whoa h4 or
wow speaking of
ridiculous but i think sorry i gave you
the car wise because i saw it but no
your point was great yeah that it looked
ridiculous to go for a little bit right
so you kind of just believe that fabiano
knows what he's doing yeah and so that
you just say all right this guy's well
prepared he's got this under control but
h4
what a move here by hikaru
you know what that move says
it says you were right hicaro came to
this game for a fight
yeah
he came to this game
to put pressure on his countrymen and
say all right
i'm not rolling over for you buddy
i'm coming after you that's a very high
quality chest movement the point is if
black plays h5 yep it may not seem like
the placement of the white pawn makes a
difference that's on h3 it's on h4 who
cares well hikaru cares because now he's
got a stronghold on the g5 square and he
can actually play queen d2 to g5 oh wow
and a queen trade would greatly diminish
the pressure down the f file it would
accentuate the power of the knight on d4
it would increase the pressure on the h5
pawn and it would give white i think a
pretty stable advantage and you don't
even have to rush with queen g5 maybe
there are
you know there's a more refined
uh way to continue but i think h4 is
definitely better than h3 and it is
never easy to play such a movie robert
yeah
so it forces black's hand in a way
go ahead robert that's an amazing move i
mean i think
we kept on h3 in like eight different
variations but it was all h3 give my
king a space so i can't get background
checkmated but h4 does that and more as
we keep talking about h5 for white to
kick that queen away and to
um then get the g4 square once again you
would love to play bishop g4 but now
that as we're seeing h5 for black is not
quite as nice because white controls the
g5 square and whether that's putting the
bishop on g5 bishop e3 bishop g5 which
is possible another idea uh but queen g5
right away looks really strong and
because black has committed the pawn
structure
all those pawns in the light squares
that means that
white can go dancing and prancing around
those pawns and there's nothing black
can really
do yo yeah
wow wow fabiano
looks a little surprised by this h4
strike from hikaru
he has 30 minutes to make 13 moves so
again
nothing egregious as far as time
pressure goes in this game but
30 minutes could go real fast if you're
uh
if you're not careful especially if the
position gets as uh as wild as this one
might become yeah and the thing is with
every move hicaro is posing
a a new challenge and a new decision
like and he does that so incredibly well
in blitz where he he always forces you
to make these decisions which are
ridiculously time consuming and here's
another one you know the move h5 may
seem natural but again it weakens g5 you
also have the move h6 here
the question is what is the lesser evil
is the lesser evil to allow white to
play h5 which ikaro almost certainly
would in this situation and play like
queen d6 um but then the bishop from d1
it waltzes into g4 and white's pieces
start to unfurl yeah don't you touch
that
although in theory you couldn't go there
by the way now that kh2 was there so
that
it wasn't losing in one move by the way
but if you were looking at fabiano's
body language and the way he just kind
of responded
i think he did miss h4 and the other
reason h4 gets credit for hikaru is it's
exactly the move that would be the
counter to queen g6 right
knight to c5 was the move we had spent a
lot of time looking at here for black
as a means to improve the one piece that
isn't really playing very well for
black's team at this time right it's
kind of a donkey on b7 so let's make it
a real horse but fabiano didn't and we
were applauding queen g6 right
in all fairness it freed a different
route for the night and the queen looked
like it was putting pressure there but
it's like as far as heavyweight boxers
right footwork one counter punch equals
another counter punch h4 is exactly the
kind of move you applaud for a
karnakamura because that queen suddenly
is a target on g6
and this move would not have been played
if not for queen g6 it's a fantastic
move yeah and now i regret agreeing with
queen to g6 i like my knight c5 to e6
just yeah calmly trade off some pieces
yeah see how white is ever going to win
uh but just
hikara trying to give his bishop on d1
this g4 square it's so important because
if his bishop can get out to g4 then
it's aiming to go to e6 it controls the
f5 square all that stuff so
i think that fabi's in quite a deal of
danger here and it's not just the knight
on b7 we're criticizing that piece it's
also the bishop on d3 that it
looks good there and it has helped
threaten some checkmate patterns
but it's there to stay and it can't
attack anything and it's like away from
many of the critical light squares in
black's side right e6 there f5 that
bishop on d3 is not helping out and this
is now becoming a real problem for
fabiano so if he feels that instead of
allowing h5 he should play it himself
and offer this queen trade which
honestly doesn't look very good but at
the same time after the queen trade i
need to protect my h5 pawn with g6 so
how does white end up crashing through
white does look like uh he has the
better position caro does here but where
is the the knockout the pawn g5 could
also become a target later it's hard to
untangle
yeah
so maybe this will be what he what he
has to go for he being fabiano
um at the same time
i don't know that black has a ton of
winning chances in this in this one
either right this is this is a position
where white can probably also set
kind of safely
and these dark squares i don't have any
pieces on them yet but you know what i
want i want to i want to find a way to
get in on this action right you know
what i'm talking about
here and by the way if i put that bishop
on f6 and my knights on f2 and i get g4
anyway
obviously there's a lot of work to do
there and and players like fabiano are
accurate in how they apply pressure to
prevent coordination but this is the
worry you have when you have a rook
facing miners right donya positions with
holes positions that are closed
positions with maneuverings that can
happen on diagonals because the rooks
are great but like robert said they're
already ideal like they can't really get
any better but the minor pieces sure can
yeah and robert made a great point about
the bishop on d3 it almost feels like
black doesn't have a light-squared
bishop right i mean it's a great poland
if it was there right i mean at some
point it was fulfilling this crucial
duty of uh pressuring the f1 square but
now
that's gotten stale
you know that's that's all it's doing
and you know it's like carly rae jepsen
you know you released call me maybe and
now here's the now how about call me
later call me maybe exactly now it's
time to
you know to produce other stuff and yet
it can because it's imprisoned i'm
pushing back stop stop shaking your head
robert carly rae jefferson is a gift to
the musical world i think just call me
maybe it's a great
if anyone wants to share this clip if
you're out there somebody you have a
loose connection six degrees of carly
rae jepsen get a hold of her and let her
know that we know we know she likes
chess she's played chess hey my
statement was complimentary at the end
of the day that bishop on d3 i've seen
worse bishops
back
here's my number all right here we go
bobby pogue the bear with queen g6 he
sure did um
he's in time trouble now yeah he's in
real time trouble and he might be in
trouble and that would not be
bad
hess was not happy though shout out to
will
one of our one of our guys working super
hard emotion best 2015 album there you
go see
well i can't really agree with chat it
goes against my brand yeah but okay i'll
make i'll make the chat a deal put put
some effort into calling you ready
jefferson go ahead i'll listen to some
more songs tonight okay all right in
exchange for people to call give me a
pass
i will listen to
call me maybe this is crazy
but bobby might have missed h4
and uh
his position could get shady
okay it's seriously though this is
chances might be slim
oh whatever you say marshall just make
sure it matters even though i mean i
think the next time he'll stand up from
the board we'll be after before okay
okay he needs to be careful not to lose
himself in the comments somebody help me
please
somebody he's only got one moment yeah
so he better own it yeah he'll need to
marshal all of his pieces
especially that night on b7
okay let's back up to the bird's eye
view and look at all three games at
where they stand in progress again i
said three on purpose that wasn't a
mistake if you just tuned in yonda
pandashi drew his game with no real
effort against dingley red maid despite
having white
although if fabiano gets in trouble here
and somehow loses to nakamura he will he
will look like he played it a hundred
percent correctly and that he started
the back half calmly
didn't do anything crazy maintained his
lead to prepare for the battle with
carwana tomorrow
um
this does not look like a fobby who's
happy to be in this position
oh he completely missed h4 and obviously
we didn't even mention it while we've
been analyzing
and it's a great move by a car it's
actually one of the best moves of the
entire tournament it's just it's a
shocker and it came at the perfect time
for him because he is over an hour on
the clock and he's feeling this position
he went knight h1 he's doing everything
that could be asked from him from what
this position demands so when we see h4
here threatening h5 bobby knows that
it's now or never for him because if he
doesn't play h5 he car has it pre-moved
yeah right like i'm gonna play h5 unless
i legally can't do that but if if i do
that do i still have good chances to
survive and the answer apparently is yes
and i also don't really see too many
other appealing ideas for fabi because
if you allow h5 the bishop gets to g4
just feels like more of white's pieces
are coming in not that i love the end
game without the queens but i just don't
like the look of this bishop coming to
g4 the next bishop can come to g3 it
just feels like all of white's pieces
are coming to life
no you're totally right as much as
you don't want the end game the more we
look at the position
it doesn't look like fabiano has a
choice here dania i mean his time
situation is becoming a disaster yep
it's really becoming a disaster
13 moves i mean
he's thought for about
eight or nine more minutes on this move
and you can just sense the agony and he
can't decide he can't make a decision
he doesn't like anything
that he sees and you can't really blame
him
it's particularly frustrating for
fabiano too because he knows how much
this game matters in regards to the
overall tournament standings right this
not like you want to lose any game in
the candidates to anybody
but
knowing that his uh
the person he's chasing is getting a
little bit of help from time to time
from from example richard report in the
previous game
yesterday
he can't afford to slip in a game like
this to nakamura we actually caught up
with fabiano and got his thoughts his
candid thoughts on just how he felt
after seeing the way report uh
approached yonda pomneshi in round seven
i i felt kind of sick to be honest
i mean it's one of the most shocking
games i've seen from a top player in a
long time it's like the line that's
played is known it's been known for like
a decade that it's a draw
like you you don't really go for this
with white and if you do go for it you
take a draw because uh f3 is just worse
for white
once you end up in that situation that
like your preparation has gone wrong
he's down an hour on the clock and he's
out of preparation why is he going for
this i mean it's totally insane yeah
it's like um
it's like some sort of hypnosis or
something right because i can't explain
otherwise
you know i want to start with you donya
because
robert and i have talked a lot about
this at this point given what we saw
yesterday you were watching as a fan
seeing what was happening in report and
upon rishi but as a player have you ever
been in a spot where you felt sick
by what was going on
on a board not your own game where you
felt frustrated by how someone was
approaching maybe a player in an event
you were trying to catch someone
standing you ever been in that spot
where you just felt so torn up by
something you couldn't control
100 i mean and obviously more than once
and i you know i'll think of some
stories but
it's a particular kind of agony when you
know that cynical side of your brain
always plays out the most undesirable
scenarios you're going to the last round
you know let's say you're half a point
ahead of the the rest of the field and
you decide to make a quick drawing
you're like that guy that guy's who's
half a point behind me he isn't going to
win with black yeah it's going to be
fine and then by the time you look it's
move 15 and somehow black is winning you
know it's an exchange french and yet
black is a huge advantage it always
seems to happen like that i mean that's
murphy's law
so it's a universally shared experience
i want to get your thoughts on that
again robert but one more comment on
that is
what else so knowing how you felt in
your own games and then knowing how fabi
said he felt what were you thinking as
you saw report kind of crumble in terms
of his prep right you're watching yonda
pandashi at one point take a point and a
half lead over caron as a fan yesterday
before you hopped on your plane what was
your take on that game
it i mean it was
i don't think quite as shocking to me as
it was to fabi because he's actually
playing the tournament
i think i understood it from the
perspective of
richard report wanting to
influence the course of the tournament
it was the last game of the first half
of the tournament he had the white
pieces
and i hate to use this phrase because i
think it's so overused that i really do
think it applies here
i think his emotions got the better of
him yeah and i think his
his desire for
uh to create a fight with the white
piece is to not let jan you know just
bail the game out right out of opening
preparation yeah it superseded his
rational thinking and
that happens to everybody but i think it
happened in a very clear way
in his game
well robert you uh
you know what bobby said yesterday you
were here and now he's in this tough
spot um
what do you think is going through his
head right now you think fabi has the
ability to just stay focused here and
not be get emotional himself think about
what's at stake outside of the what's on
the board or
do you think he might he might start
making some rash decisions well he just
moved as soon as you asked me the
question he brought his knight to c5 and
we saw the eval bar start going up in
white's favor now
i think that it's not misleading
obviously we are starting to like hit
cars position yeah but it's really a
complex position so it's not one of
these plus two advantages where you're
just like okay i see how white can do no
wrong and it's just like easy to press
forward
it's still really
a tough position for both sides
i do like white's bishop on d1 coming
out but to answer the question to take a
step back for fabiano i mean he knew
this was going to be a tough game this
never was going to be an easy game
and
um you know he came prepared quite
deeply it would appear but he started a
misstep but just because the nature of
the position and i asked you both
earlier who does it favor to have a long
line of preparation does a favor hit
karu does it favor fabiano and hikaru
does have the first move advantage he
has a position where he has an imbalance
and based on what we're seeing here it's
clear that hikaru won
the opening he's been ahead on the clock
all game bobby's in really bad time
trouble with only 18 minutes left after
27 moves
so maybe fabiano he might regret not
going for the berlin like we've seen in
the rapids we're making a joke about it
but perhaps there was something a little
more solid a little less
confrontational that he could have
played that
would allow him just to have a slight
disadvantage but one that wasn't like
so
combative and hard to play
maybe in the end he'll be regretting not
i guess taking a page out of john's book
who clearly made a concerted effort to
start the back half off calmly
patiently and
he was white so i think there's a
different type of criticism that you
know could come to to yonder palmness
you should this
should this uh event not go his way but
but still right now jan looks like uh
kind of smartly so just wanted to
make sure he didn't do any
self-inflicted damage and see what
happened in nakamura car want it because
hikara might become yonder palmerishi's
best friend at the end of this day and
we can't forget that
magnus if we take him at his word he
said he'd only play alireza and that's
one of the prevailing storylines that
there's a huge fight for second place
especially if hikaru can beat fabiano
he'd only be a half point behind fabiano
if report or duda win their game there
would be one point behind fabian and
still get to play him and so out of the
corner of my eye i've been keeping a
look at this report due to a game yep
and that one's also interesting so i
think these players they kind of can
thank magnus in a way
because they're like okay so i'm not
gonna get first place
but if akaru can beat fabiano and things
happen here maybe i get second place and
maybe then i can play a
kind of odd world championship match
it would be odd of course if magnus
carlson was not competing in the world
championship match but taking him at his
word
and
a lot of people taking him seriously
that wouldn't that be interesting if we
had a match of completely unexpected
players uh yonda pomnishi and somebody
else from this event competing for a
world title that would be nuts this
would be the only candidates or
something like that
has ever happened obviously
well h5 has been played on the board not
quite relayed yet here to us apparently
but uh we saw hikaru push the h pawn
and the wheels are starting to come off
the wheels are starting to come off a
little bit for caruana if that queen has
to leave the g4 square
that's the problem
is that the bishop fills it
and now there's pressure on these
squares now the knight coming to c5 does
protect immediate threats we see h5 now
on the board
and uh
yeah fabby's settling into yet another
thing
and every second right now is
you know brings him further into queen's
devastating time pressure
and a big problem for fabiano is that
he had his queen on d6 and his knight on
b7 instead of just bring his knight to
c5 immediately which he could have done
he has the same position but white's
pawn
is all the way up on h5 right so white
got several free tempe essentially and
very useful ones at that because
now hikaru can
get his bishop to g4
so
it's i don't know it's a nice turn of
events for hikaru one for
fabiano that i think he wishes he could
take back
yeah and i mean
hikaru you can just sense he's drinking
his water he got up from the ward
several times
and the kicker is that he has an hour on
his clock but he's done all of this he's
found h4
and it's like he's spent no time and now
he's got
oceans of time
to figure out
you know the next three or four critical
moves right which
will potentially further increase his
already burgeoning advantage
and i think that there's a trap that
players can fall into when they're well
ahead in the clock they're starting to
feel the position like let me put
pressure on my opponent on the clock in
addition to the board and they start
playing a little too fast right we've
uh seen yana palmistry do that
in a number of games where he just like
feels like he's in stride let's just
keep going with it and
you know here at karu he made a quick
move bishop g4
and he's playing
he's playing quite fast
but he's not rushing you know you're
saying that i think there's a huge
difference between the two moves
spending two three minutes
is playing confidently but not rushing
spending five seconds
that would be succumbing to that
temptation that's right very important
difference between those two modes of
playing
and ikaro is a i mean his time
management is excellent yeah no general
that's the thing about him and we've
seen him do that in bullet chess
championships in all sorts of speeches
champion blitz events where he can play
instantly and play super well he
you know people were saying oh you know
he hasn't played classical chess all
this but he has been working on his
chest by playing so many of the top
players in the world in all sorts of
formats so we see now the position up to
speed
hikar bars bishop out to g4
and i mean what does fabi even do here
he can bring his rook up one square to
f6 to stop you know pieces coming e6 at
some point but it just feels like bobby
has no plan whatsoever and earlier we
were asking how ikaru improves his
position now that path has become
crystal clear i mean queen e3
bishop g3
b4 and all of these other moves knight
h1 to f2 so the more you look at this
position the clearer it becomes
that white now has this very very
obvious pathway toward activating all of
his minor pieces and if he does that the
moment he does that black is totally and
utterly busted
i would go so far as to say that this
position is now almost lost for black
maybe flat out lost
wow fabiano
thinking hard he might agree with you i
mean he might have to play that e3 move
at some point right that earlier
we were telling how it doesn't work and
it may not work anyway but when you get
into a position like this sometimes you
just have to fling pieces at your
opponent and hope that they go wrong so
you know fabiano he's he's trying to
calculate
but
the current situation is such that
calculation might not even help him at
this point right he is in a position
that is that much worse and it is plus
two for white i was just saying earlier
how you know it's not there's no clear
path to victory for ikaru but it's
obvious the trajectory of the game is
going his way he's bringing his pieces
out and fabiano really doesn't have too
many moves that i can see
yeah it's crazy how quickly things took
a turn and that's what all
what even adds to the brilliance of h4
yeah the fact that it it turned the game
around within like four moves turn it
around
knew as soon as you played it i think
that yeah he played h4 and he got up
from the board you could tell i think he
knew that fabiano likely missed this
move he screwed the pieces he screwed
the piece in oh he got up he he knew
right away
that uh that this was gonna spell
disaster
probably you know if we back up to the
moment that we were talking about
where h5 maybe should have been played
by black
i think that was such a hard thing to
play robert because getting the queens
off the board in some ways almost feels
worse right of course it's not
objectively we saw the computer saying
that this is a safer way for black to
play but i think maybe from fabi's
perspective it was like getting the
queens off the board knowing that really
only white can maybe win this end game
with maneuverings felt like a harder
commitment to make
than keeping it
in the complex nature that is with the
queens on the board but the problem is
as daniel was just saying like now
you're almost going as far as saying
that black is lost because with the
bishop coming out you might want to have
a take back here yeah and if he was
afraid about the bishop on f2 going to
g5 which was another possibility instead
of the queen trade after black played h5
it's you're giving up one of these
g-squares for the bishop anyway so uh it
seems that he picked the worst bishop to
allow out of the box and the bishop one
f2 is still getting involved in the game
so it's like you have both bishops in
rather than just one and that's going to
cause fabiano he's down under 15 minutes
and it's the 29th move so that's barely
over one minute per move and in this
position it's like such a complex battle
still that fabinho really just doesn't
have time
you could have 15 minutes for one move
in this position and burn it very
quickly
this is super tough
incredible yeah as as we've said before
everyone the time control is
60 minutes added after move 40. so the
reason we keep saying 11 moves to go on
move 29
you are uh faced with only 14 minutes to
make 11 moves
to get that extra hour on the clock
which at this point bobby could
desperately use
another 16 minutes to try to navigate
the complicated position
this is just shocking kind of takes the
air out of the room if you're if you're
team caruana right you've got your uh
your fellow american countrymen hikaru
nakamura
not fellow olympia teammate as we know
hikaru not going to play in the in the
uh
olympia coming up next month but
these guys have played on many usa teams
together and had many many battles
rivals for many many years and right now
this is not a game that you want to give
to your rival
with so much at stake i said is one bit
of
good news consolation for fabiano is
that yandhru so he needs to beat yon
tomorrow no matter what no matter what
yeah if he's a full point behind and he
wins that game he catches up on the spot
so
obviously father did not come today
wanting to lose he probably didn't think
that he was going to lose he was
confident and he isn't he's not it's not
over obviously this game is far from
over but i think that you can at least
lean back and like look i have to beat
yon anyway yeah so now i'll be tied with
him rather than in the lead uh but as we
look at this position
what i'm trying to figure out is what's
white's threat because you're gonna have
to move this bishop from f2 at some
point and then i will immediately play
rook f1 so i'm just going to hopefully
get some kind of counter play make
white's life difficult and we should
remember that's a rook and two pawn
for two minor pieces yeah if i have to
give a rook for a minor piece but i also
got a third pawn in the process three
pawns is often pretty good compensation
for a minor piece so there are going to
be possibilities here for fabiano to
kind of not bail out but just try to
give away some material
and that allows him to breathe a new
sigh of relief and have some chances
himself
yeah yeah if you're good no i was only
going to add that i think queen e3 might
be one of those stabilizing moves that
prevents a lot of these ideas but
i'm going to say if you're yonder palm
rishi like you said uh robert the good
news if you're team caruana is that even
if you lost this game you're only a full
point behind if you're going to pump
this year you're like man if only i got
a win against stingley ren this would be
over
right point and a half league could clip
it and ship it at that point uh the
point and a half would have been
insurmountable even if he did lose to
carl to paviano so um are you okay with
danny what i don't think john de palma
has ever lost to five out of corner in
classical chess
really there's a first time for
everything but if i'm remembering
correctly quagmire's never beaten yawn
in a classical game wow well that is a
stat that uh fabiano would
desperately hope to change tomorrow
regardless of how this game turns out uh
let's let's back up here and and uh take
a take a reset at the other two games
still in progress because we're being
told that richard report also
has earned not just our love for his
style and beautiful red jacket but a
much better position on the board
against young christoph duda
wow how the landscape of that position
has changed it's crazy
it's almost like you think this is a
different game from what we saw five
moves ago you know what i game i think
it is yana pomshi against yanchez stuff
dude yeah where there was a pawn on g5
and that is what buried duda and right
now is upon g5 an open h file moves that
i would consider from the white side
would be to get my pieces on the h file
i'm wondering if i should just start
like the rook h1 and king g1 and bring
all the pieces in for checkmate but i
also can see a kind of near future for
black to go rook e6 the king can then
run king fa king e7 so if you think
you're going to check mate well the
king's just going to run away from the
mating box
i i think we should analyze to see what
happened here right i think we have yeah
let's go back all three of us would like
to do that am i speaking for everyone so
after knight takes she fought well no we
started yeah
i was going to mention this move but i
wasn't taking it seriously because it
opens the age file
but it means that
uh
young kristoff saw that he didn't just
have to play g6 but maybe he didn't see
that he had a chance for a five as
robert pointed out and instead blocked
the checkmate by interposing but this is
not a move that the computer likes very
much after hxg bishop c8 rook g2
oh it's funny the computer wants f6 no
human in the history of humanity
whatever makes such a move and allowed
g6
it doesn't seem right oh now of course
the obvious king of fate yes oh yeah of
course
yes if you want to king e7
rook h8 rook h3 you didn't see that in
advance
um but apparently that was the idea my
hairs are greying yeah brain isn't what
it used to be
but uh
but yeah no jokes aside where the
sarcasm meter just to clarify for none
of us really believe that that's a
that's a reasonable thing to expect uh
young christoph to have found but he
doesn't he plays rookie seven and now
after we see reports
queen to
f3 bring maybe the g3 square i don't
know
yeah
it's one of those multi-purpose moves
where his next move is going to depend
very very heavily on what defensive
construction
uh jkd is going to choose because one of
the benefits of putting the queen on the
file as we discussed robert pointed out
the idea of lagging rookie six if that
happens now then you can meet that with
the very nasty move rook f1
throwing a you know a spanner in the
works because now
by defending f7 black is simultaneously
blocking
the king's pathway to salvation yeah now
you have moves like this and quickly
getting on the h file
yeah no it feels like all of white's
pieces are coming to the party the one
piece that's not involved is the knight
but another thing that queen f3 does is
it vacates the g3 square that's a bit
far away but knight e2 knight g3 if you
want to bring that knight in and knight
to h5 things like that so
it's a long way it's a long journey but
it's just another thing that i'm noting
so queen f3 looks like a very nice move
a kind of precise move from
report just making sure that king's not
running away as we keep talking with
rook f1 will force a piece onto e7 in
many of these positions and that's the
escape square that black needs
so hard to face such a move
yeah queen of three is a super i like
robert's idea of 92 knight g3 a lot
that's a
i think that's a very clear reason to
have played queen to f3
his clock though is a little bit
concerning 25 minutes for
15 moves yeah
yep
so
he'll have to put a move on a little bit
although i think that very soon dudeo
will be the person down on the clock
right i agreed yes exactly
yeah yes the 40 will become a four
especially after the move queen of three
that is a
that's a really nice move
that's a nice move and once again
there's this move f6 which is incredibly
ridiculous because after g6 it looks
even worse now
yeah how are you how are you not made
how are you inviting this idea but
although actually after f6 i just take
an f6 maybe i
uh but
doesn't g6
lead to force mate with queen h5 like
how does black defend against that i
thought like the king was running away
but now i'm all right we gotta look at
it again okay f6 oh your queen gets
trapped look at
this show me what you're thinking
because i can't follow you grandma
g6
uh rook c7
rook c7
queen h5
king f8 no queen h8 check king e7 queen
takes pawn king e6 and your queen gets
trapped because you go to the h5 rook h8
can we just walk out now and let the
computers play the rest of the game sure
let's explore madrid
goodbye madrid
so again it started with and then they
went into their head i was with you chad
i was also lost i couldn't follow the
line they were thinking about but that
is an insane idea the computer is
suggesting f6 here and again
white doesn't take the pawn
right now you're starting to open up
your own this also looks terrible
it also looks terrible but after brook
f7 it's actually
hard to continue because if you just
take everything and trade here at the
end of these lines black is getting
things like queen h4 check and that just
feels a little scary so the computer in
this position suggesting f6
is bananas and it's because of that
bleeping line
and
it's like you don't have to bring your
queen up and get it trapped obviously
but like
rook c7 by itself still looks bad for
black right that knight can go from e2
to g3 and so on so yeah just the thought
of allowing upon the g6 feels incredibly
wrong
yeah
that's unplayable they were human
if someone finds that idea at the board
it's time for the arbiter to check them
the next time they go to the restroom
all right well
let's let's back up and take a quick
look at where all three games stand we
do owe ali raza furuja and team river
job off a check-in we'll probably do
that on the other side
of a quick break uh assuming that
fabiano is still holding against the
kara nakamura i think he will be but
that advantage looks like it is
increasing
uh for the
the other american i don't mean that in
that i'm putting fabiano ahead of
hickory in the tournament but as far as
the standings go yes fabiano is is in
first place the leading american at this
point but right now it's the other guy
in third place who might be about to
shake things up big time
uh so we're gonna we're gonna take a
quick break and come back to that action
but before we do remind you that when
the candidates is over
there are still
a lot of chess events to watch july 9th
and 10th is our next big celebrity chess
tournament if you will pog champ style
it's blitz champs though with larry
fitzgerald nfl hall of famer amari
cooper nfl pro bowler kayvon thibodeau
top five draft pick so many great
players in this event going to be a ton
of fun make sure you tune in on that
weekend july 9th and 10th uh as we are
raising a hundred thousand dollars for
charity hundred thousand dollars in
prizes going to the charities of these
guys choices and and there are other
players in the event as well so all
right when we return we probably will
dive right back in
to the uh carwana game right now we're
going to leave it with young christoph
duda as he takes a think and fabiano
right there trying to hold this one
against his fellow countrymen our
coverage from madrid returns in a moment
don't go anywhere
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less accurate than them in every
stage yeah man that that stings a little
bit okay do the more game review okay
yeah thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks
i gotta stop playing cats on twitter oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best let's go to
uh tactics
mates
probably need to work on these ones yep
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taking
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against tess
rook there for rookie too
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
the feed a candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger yon napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs.com
grand swiss
ali rezafaruja won the grand swiss
turned the heads of everyone in doing so
and has become the youngest player in
history to cross the 2800 evo rating
barrier he would become the youngest
world chess champion of all time should
he win the candidates and ultimately the
world chess championship match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss
the u.s number one and third highest
rated player in the history of our game
is also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlson
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
priest cycle
grand master hikaru nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard rapport the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master tamor
rajaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one
punched his ticket by ousting none other
than world champion magnus carlson in
the semi-finals of that event
judah would ultimately defeat karjakin
in the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grandmaster dingley
rent
dingley wren takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 fee day rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
[Music]
wanna play check us online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grand master chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
and we are back here round date for the
2022 f8 candidates in madrid it's the
palacio de centonia
we have a live audience in attendance
daily
it's a ton of fun here a beautiful
beautiful and historic building where
some historic
some historic bleep is going down here
some historic stuff happening
uh no matter what happens at the end of
this event we will have a lot of things
to talk about that will affect the
future of chess history
could a crazy scenario where someone
like ikara nakamura gets second place
competes for a world championship title
because magnus carlson doesn't play who
knows
fabiano carwana obviously wants another
chance at the king
um
take more of her job i was just happy to
be here no i'm just kidding um
what do we got what do we got to talk
about right now guys so many changes in
the nakamura karwani game i mean yeah i
think we got to go to there the java of
the perugia game is interesting but yeah
we have to go to the game with the
player entering the round second place
and rook f5 was last played but the
queens are off right when we went to
break the queens were still on the board
so i guess we gotta go back in time a
little bit here yeah so fabby initiated
the queen trade with queen d6 to f4 he
judged and hikaru did play this
stabilizing queen e3 move threatening
bishop g3 so
you know last last chance for fabby to
trade queens he goes for it and then gar
makes his very interesting move knight
e6
uh which some people in the chat didn't
particularly like it makes sense i mean
he's trading off the knight on c5
forcibly yep
i think it's a simplifying move it does
make sense it makes a lot of sense yeah
and then he wins another bond
but probably trying to win it back
from from white's perspective getting
rid of that pawn is so key to eventually
maybe getting rid of all of black
stranglehold over the center here uh he
may lose the h5 pawn but the two miners
will will outplay the rooks if they can
just get loose right h1 and f2 are not
the desired squares for nakamura's minor
pieces and robert we were talking about
this yesterday when it comes to
evaluating these imbalanced material
positions queen versus two rooks miners
versus a rook a single pawn is less
important than activity and the
initiative right so fabi's going to take
that pawn but hikaru's idea this is
going as planned he wants to get out
get out eventually now he's going to get
at this pond which is partly what
happened when he won the d5 pawn
and uh looking more and more like only
hikaru can win this game oh for sure
only
excuse me picard can win but we're also
getting to a position kind of what i was
hit to get earlier where maybe fabiano
will be in a bit of trouble but he could
sacrifice a rook for a minor piece and a
pawn so he has two pawns and a rook for
a knight and bishop and it's not clear
how hikar is going to start scooping up
the queen side pawns for example you can
attack the base pawn upon chain is only
as strong as his base pawn a6 can be
defended or pushed because b5 is
defended by the other rook so black's
rooks are not really harmonious but at
the same time how does white proceed you
should go after the e4 pawn that's for
sure but taking on e4 could allow some
liquidation that may in fact help
fabiano's chances
okay so let's let's
how does a line like that look so let's
say white plays
i don't know the move i was thinking he
played bishop d4 first you could also
play knight g3 first but then if the
rook comes to g5 i actually can't move
by bishop so i want to do this one first
you can't play rook g5 to prevent knight
g3 because of bishop e3 and you can't
play rogue g4 because of knight f2 so
wherever you go there's some sort of a
fork okay so bishop d4
so rook f5 beige book
okay so this threatens rook f1
i think we go for this
right
and so are you actually threatening
movement broken 54 on the board yeah wow
so let's say i bring my rook back
somewhere let's go to f8 okay okay
doesn't matter okay
if you take on e4 i immediately have
rook for one check and i can start
trading rooks and okay i see so the
pieces start coming off and your your
idea is that if that happens just like i
said
white spawn didn't matter if if white
could get the initiative here black
spawn doesn't matter if black can start
getting the initiative
right yeah you
what black really wants to do is just
get rid of white's pawns right
at this point
carwana is in hold the game mode if you
can simplify and get a draw
maintaining only a half a point deficit
versus yonder pannashi he'd probably be
feeling very happy about that well the
short-term goal is to get to move 40
without dropping a roku or the pawn on
e4 and that's a very tall order to begin
with he's got five minutes sorry five
minutes and 50 seconds to be exact to
make four
moves and these are maybe the biggest
four moves of his candidates
campaign at this point
yeah can he tamp down this rapidly
developing initiative and rook hf5 i
think is obligatory
you cannot allow
and knight g3 is a huge threat like if
you wrote g5 there's again this bishop
e3 move yep so i think fabi has to save
some time and play it immediately and i
think he's about to do it
yeah i think maybe he's preparing his
next move because he anticipates knight
g3 and he's thinking okay my rook
doesn't have many squares it has to go
to f7 or f8 is there a difference and
maybe i can play the follow-up quickly
because ideally you you
think on your opponent's time yeah so
rook f5 i think that as you said you
have to play this move and then he's
trying to spot the difference between
rook f7 or convey
so rook hf5 we're anticipating knight to
g3 might happen
the rook comes back to f8 what else
would hikaru go for here besides taking
the pawn let's analyze that
maybe you move like rookie three to get
the off of the first drink so that
after knight takes e4 you've taken the
sting out of rook f1 check largely oh i
can't defend if i'm on f8
if i'm on if i'm on f7 i could play rook
e7
right
can you play rook c8 here and just chase
the bishop around i know that looks like
it allows bishop b7 to win a6 but
actually i think i might want you to
take that pawn to give my rook some
activity down
okay eight you want to come around that
way yeah
and i don't want to take this pawn
i don't think you do no
so if you go for it i'm gonna of course
trade pieces
and after you take with your knight this
is a type of position where i feel like
it's gonna be hard to
target black's pawns the two rooks will
always defend and obviously white is
better than playing for a win but i do
feel like there are some pretty decent
chances for black to hold just because
it's hard to organize all of your pieces
at one particular pawn
god
yeah fascinating and another just
really quickly another issue with such
positions is that if you're not careful
you will allow the rooks can always get
active right there's always an inkling
of hope when one side has two rooks and
the other side has only one
yeah
so you don't want to trade pieces here
until you can really corral all the
pawns so bishop e7 might be the move
and after
oh i can't even play rook b8
that's just savage fishing
e5 bishop e5
bishop e5 is instead of the move instead
of bishop takes a sex yeah
[Music]
everywhere they're everywhere gosh
seeming pretty relaxed there
yeah he's swiveling around in his chair
he's just sort of waiting for fabi to
move but he hasn't put on his coat he
hasn't put on his coat yet so he knows
the game is not over
bobby only has three minutes to make
four moves or this game will be over uh
that's less than a minute of move rook h
f5 on the board
as anticipated
and we adjust yep and we know that
fabiano caruana is now i think the third
highest rated blitz player in the world
so yeah his blitz skills have really
improved throughout the last couple
years so don't be fooled by some of
those older notions about fabiano you
know he has
four moves to make and he has plenty of
time to do it based on his skill in all
disciplines
i think like you said he probably was
calculating not just rook hf5 but what
his immediate response will be on knight
to g3 definitely um
and then uh
car is about to return that favor though
he will i think likely want to use some
time here
to make sure that before he blitzes the
moves out we keep talking about this a
lot right you don't want to play blitz
chess just because your opponent has to
as much as you may be the you know the
best blitz player one of the best
players in the world if you're a car the
smart thing to do is to really make sure
that you've zoned in
on what you want your next line to be
before you put fabiano back on the clock
the interesting thing i think a lot of
people might not know this back when
hicaro was uh like 20 in the 2600s
during uh when the dinosaurs roamed the
earth
and you know the woolly mammoths uh were
destroyed by meaty meteor yeah uh hikari
used to have a problem of playing too
quickly in in late middle games
especially in winning positions and
there was a
pretty well known game at the time
around 2005 or 2006 where he lost
uh to josh fudell in round one of a u.s
championship
and i think i read in an interview that
um that game was like a light bulb
moment for him and ever since then he
didn't you know he he still has really
good time management he plays fast at
times but like i said earlier
he never rushes he he's discipline
always prevails and i think we're seeing
that here yeah
it's hard when you grow up you know
literally
calculating people off the board
faster than them by a mile right i mean
uh
it's hard to develop that that muscle
until like you said a light bulb moment
right something happens that makes you
hit rock bottom so to speak in regards
to really forcing yourself to slow down
and develop the maturity that we're
seeing here from hey car because
regardless of whether fabiano has some
decent holding chances he knows this is
his game to win right now and he needs
to be accurate if he's going to keep the
pressure
and figure out a way to convert and i
wonder how his memory of this tournament
can impact him because he lost round one
to fabiano of course he wants revenge he
then beat rajabov but after that he had
that game against jan upon machine where
he had actually the same advantage
according to the evo bar as we have
right here right the same about
approximate evaluation a very different
type of position yeah in that game it
was even material uh here it's in
material and balance where white is
probably gonna be ahead uh but i wonder
if you sort of question yourself a
little bit after slipping yeah where
you're like i i i obviously confident
that i'm better here but can i prove
that advantage so let me slow down take
my time and he has plenty of time left
42 plus minutes for four moves i mean
yeah he's got an eternity and especially
with the speed he calculates he can win
a title tuesday in that time
and he has many many times he wishes
maybe he could draw some arrows on the
board we need to have someone make a
meme where hikaru is drawing arrows on
the physical board right now with his
mind drawing drawing arrows
in his head the genius that is a karo
nakamura on display often when he's
streaming
um
okay well
taking his time fabiano will only have
three minutes on the clock his time
remaining before having to make four
more moves and reach time control
and i think hikar i mean you can see his
eyes they look like they're at the e4
square that pawn
because he's trying to
correctly assess
what trades are acceptable for his
winning chances yeah the last thing you
want to do is just start mindlessly
taking upon allowing some liquidation
and it's the wrong pieces coming off the
board for your opportunity to win the
game so yeah he's doing the exact right
thing and we have somebody here
rooting for fabi rooting for bobby bobby
you can draw this come on hundred
percent
bobby's got a lot of love in chad we
know that when he bob's his head i can
just hear takes takes no we all that's
true we all hear it takes takes takes
takes
yeah i mean obviously icaru has more
fans around the world than maybe any top
chess player in the world these days
with his streaming and content career uh
but we know that fabiano has a ton of
fans in our community so we see a lot of
support coming in for him whenever
hikaro looks to the side he's speaking
to chad
right
but yeah bobby earned a lot of love uh
well yours i love as a player also was
in the commentary booth and i think a
lot of fans
didn't think it was the stupidest belief
they'd ever seen to have fabiano
commentate during the world championship
but we don't want him back there we want
him competing for the title but uh no
matter what even even maybe hikaru wants
that from a content perspective to be
honest but ikaro's job as a professional
is to make sure that he does everything
he can to take down fabiano caruana in
this game and right now he just might do
it
and if his car can go on a winning
streak if he can start here and fabi
beats yan that's actually what hikar
would want because hikaru that's that's
the recipe that is the improbable recipe
we talked about it would be if a car
wins this game and fabi takes down yan
and then hikara can start winning
several games in a row that's the exact
recipe for him to catch up and have a
chance at first place and
we were talking about this i think with
maurice ashley
danny yeah how
how if there's one player who can just
suddenly go on this crazy hot stream
called it yeah and of course there's
john de palma who's already done that
but if somebody who hasn't done it yet
it's
yeah well hickory was in studio
yesterday we asked him how he how he's
played so far he said you know i think
i'm playing pretty well he feels on form
right and so we were walking home with
maurice yesterday and we all kind of we
had that conversation okay besides jan
and fabi we were just saying who's the
other player who might catch fire and we
all kind of said like i feel like it
would be hikaru if one person was going
to get on a roll given how what we've
seen to this point how he's played what
his potential is and if it started with
a win
on the back half go ahead daniel and
here's another another thing to chew on
the fact that
yes sikaru
you know didn't convert that very
promising position against ion but the
fact that he had that promising position
how many people this tournament have had
a plus two or plus two point five
position against nepo
i don't i think might be the elviano and
fabian
yeah and
that was oh that was a wild game with
this um
knight g4 kind of
gamble that fabiano took it paid off he
wasn't even i would argue that that
position was
very wild i mean hikara was flat out
right outplaying him at some point
and when you know you have a position
like that against the leader of the
tournament that that says a lot about
your form so i think hikaru extracted
the positives out of that game as he
plays knight f2 so that's what he was
thinking about
and
wow and that's exactly what we're saying
so there was a little bit of difference
between knight f2 and knight g3 but
knight f2 actually threatened to trap
the rook on f4 so that's why the rook
went back to f7 to clear space on the
file because bishop e3 with a rook on f5
traps that rook now that the rook is
back on f7 well bishop b3 the rook can
just slide back to f6 or f5 so that's
nice so knight f2 was threatening to
trap the rook where it stands because it
guarded the g4 square so even though it
didn't attack the rook kind of the same
same thing that knight g3 would have
done the rook still had to move because
of that threat of bishop e3 so
here we sit hikaru
not playing his next move fabiano was
ready for knight f2 which is important
for him he needs to be ready he still
has three moves to make with only two
minutes and 42 seconds to do it
and i i feel like hikar wants to wait
before taking on e4 that's like the
sense i'm getting here that pawn's not
going anywhere you have e3 covered by
your bishop and your rook so if he can
make some improving move like earlier
when the knight was on g3 dania
recommended sliding the rook up to avoid
a rook trade yeah rookie 3 is just bad
now because your knight has lost uh but
the point is that maybe there are some
improving moves here for hickar like
even like in the movie a3 or a4 over the
queen side that could be useful as black
is kind of focused in the center and not
attention being had over there on the
queen side so maybe there's just some
useful move that hikara can play you
could also try to get your king active
with g3 and king g2 right and avoid the
first rank check once again and that
that's a key first rank check that we're
avoiding everyone because not even
though it's not checkmate anymore if
that check happened you had to trade
rooks and typically you want the rook on
the board if you're facing two rooks in
these two minor piece kind of dynamics
because it helps you have a piece that
competes like they do right you want to
have a piece that moves like they do in
a lot of cases and knight takes d3 is a
threat here so black has to move the
rook again and yeah so who knows where
maybe i was wrong on rook f3 but if you
don't go to f3 and hit the pawn then
well if you go to f5 then isn't there it
might be taking right away because
knight takes you through bishop e4
what's wrong with you you're gonna think
that but that's the exact type of
material so knight takes d3
e takes d3
bishop e4
this is what i've been trying to get to
so thank you you've helped you're very
welcome i knew i would set you up you're
getting to say something profound king
g8
oh yeah sorry
bishop takes rook rook takes bishop this
is what i've been looking for so donya
helped me out here it's two pawns for a
bishop so materially speaking obviously
white is a head but black has pretty
good chances to hold this game because
you have one pass pawn and a nice
connect four pawn chain and then you can
create a second pass pawn on the king
side so white's forces are distracted
and there's not much more to attack to
begin with so yeah
this actually might give good chances i
want to speak engine for a second
you know i don't like engines in the
beginning
baby when it's about plus two in a
position like this it often means that
there's some kind of fortress down the
line yeah and when
magnus carlsen played the 2016 world
chess championship his first game
against karjakin it's just something
like
minus three or whatever it was but
kayaking built a fortress and
magnus couldn't make any progress so
that is something that
players are really good at spotting and
these two players ikaru and fabi and
hikar is probably thinking what
material wind do i not really want and
this looks like one of them and from
fabi's perspective he's always looking
for an option just like this that when
on the surface it appears that white's
winning chances are actually
not quite as high and black's drawing
chances are greatly improving mm-hmm
and i will just add to your
excellent description that what i think
would fool a lot of people here is that
they look at this position and say okay
well i'm fully restraining the d3 pawn
that pump's not going anywhere the
problem isn't in its current state it's
in the fact that it is not allowing
whitestroke the freedom to get active
because the moment you're going rookie
seven i can't just go here
and there's very little you can do about
that yeah
no and i'll i'll
also add to robert's point because it
was a great one that he already said
that it's this type of eval 1.8 1.7 and
you know
you added a concrete point the rook is
literally trapped to the first rank in
some ways and the king is trapped on the
f-file so if you just look at the
specifics here everyone there might this
might actually be a weird kind of
drawing fortress because the king can't
enter and the rook can't leave without
d2 the bishop while looking very
beautiful there in the center doesn't
actually maybe do what you wanted to do
here it can't undermine the pawn chain
and the last thing i'll say is this is
this is one of those rare frontiers guys
still left where a human being's
super long foresight the way that we
humans approach chess well we played b4
that's different it's different than
engines
in that you know what you know what i'm
getting to here right we call it the the
fact that the math will always say this
but a human can see a fortress which has
nothing to do with the amount of moves
it takes to get there has nothing to do
with how fast you can calculate you can
visualize almost an abstract way a human
brain would to say that position despite
the math is actually a fortress because
of x y and z and so there aren't there
aren't very many positions like that
left in chess where a human being can
quickly a strong human being not me
right a very strong player can quickly
visualize
that that it's a that it's a draw right
even though a computer would take a long
time to see it that's that's such a
great point and there's nothing
intrinsic in this position that makes it
a fortress the fact that the rook is
cutting the king if you program that and
say a rook cutting off a king equals
fortress you're gonna get in trouble
pretty fast they don't if you say
right protected passer on d3 equals
fortress i can give you 50 examples
where passport number three doesn't mean
anything right
okay i think five minute car went down
to one minute and 40 yeah we got to get
to that bobby only has one minute he was
surprised b4 caught him off guard and
what is he going to do as a response to
this move because
that actually is really nasty maybe
white can start trying to pick off those
queenside pawns upon a6 stuck in place
and what moved the father
way bishop
oh my gosh bishop e8 because you need to
bring a rook to f5 just to defend the
pawn your other rook gets trapped bishop
e3 oh
there is rook h4 but then g3 really
traps that rook over there and if we
should be at rookie seven are you saying
that you just take on h5 or is there
something more i'm i'm taking your
offering fun gobbling he's a pawn goblin
yeah fabio won't survive without that
pawn no without the pawn majority that
was one of his only assets
what what a huge move by hicaro b4 is
exactly guys the reason why we said we
said maturity poised be deliberate use
your clock as a weapon because b4 is the
type of confusing move you want to play
when your opponent doesn't have a lot of
time
that's and that's the kind of response
you sometimes get is a mistake from your
opponent yeah because
i mean b4 is like you can't really do
anything as black but maybe there was an
opportunity just a moment ago i mean i'm
sure we can look at it after the game
but right now fabiano plays h5 and
bishop e8 just looks like a game ender
and not just that if you take bishop
takes e4 check even
with the knight landing on e4 now g5 or
c5 yeah and a6 is stuck in place and
just
going to be picked off
b4 was such a strong move the kind of
move that just irritates you because you
ask your opponent do you want to amp
assange now he's like thinking about
wait that's a huge commitment i can't on
poisson because of you know undermining
my own bishop but if you don't on
passant you're panicked about the
long-term weakness that is now the a6
pawn and it's just passive enough it's
non-forcing enough
that you you get emitted off your
opponent's clock just for that
that was that was exactly the kind of
move take note boys and girls watching
the show of moves like b4 when you have
40 minutes on the clock against your
opponent's two minutes that's how you
get people to make blunders in time
pressure
yeah he's definitely deciding between
bishop e8 and bishop takes c4 check
but bishop e8 seems to be the more
concrete the more
decisive of the two options
yeah wow but it is amazing that bishop
takes e4 the kind of move you would
never want to play last move because
it's the forcing move that lets fob you
reach time control just from trades
now it's actually really strong because
you snuck in this b4 move crippling a6
so when that knight comes in you got
problems right you could you could
actually do it
now when where you really couldn't
before there is no rookie 7 because
knight g5 check would win the rook
and now knight c5 is way better than it
would have been without before again
what we were saying everyone is if you
this is the opposite of what you want to
do here making this trade in this
position you just let black make a move
like get pieces off the board with with
uh get one step closer to time control
but b4
what a move
h4 and b4 those are the two moves of the
game
yeah h4 really is the heroic move back
there and then b4 is one of those moves
where you're not making h4 wasteful
right it's like i don't want to waste
this great game so let me play b4 and
then seal the deal yeah
it's funny that before was a move we
considered when the knight was on b7 but
it's such a universally strong move like
now there's no knight it's still a great
move because now it fixes the queen side
pawns in addition to all the other
things it does and how bad is that
bishop on d3
right as soon as c4 and e4 happened it
was entrenched and tuned whatever you
want to call it but never could get out
and it couldn't be useful and now its
best use will be just to trade pieces
but it's too late and just been out of
play this whole game and
he being fabiano could never get rook f1
in so
picard did a great job of avoiding rook
trades
yeah you're right this
this bishop just went from the biggest
strength on the board to the most
misplaced piece if you could have put it
anywhere else
you may have had a different dynamic
with those two rooks being able to
compete with the miners
icon's depth of understanding about i
don't know how deep his prep went we're
going to maybe ask him if he wins this
game he'll probably join us in the
studio
but the depth of understanding he had
about this position is really showing
clearly here that whatever prep
they got up to regardless of where the
the actual concrete move ended
this has been an absolutely stellar
performance from nakamura here today
and it's what we've
almost become used to and that's not to
take it for granted when he plays a
masterpiece but we mentioned the other
day his win over magnus carlson won the
champions chess tour events where it
just looked like a kind of fine position
for magnus but hicaro had that really
deep fundamental understanding where it
felt like magnus was the best chess
player on the planet he just could
hardly move and every single move that
hikar made improve his position it's
like karpovian in a sense
well i like to come back in these
moments to what i say at the start of
some of his speed chest championship
matches where a lot of people you know
who watch his streams they just
associate his incredible speed with
tactical ability and his tactical
ability is incredible but i think at his
core and he himself has made this point
you know he's he's a positional player
notice how his pawn structure is always
healthy he rarely has weaknesses in his
position his repertoire is super solid
so
you know as he's gotten a little bit
older he's
become more like karpov
and
again that's that's terrifying
i became less like harper as i got older
you decided to become more like carlson
any hooters we're gonna back up really
quick look at a bird's eye view and
we're not gonna leave this game
especially probably guess on the clock
but i do wanna
i do want to
pay our dues
okay somehow
it's getting more unclear by the second
did that pawn get to f5 and
allow how did it get there what happened
to ambassador isn't there a checkpoint
at f6 was it there went straight to f5 i
don't know
do you know like f6 and then oh my okay
so we'll have to unpack that also for
russia
unfortunately we haven't given that game
as much as maybe the the x's and o's
itself would be due it looks like a very
interesting battle the reality is that
we've had some other games with slightly
more at stake at this point in the
tournament so all apologies um i feel
like they've had the same position for
like 30 minutes maybe it's fascinating
for us to go back and look at but
yeah not
true
they haven't traded anything in a long
way you haven't traded anything in a
really long time
the bishops left the board and they said
that's all we need
yeah today that's
all right
i don't know why my shoe was cutting off
my ankle circulation today i tied it too
tight yeah i keep it you notice i keep
wiggling it yeah do you need a moment
but i do that i can't feel my toes right
now
oh wow i'm not kidding actually at the
next break i'm gonna untie my shoe and
get my foot out of here
sounds like a pretty good call
i'm trying to everyone's watching me
twist my foot they're like dude did you
actually go to that we need to go in
that position are you there's no way
i'm going to click you there there's no
room for what just happened how in the
world can you make the move b4
on the queen there's no way that move
just happened
uh yeah we got a pen to a live cam we
got a we've got a visual conference into
the live game of report and duda just so
we can see
what's going on with that game
i don't know if the team can hear me how
do you possibly play the move b4 right
like
the h file is open there's all sorts of
checkmate threats
they did places
okay how did he get his pawn to f5 we
have so many questions yeah there's so
many questions about the last four moves
have been like an apocalypse has
happened
shaking his head
okay let's let's go there real quick to
the report due to game look everyone
keep an eye on hikaru's game we'll pop
right back to it but
what just happened
how did the pawn get to f5 he did get
there and there was no on poissant wait
he played g6 and f5 wow
yeah we're keeping the cam on it karo on
purpose because the moment he moves
we're headed back there oh
okay i think he wanted ambassador to
happen he being duda because he would
play rook h7 check take the rook on h1
and then like king f7
and just say that pawn's an umbrella
right it actually shields my king maybe
i can take it back soon but
wow what an idea back to nagamura
i'm on the board whoo he didn't play
neither speed nor knight 64. played a4
and now takes a four okay fabiano has
this his last move to make one move to
make before time control and it is now
he's with a minute on the clock he's
probably gonna go h4 or something just
try to keep the status quo
well if you want oh yeah you can't we've
ripped out five years ago yeah i think
he had to play for he gets an hour
in doing so and we can take a breath
hikaru says you do the french word for
adjust for those who don't speak
francais
uh i'm surprised that gordon played
bishop v8 yeah
he just played for i mean a very logical
move though right he's still completely
winning you know these pawns are split
a6 and c4 yeah so objectively the
position
is still
clearly great for white but just feels
like maybe fabiano has a little bit more
life than before because the knockout
right that final touch still isn't
abundantly clear at least not to me and
watch out for black to throw in the e3
at some moment because you can't yeah
you did to free the bishop you can't
take with the rook without losing your
knight on d2 that you need the bishop
directly protecting the f2 square if you
take the bishop there could be like a
rookie seven and all of a sudden there's
this pin on the e file and we might get
a rook trade which is what black really
needs so
i'm not counting fabiano yet of course
with proper play hikaru should be able
to
take this one home but it's not that
clear
yeah
feels like he gave himself more clarity
with a4 right you said it was like a
simple simple approach
in a good way it's it makes black's
position even worse on the queen side
but it may not have been
the most concrete knockout that he could
have had with that pawn h5 easy for us
to say i guess as a
group of three people commentating in
the help of an evil engine
we can kind of spot things pretty
quickly but
yeah i'm with you robert i think that
suddenly this position breathes a little
bit of life and this e3 shenanigan
is really tricky but okay now that we've
reached move 40 we we are gonna back up
to do what i was trying to do before and
head back over to the man
in the red suit what is happening to
black's king
no pieces are defending it
oh my god this looks terrible
this looks horrible and queen h5 yeah
just oh my god queen h5 broke g7 there's
94. what was the two open the f5
that is just dirty can you play that
move when you're about to get mated on
the h file i don't think you can maybe
he just thought he's gonna check me no
matter what so it was it was a yeah or
he succumbed to the sort of pavlovian
instinct that white would move the
knight which is not going to happen in a
million years and if he moves it he's
moving it to e4
yeah so queen h5
h5 threatening queen h8 and queen f6 and
rock h8
so rogue g7 is forced to try to slice
off that pathway
and knight e4
not the only i mean g6 is also easily
winning yeah 94 because you're opening
up the f file so if f takes e4 your
queen ha check
seven you've rook f2 and
bye bye
apparently g6 is
mating even faster but he would resign
probably after 94.
yeah this is
pretty straightforward
robert you called it when we had the
pawn on g5 and you we were already
seeing a little bit of the pressure as a
report
i think you've been 94 first
does play 94 first
oh dude did you see his face he's he
can't believe it he looks over he knows
he's done
i was going to say you called it when
that pong got to g5 you said this looks
a lot like napomneshi duda and young
kristoff hasn't hasn't enjoyed himself
defending kingside pawn storms here in
madrid and duda found this brilliant
idea h4 queen takes h4 knight h7 usually
when you find such an idea
it's like the game starts going your way
but i i honestly think this decision to
take on g5 of the night was bad that's
what started it all and it's so easy for
me to say that now of course
but but you're right missing g1 that
that's what decides these games these
tiny subtleties
taking with the queen would have been
the easy way for black to maintain an
edge simplify the whole purpose of what
report was doing which was to try to get
a reckless attack because with the
queens off the board that kind of attack
is just no longer
instead duda got really excited about
his own attacking chances taking with
the knight so that he could keep this
rook lift idea open but i think i think
both you were right about that and i
think robert as he points to me was also
right that maybe rook g1 was missed well
i was a little in between movies i also
was going to say that knight g5 the
second time was also not good so it was
the double curse knight g5
but it's funny i think maybe he if he
didn't miss it he might have
underestimated it and then made this
this wrong decision
and uh
it was a couple of knight g5 moves that
that in the end were not uh
we're not to be desired for duda
report gets a ton of credit by the way
showing up with fire
but dude is distraught right now yeah
this is
hard to watch he can't believe it and i
think
because of that moment knight takes g5
yeah he was playing for a win right
there was
he's looking at this this is my
opportunity to try to come back and if
you don't get first place here you get
last or although in this
occasion second place might also be
kind of like first place depending on
what magnus carlson's up to so i think
for duda like he needs to strike at some
point but rapport and dude deserve a ton
of credit these guys are as combative as
they get they're at minus one both of
them report after a tough day yesterday
he strikes back and dude judo isn't i
mean he just doesn't want to be anywhere
near a chess board right now and he's
literally talking to himself at the
board talking himself in circles
probably not even talking to himself
about the current position at hand
thinking about where this game was
earlier and what went wrong
it's the jacket
i think that's pretty clear the red
jacket we've eliminated all the other
hypothesis what i was about to say as we
were catching up on how it went down
report got a ton of credit for how he
went after this game right they both get
credit like robert was saying they've
been playing a lot of fighting chess
despite a lot of draws that they had
to start the event but
yeah this is a heartbreaker for the
number one player from poland on the
flip side though you have to kind of if
you're a fan of chess be happy for
report because he tried yesterday he
failed miserably by his own admission
but he just came back he played some
really ambiguous amorphous line with no
real plan
and maybe objectively it wasn't better
for white but he just
posed questions and younches of duda
wasn't ready to answer all of them and
now the only question i have is is he
gonna resign or play a couple more moves
because this one's over
yeah i feel like he's gonna stop the
clock at any moment
such as in the next 15 seconds
but i mean this this you know he's a
youngster he's only in his 20s he won
the world cup he eliminated magnus
carlson he won the grand chess tour
rapid and blitz event in poland he's a
hero in poland he's won honors from the
president of the country like he is
really making moves there and there's a
reason why poland's been hosting more
and more tournaments and it's because of
jan schistoff and radislav witachik
perform but i mean look look at him
right now it just you know he's clearly
put so much into this tournament it's
not going his way but he is combative
he's had six draws and he's trying his
best but when you go against the best in
the world uh sometimes that one he
doesn't even wait for his opponent to
come back to the table
simply pauses the clock and resignation
stands up to put his jacket on
and he's not even waiting oh there's a
report coming back to shake hands
and uh
but in a strange way like that's of
course as painful as it is to watch this
is also partly what makes just so
relatable no matter what your rating is
what language you speak to yourself
these emotions are totally universal
anybody who's ever played
you know an important tournament of
tournament that's meaningful to them
can understand exactly what he's saying
to himself you know as he's
as he's expressing this pain in his
emotions but
all credit's a report
for the for the way that he recovered
today yeah
it's the jacket
put on a red jacket
and yeah and he bounced back
uh
i think we're gonna bounce to a break
now that we've reached time control i
believe we have in in both games
although what move is it for
no we have not actually
we're not even close not even close how
is that possible well we haven't been
looking too closely at farouja or jabba
they've been spending a lot of time
deciding what squares to put their
knights and rooks on
um i'm seeing it no i'm kidding
it is a position by the way that is
about to come to life
d4 has been played there's tension on
the board between the central pawns
and somehow
faruga figured out a way to open the
queen side and he kept the a file which
is a big thing we were talking about
um earlier that any time white tried to
do that robert black would be the one
getting control over that file yeah but
he may have the a file but look at that
f file if you think you're just gonna
double and isolate black's pawns if d
takes e5 you're mistaken because after
you take that pawn on e5 yeah it looks
like it's about to be a problem right
black's gonna be stuck with pawns but
look at the f file so i'm ready to take
your knight on g4 and try to remove the
guard so i'm just willing to
leave myself with bad pawns if that
means that i can just aim at the f2
square because the rook and a3 and the
rook on e3 they're not coordinated at
all and so blacks works on the other
hand looking down at the f2 pawn and
towards the white king that could spell
some trouble what's the reason black
isn't also threatening to take e4 i'm
asking for a friend not for me no you
you absolutely are so i think that white
actually may take the knight and f6 but
now i have to calculate g takes f6 in
addition to the just rook taking it's
going to be a very dangerous move i
think gtx is better because rook takes
knight the other knight comes to g4
right and then h5 becomes a problem
okay so let's look at that so if white
tries to deal with this by knight takes
f6 black will actually take with the
pawn
and here comes f5 can you come in a
g-file maybe a knight sack at some point
you'd clear not to worry about the e5
square anymore you have two
you've taken care of that problem right
it has a little bit of protection okay
um
so maybe knight tiff's takes f6 not what
future wants d takes e5 you were saying
is
knight takes e4 yeah your move is even
better oh okay there we go i was
wondering i was like i'm counting
attackers and defenders here i've
degraded myself to to just counting here
i'm not trying to use any international
master level knowledge with you two here
that's not a bad strategy in this
position in a move by ali reza rook a2
which what a cold move
oh
wow he wants to
he's like please take my pawn e4 oh does
he want h5 and queen d3 he absolutely
does
let's look at it knight takes
h5
knight has to run wasn't timor's king on
h8 why did he put on h7 because now he's
regretting that choice
yeah this looks very iffy
okay and maybe queen d3 first is somehow
more accurate because i saw the eval bar
go down but i think it's the same
principle the whole point is that when
the queen comes to this diagonal h5 is
really hard to deal with and now knight
f6 would be taken followed by h5
to uh to win a pinned pony and if you
play d5 instead of uh bringing the
knight back to protect your knight now i
go h5 and knight takes e5 as a fork
knight takes e5 is a forking problem um
okay
yeah so faruja bringing bringing some
attention some fire to the board he
desperately wants to get his first win
here in madrid
he has seven and a half minutes to play
his remaining six moves
and six and a half minutes for her job
off to play his six moves
by the way as he's thinking
i think the reason why h5 first wasn't
good was really interesting there's we
don't have to delve into the details but
knight f4
oh wow gta except for he takes f4 with
just a huge initiative that knight from
e4 slides back to g5 and potentially h3
h3 and there's a mating net right
everything comes alive
okay wow
that's why h5 wasn't correct in in
addition to the fact that queen e3
seemed like the more logical thing to do
we have a couple moves being played now
rook a2 queen c4 and ferruccia
immediately responds by putting the rook
to safety
what a scary position for white still
five moves to make for ferugia six moves
to make currently where we stand
for tamar raja buff
this game took a long time to heat up so
we we didn't give it a lot of attention
earlier
uh with all due respect there were also
some other crazy games going on report
and a red jacket did damage um
well now that rook left a2 i'm wondering
if black at some point should think
about rook a8 swing back yeah to go over
to that side of the board and i mean
there's so much interesting tension from
d4 to e5 i don't think that black wants
to take on d4 that badly um you know you
could take with the queen on d4 but you
could also take with the pawn on d4 and
opening the c file should be to white's
advantage because the c7 pawn is
backwards and uh target so
it's a really really difficult position
to assess for the players and they're
down rajaba down to five and a half
minutes alireza seven half minutes this
is a blitz game
and it's not easy to parse through the
details especially because it's a blitz
game with no increment
we don't even do that to the players in
the speedchest championship we're kinder
than fidei and robert called it
rook a8 swings back grabs the a file
and you know what's interesting in terms
of cataloging why this is such a complex
position i think that the most complex
positions are ones in which the tension
is occurring on all
three parts of the board at the same
time yep like you've got queen side
tension obviously there's a battle over
the a file or
you know it's like black ran unopposed
they won the election uh there's tension
in the center on the e5 square and
obviously there is
massive tension on the king side with
that knight on g4 the possibility of h5
and conversely black's
uh pressure down the file so
stuff moving parts everywhere hard to
keep track
and we're in for a roller coaster in
these last five moves aruja on the clock
he has five
minutes sorry five moves to make in six
minutes
remember once they reach move 40 they
get 60 minutes added back onto the clock
they don't get increment yet
until another
20 moves are made you have to reach move
60 to start getting 30 seconds added per
move it's been a storyline throughout
the event the fact that this is a major
event without increment really for the
first time in a long time the first
candidates without increment um
in
in maybe the modern era here in the last
in the last decade or two so uh the fact
that these time scrambles are not coming
with any relief to the players makes the
drama and tension very real
uh with jokes aside that's one of the
reasons and that's one of the pros
arguments for the time control is these
moments are very exciting
because the players are very nervous
and now all the res is in under six
minutes
and it's there's no clarity here right
so do you take on f6 but that allows g
takes f6 we're just talking about that
where black gets the capture toward the
center the e5 pawn is well defended the
g file opens up so watch out for some
kind of night sacrifice at the right
moment and there's still this tension on
d4 the c3 pawn is a bit loose but the
rook on e3 is doing a good job defending
can black go rook a3 bring the rook back
second rook over to the a file there's
so many questions here and white's
foundation is good or the pawn structure
is pretty healthy but i feel like i
would prefer the activity that black's
pieces have especially in the context of
the time situation
i agree
white structure is strong though like
you said the house don't fall if the
bones are good you like all your reza
nice king g2 is a move okay another
reference that means it's a great
reference
but uh
oh perugia has moved rook f3
putting that rook on the file
to pin the knight actually trying to
force her droppers back to f8 yeah
saying go to f8 where you whence you
belong the problem is isn't that where
black wants to put the rook
i mean you were highlighting robert that
by coming to f8
you now maybe allow rook a3 at some
point the other rook can follow suit
black is switching to the queen side
here knight e3 almost traps the black
queen i was just like looking to see how
many squares there are there is the c3
pawn hanging and the queen go back to c6
but for a moment i was wondering if rook
f8 actually allowed your queen to get
trapped but it doesn't
for java putting the other rook on f8
trying to say that maybe hey why don't
we just repeat this one so we can both
get some more time on the clock what do
you say kid
it's not
i mean i think it's pretty unlikely but
it's not totally
out of the realm of the possible yep
because it's so hard for white to make a
move and now he's down to four and a
half minutes
four and a half minutes for four moves
for farouza
roughly the same pervert
jabba their hearts must be beating out
of their chests you can just imagine you
can feel the tension
on that board
it's kind of funny because i
almost
don't know what to play because they're
like eight different moves that all look
like they're decent for both sides and
you're in this position where
um
yeah there's too many options
yeah that's why i mean i don't think
it's crazy that we'll see a repeating of
moves we already established that you
don't want to take here on f6 and allow
black to take with the pawn
um
yeah glance at the clock a little shake
of the head a very universal kind of
motion you know what that means he
doesn't see a better move
and that increases the likelihood of
rookie three looks at a scoresheet there
three and a half minutes for four moves
ferocious farouza glancing at the clock
and the scoresheet back and forth four
more moves four more moves clock score
sheet clock score sheet
already definitely wants to win this
game but compared to earlier right where
he was up on time by a couple minutes
just a few moves ago now he's the one
who's down on the clock and it's not
getting simpler and no trades are
happening you often want to see a few
trades some the position to clarify but
right now their knights are having a
stare down the rooks on the f-file two
for black only one for white and that
rook on b2 that's been like the piece
that you want to use it is protecting
the f2 pawn which is very important in
the event of rookie 3 but other than
that it just feels like kind of a
defensive piece
yeah it's got
very little future as you said other
than
its assigned role of protecting f2
and with every passing second it seems
that his frustration is
palpably growing
i don't think he wants to play knight f6
and all g takes f6 i think something
about that is concerning him especially
as we get down near move forward and
only three minutes approximately
remaining for white knight takes us like
gtx that kind of transformational pawn
structure yeah that feels like now you
need to think all over again about an
entirely new position but what's going
through your head from like you're
balancing the practical emotion you feel
but trying to solve the position which
is at some point do you just like i said
at some point do you just say i'm going
to repeat moves so i can get more time
on the clock you have no other choice
and now and our job doesn't have the
same yeah
this
is you called it
not not improbable
turns out it was more than likely and
probably timur is not going to try any
shenanigans and him playing r8 almost
instantly that further increases the
likelihood that ellie ross will repeat
he's just not giving him any time he's
kind of oh no
no he's tired he draws let's go he's
tired of draws he's tired of being in
the bottom of the standings i'm going to
go for it but will that be a mistake he
regrets if for java plays g takes f6
then he's saying hey i wanted that and
now i'm going to i'm going to flip this
thing around hijab has to play g6 so
rook takes f6 runs right into h5
followed by knight g4 followed by d
takes e5 you're just going to lose a
pawn okay oh yeah so he's going to take
with the pawn and he does
so i'll just show real quick
if rook takes f6 had been played it was
actually not just a matter of black
wanting it but it actually was no choice
i just take on e5 first take on e5 first
so that you win the pawn and you win the
queen
oh my god that's what he did remember i
mentioned earlier the queen was running
out of squares
bye bye all right
nice idea okay but gtx f6 was played we
see that
farouza responds with knight to f3 where
java has four minutes to make
two moves moves 39 and 40. ooh f5 is
very interesting here and then meeting
h5 with something like knight f4
robert you pointed out that idea yeah
black strokes come to the g file
in an instant and the c three pawn is
really weak
wow and ali razor down to one minute and
22 seconds i know he only has one move
to make but if f5 is played that's not
going to be an
easy put him in a situation where he has
to make a very committal choice and move
forward without sacrificing objectivity
yeah rajaba puts head in hands plural
he's going to figure out what he wants
to do to make this last move for perugia
the hardest possible move
on the board you want to make sure that
your opponent
has a chance to blunder in these in
these spots and these positions are
really funny to me because we see the
evil bar thing slightly better for white
what the players are thinking this is
crazy i have no idea who's best
absolutely
i didn't make a move although i don't
know
i think in all fairness too they don't
think in terms of the eval and that they
know when a position is unclear yes they
know when it's slipping so there are the
rare occasions where they don't realize
that one of the players has a bigger
advantage yeah but if you said point
four they'd be like what the for who
they believe
what does that even mean yeah exactly
yeah point or point two for for who's
yeah
either side yeah meaningless evaluation
more upper jabba's alley i think is a
move like rook g7 but that wouldn't
allow alireza to quickly play king h2
like put anything on the g phone and
white's king is going to get back away
from a very good point rook g7 just
makes white's 40th move easy i think
that if he smells blood if his
experience oldest player in the field
playing the youngest player in the field
in this game if his experience says that
he sees some nerves some shakiness maybe
he goes for a five and lets ferugia kind
of squirm a little bit under the uh the
clock although rajab has struggled to
play those kinds of moves right even
with a lot of time on his clock yeah and
that's why he hasn't won a classical
chess game in more than three years
i i'm not trying to no but it's the
truth right yeah rajab has struggled at
times in these critical tension-filled
moments to be willing to do that which
is funny it's not the younger jabba we
grew up watching or i i did not
it was crazy hey i'm old jesus
[Music]
played king's indians and sacrifices and
schliemann attacks back when the
schliemann was not even supposed to be a
thing anymore you're even supposed to
say the word
what does it even mean
that's another show
um
but okay
rajabov does he play a move that allows
for ruja to approach mu 40 with ease
let's not forget robert has two moves to
make yeah actually
he needs to make his 40th move too to
get that hour yeah by the way he now has
less time than perugia oh my goodness
and he's playing no nine seven seven
yeah
okay
okay but that's one of those moves where
you now white doesn't exactly know how
to respond yeah okay i can get behind
that i don't think it's a but what's the
idea i i don't know i was gonna say it
wasn't that's exactly the point he wants
only reason to ask that
and he wants alireza to spend a minute
and eight seconds asking what the idea
is and if i'm already i do not want to
take on e5 because that feels committal
it might be a good move but d65 is a
move obviously you can't take back and
maybe opening the f file again is going
to hurt you more than it helps you so i
i think you'd want to just play some
kind of knight d2 and that's a good one
just like even move the king
yeah yep
move the king knight d2 would just be
the tempo you need and it would also
help roger by the way because it would
force queen to c6 and we'd have more
time on the clock um
and hollering okay
so
i don't know with of course the dgc
relay isn't always
yeah does the clock reset a little bit
there yeah he had more time than it was
showing i think now he has less time
than it's showing because it from his
body language it seems like he's getting
ready to make a move so i would estimate
15 seconds he keeps glancing at the
clock oh he's really nervous
i don't know if we can get a view on the
clock that would be sweet 15 okay so
something is wrong with the relay here
apologies
that was
i think it's seven seconds he made that
move with seven seconds on the clock he
did
and that both of them immediately get up
that was exciting i was anticlimactic so
i don't know what happened there with
the relay unfortunately it wasn't as
dramatic as it actually was for the
players those nerves on purusha's face
were very real he made that move with
seven seconds on the clock we did not
have it properly displayed on the screen
but rajaba responded
instantly and we have reached move 40
on all boards
exactly i'm both breathing and looking
at fabiano's game and the last one
played was h3 and then ricardo just
played rook a2 as if nothing is the
matter it's just another day at the
office what although the email bar says
uh maybe that's a little bit helpful for
uh the thing is this with every move
that goes by that allows carwana to make
trades
the greater his drawing chances get so
uh of course you know we don't know
fully yet
will there be a story line in hindsight
that there was an opportunity for
nakamura bishop eight will he go on to
convert anyway certainly right now you
would still put your money on that
result white is much better
but um
but if the game is still going you're
feeling better about fabiano carbona's
chances because with every trade the
harder it's going to be for white to
convert so
all right
it's going to be hard for us to get the
break we deserve and forgive to give my
toes feeling again if i don't throw to
this next uh this next read so that we
can take take a step out of the studio
here coming up after the feeding
candidates the next feed a major event
happening in the world is the 44th chess
olympiad it is headed to chennai india
and it will go down july 29th through
august 9th starts early if you're
watching this particular show on the
west coast 2 30 a.m pacific time you can
go to go.chess.com
olympia22 2022 to get all of the info
tune in we'll have many many great
commentators daily covering the action
robert hess will be there because he'll
be the team captain for team usa in
chennai so if you're tuning in for
robert hess well then don't tune in
because as much as we love robert he uh
won't be there anyway he'll be working
with that guy to try to bring gold to
the usa can that guy bring his position
back to life and maybe save his
candidates chances here in madrid we're
going to find out when our coverage of
the 2022 feat of candidates returns in a
few
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
apparently this is the horse she rode in
on literally queen isabella herself on a
knight a noble steed you know changed
the world forever it's why
everyone in madrid
knows the game of chess
they know that the candidates is here
they know that uh that this is
one of the capital cities of our great
game and it's all because of that lady
right there on that noble steed now
that's a 9. thank god for queen isabella
changing the rules right giving the
queen her powers
i know that in the filming we're really
running with this but in my head it was
the queen of france so that begs the
question who is the chess.com historian
and can i fire them
well you'd have to fire yourself i think
yeah that's a good thing
that's uh call that's an out take i
believe they call it him yeah i'll take
so mike's gonna say was the queen of
spain next time he knows yeah he knows
yeah we gotta find more about this lady
and find more about what the people know
here
you guys excited for the candidates
hey can we talk for a second about this
here we go
to the plaza we go
which way is the plaza
you guys play chess yeah yeah
there you go
are you excited for the candidates yeah
yeah
yeah
you know what it is you don't know what
it is
okay what is it we've watched the
queen's game oh you watched the queen's
gambit me too okay you guys actually
played chess like on your phone
what are you playing chess.com yeah
you're about 1300 on leashes yeah so it
means you'd be like 900 on chess.com
actually yeah give me your username i'll
give you a diamond membership
not kidding he's going to be a contender
in like three years
he's up and coming so i'll give you a
premium membership and then you won't
have an excuse then you can use that
i'll go back to it yeah all right man oh
you're in i am that's me man
magnus he's like number one oh yeah the
guy like beats yeah so this tournament
decides who plays magnus carlson
so the next challenger comes out of this
tournament all right guys enjoy thank
you so much have fun so much see a great
trip guys there you go no drinking no
drinking yeah
that's true you guys are connected now
yeah we're buddies on we're going to
send each other some ticks do you think
they already talked and then we'll we'll
we'll talk about it is that your phone
buzzing they are they are they already
yeah they're already hitting me up for
my digits okay yep maybe wearing a pager
wasn't the smartest idea to fit in with
them
[Music]
play chess online or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess the
world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus there are those
familiar with the biggest stages in
chess yet still chasing unfinished
business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
[Music]
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
miss amigos
i can feel my toes again good news
good news fixed my shoes uh
bobby uh probably hoping that he can
field this position you know if he'll
start feeling good about his position
soon it doesn't not does not look great
in that regard
grand master robert has grand master
daniel nereditzky
we are here in madrid we are covering
round date of the 2022 feed a candidates
we had a huge win already from richard
report who
gave the event a huge loss
uh yesterday so huge rebound for him uh
he caught up with dena bell and kaya
we'll be checking out that interview
later on fans get excited about that
we've got
we've got a couple interesting positions
left here but one i think that we
definitely have to jump back into
asap
whoa
during the break i honestly didn't even
look at the position
now that we brain processing
yeah you know error short circuit
you know eating the acai bowl that the
team was so nice to wait they got you
you're also evil yeah
robert was so high maintenance about his
acai bowl robert talking about this
non-stop he's been talking about more
than like i was enthusiastic all i did
was mention it and that was it and the
team was so talented you're allowed to
be high maintenance
you're allowed to ask for help
no i'm kidding
i'm going to be asking for a gazpacho
sorry so you he was eating an acai bowl
i didn't see the position but what are
your thoughts on where it stands
first of all how many pawns does black
house black has five pawns for just two
for white
how does he have three pawns for
i mean
those three pawns are about to be shaved
down but
but i really feel like fabiano has
improved chances right because
earlier it felt like hikaru's pieces all
had strong positions right outpost that
bishop on c6 is now back on d1
i just
why did it go back there well let's
let's back up to where we left it
because this is definitely going to be
the main area of focus let's see so
speaking of when the bishop was on c6 it
was here
and we saw this
maneuver where the pieces started coming
to life and it really felt like after
before frankly i think we all i mean our
the emotion was in our voices right it
felt like the wind was imminent for
hikaru with before bobby barely reached
time control with h5
and right here
now that we can see it with hindsight
and let the engine confirm this
definitely was the best move
for heikaru
the rook moves somewhere
and the pawn falls
and this might have been the simplest
and cleanest but
that pawn's now on g2 that pawn is now
on g2
but icaru had a plan with b4 and he
stuck to it he played a4 and his goal
was to sort of break up black's pawn
structure over here but that left a
little bit of life in caruana's position
and he started pushing those pawns with
the idea of trying to trade everything
he can as fast as he can that's his best
chance to draw okay i think a car just
completely missed his sick move
that so you know what's funny about that
not funny for hikaru and just wait can i
try to fill in the blanket yeah go for
it but this is probably completely
missing the mark
it's kind of similar to the move e3
uh in the sense that it tries to
distract the knight in order to trade
rooks right but but what i got to think
from my perspective h4
i was thinking one dimensionally i was
thinking h4 was played just to avoid
bishop e8 and protect i never for a
second thought that h3 was going to be
played like that this problem is going
to be used as a decoy and it's just a
brilliant defensive idea by fabian i'm
assuming hikaru missed and the point is
that as you were just
calling out knight takes h3
allows the rook trade and you see the
evaluation immediately plummet saying
black has no problems
so if you take with the pawn on h3 then
the black rook can come to f3
and this bishop sometimes and look at
this rookie one thinking that you're
stabilizing does rook g3 check to move
the king away from the f2 knight and
then you take on e3 removing the guard
you get an extra pawn actually for black
wow and he car was very fortunate that
he had rook a2 because
absent that move if his rook was on c1
rather than a1
i don't know if he would have even been
better there because the other threat we
haven't even mentioned yet is h2 check
was a threat here deflecting the king to
win the knight on f2 so
in fact i'm kind of we're all catching
up to this right now but i'm actually
seeing in real time our team
working super hard they're all huge
chess fans like all of us everyone was
going nuts saying that hikaru found the
only move in the position rook a2
according to even some deep engine
analysis was the only move that kept
winning chances alive and he found it
but and that's true and a car will
continue to press for the win
this move h3 this was just the fight
that fabiano's putting up yeah this
so
this position was hanging by a thread as
far as winning chances go because
fabiano finds the brilliant running of
the h-pawn if you will alpha zero but
sort of in an odd way right not not
because that pawn
has any real aggressive damage just
renegade trying to do anything you can
to simplify the position is caruana wow
he gets one pawn off the board the
bishop comes back to d1 now we kind of
understand a little more of how we got
here
and this is
where we stand now with bishop g4 on the
board and i i wanted to add two things
the first is something i feel like i say
every single time
um there's a winning position which is
complicated which is that the first win
as my coach would always tell me is the
easiest bishop ba was the clearest win
the moment you missed that first win
gets harder and harder the harder and
you start letting your opponent back in
the game
now what makes ikaru so incredibly
strong is that
you know at some point he just hunkers
down and finds like seven computer moves
in a row and i think we're watching
that stage of the game right now bishop
a4 to d1 also very elegant and the point
of that move was to protect the f3
square robert pointed out rook f3 that
was a very dangerous threat you need to
keep the bishop on e3 that is the cog
that makes the whole machine run it
blockades the e4 pawn it controls a
bunch of key squares the iron other
minor pieces have to act in service of
protecting that bishop
which is what a characteristic way to
way to put that yeah this bishop d1
acting in service of the e3 bishop to
guard the f3 square because the e3
bishop holds it all together for white
at this point
and uh
bobby is on the clock he has
half the time hikaru does but at this
point
he's got to be feeling like the glass is
half full compared to where it was right
i mean
he has chances here if he can keep some
pressure on the board and not let
nakamura fully coordinate the pieces
yeah my reaction was at a pure shock
like i didn't understand how the pawn
got the g2 but it wasn't just some
random magic it was a great decision by
fabiano to use that pawn you know
renegade h-pawn to try to give him some
chances but
he car obviously sells the advantage and
that's as dyna's been saying is the
great thing about hikaru is even if he
let that first one slip he never gives
up he is relentless right he is the type
of player who will
try to find any last ditch effort if
it's available to him and right now it's
not ditching anything he is better he's
trying to maneuver his minor pieces and
allow himself to win but there aren't so
many pawns remaining i guess that's not
my concern for a car's winning chances
yeah he's like marshawn lynch like no
matter how many defenders he has on him
he's just gonna keep running he's gonna
keep running until he makes it to the
end zone
yeah but he's not just here so he
doesn't get fined
nice
take off my mic and retire now
you just used that one yesterday too
but in this case it was it was good wait
did marshawn lynch get fined
you never i watch the game of football i
don't i'm not there for the drama and
the press conferences who invited danya
to madrid yeah get down to some skittles
okay uh a very very famous interview
that
just says over and over again i'm just
here so i don't get fined
okay that's ringing a distant bell yeah
and uh anyway
um
no comment but we're just we're just
gonna get back here
bishop g4
hitting the rook
after moving it is is cecaro grabbing
back the pond and then kind of inching
forward or is there something else more
important than getting this very
dangerous g2 pawn that as you said
robert basically magically arrived here
um
crazy just moved
i didn't see where but
so the really annoying thing for white
is you can't move this bishop from g4
because you need to stop rook f3 it
every time it's available and you can't
really move your knight i don't know
where it would go to because you give
the f1 square and just the f file so
i
see it seems like taking is yeah yeah
that's step one but let's say black just
passes like king g8 or something i'm
just trying to figure out what what's
step two right
because there's a bunch of pins rook g6
is in the air and the d file is open
i'm trying to find a winning plan for
white just give me a second guys i'll
figure out the whole position
[Laughter]
um it's hard i mean king g3 you can
start with to avoid bishop f1 related
shenanigans yeah oh
and then
bishop d4 knight d1 knight e3 danny
you're square i like that i like that a
lot that's the square i want
i guess one of the
problems for fabiano has become as
obviously the position
has a lot more life for him than maybe
we thought it would and he figured out
this amazing h3 idea but we're seeing
hikara's long-term plan that he started
with b4 and a4 payoff because
now you're
your rook is stuck on the sixth rank so
as white starts to improve and maneuver
and and start to basically bring some
irritation to this rook now there's
things at stake by opening up the a file
you have given yourself a target that
you lacked otherwise
and so bishop d4
bringing the knight to d1 this rook is
kind of running out of squares along the
sixth rank
especially if that knight actually
starts coming in here so
mm-hmm so it's starting to feel like
it's a it's a plan to just keep using
the squares kind of like we said the
longer the game went on for the minor
pieces the more they will maneuver
themselves to new homes on the dark
squares
so
how do you if you're familiar you want
to change that you'd be even willing to
give up this pawn if you could right you
have to give yourself some sort of way
to
to get active and to challenge these
maneuverings but i don't know how to do
it
i don't think i can help you thanks a
lot i don't think there's been a piece
that i've liked less than that
right yeah
and it looks it should be good and now
it's got squares but it can't move to
them yeah like bishop b1 is useless
new vista vistas have become available
to it but none of them are advertising
it's not ridiculous there ain't no
vistas and there ain't no views there
certainly ain't no views and no vistas
another round you name that movie robert
then our relationship goes to another
level even deeper that's a movie what
movie is that i have no idea what's the
decade
uh 90s
no clue
someone who made the first move in a
world championship match was in that
movie and starred in it so woody
harrelson uh-huh
it can't be uh
white man kanji it can't be and it is
why it sounds like a random it's when
they're arguing about money that they
lost because they made a bad decision
and she's like i gotta get out of vista
views because there ain't no vistas and
there ain't no views and there's
certainly
now i know exactly what you're talking
about the exact scene you know the scene
right yeah yeah yep yep
that's scene of course how could i have
forgotten okay there you go um
shout out to woody harrison by the way
who's a great chess player yeah he has
made a move he made a move in the 2016
world chess championship in new york
woody
only plays chess only a true detective
would find that information out
glance at each other
shared pain of enduring my references
okay uh all right uh
you already you made the point that king
g8 robert is like the move to try but i
don't know that fabiano has anything
better if we're trying to put on our
running issues as black is there
anywhere that king can go that's useful
maybe going all the way to b7 to guard
the pawn would free up the rook
that the craziest idea i've ever come up
with
no
but
i mean the big question is how does
white win and once you tell me that
somebody help me please but i think we
figured that out just like king g3 g3 to
guard the bishop so that when you play
bishop d4 you're threatening to move the
knight although otherwise but it doesn't
end the game on the spot either okay
knight d-1
enough but okay we go we go here we go
king g3 okay and move my king f7 yeah
we're gonna we're gonna do that crazy
plan that dan came up with to move but
now here comes this movie uh oh oh i've
wondered you can take it again this idea
i'm attacking at the right moment oh my
god so that's oh my god
that's an idea to watch out for
oh my lance
bishop d1
why exactly i understand no but
i guess maybe you just can't make
progress
yeah so you just played what's a
ridiculous move like king e7 or
something and stare stare at your
opponent that is wild by the way like
okay i don't think fabiano would miss it
if given the opportunity but that you
can't judge me for that eval bar i know
the chat loves when i make blunders but
that is not an easy thing to see that
so maybe start with knight d1
yeah
okay or amend your plan by putting the
bishop on c5 rather than d4
but we can go with robert's approach
that's actually even better so we'll do
that bishop c5 and then
so the reason we wanted the king here is
so that if the rook went to g6 you're
not actually attacking the bishop and i
can continue my plan
i think
or knight h3 knight f4 i mean okay that
also prevents rogue dg5
yeah okay your winning plan is now
just to
be a pest i mean seriously you're just
going and
trying to discombobulate black's pieces
so abby's getting into time pressure
again he has 14 moves to make in 28
minutes so it's about two
minutes
on average per move if we're doing the
quick math on that remember that they
still don't have increment bobby has
played rook to g rook to g6
on king to g2
um remember increment does not kick in
until move 60. so
if you so the point is just backing with
donna said this is real time pressure
and that's also a great move i think
because your whole idea was go king g3
and free up your pieces but by starting
with rook g6
if you go king g3 i think that fabi's
idea might be to play bishop f1 to stop
you from going nice
finally finding a job for that bishop at
long last
look at that not so much as a job but
clearing the d3 square for like
yeah and you can't can't usually go rook
a1 because then i played bishop e2 oh my
goodness trade bishops right it's so
tricky
well rook g6 was a really good way to
start
yeah that's a pesky move
if king g3 you use the f1 square
if rook a1 or if the rook ever leaves
and not just a1 if the rook ever leaves
the second rank bishop e2 is actually a
threat now that the rook is pinning the
bishop on g4 so we shouldn't forget that
and if you go king g3 the move is rook
f5 because you get rook f3 check since
the bishop is pinned
well you you said if king she's
got five i thought you said bishop one
on king g3 oh i did but at some point
rook at five okay five is also an idea
i'm also gonna put another thing which
is that now that the rook is pinning the
bishop if this bishop moves are there
ideas of e3 and bishop f5 yes absolutely
right simplifying the position is
and let's not forget about bishop d4
rook takes too far which is a
mountain sized problem with the pin on
the g4 mission yeah this is another one
of those positions where yes white is
winning and hicario is pressing but
the complexity
and the accuracy required isn't properly
reflected in the way that the computer
feels about white's advantage remember
the computers will play perfectly and
they will beat you but this move is a
single step of that eval bar sliding
down not just of blunders like i played
with bishop d4 but because of these
other tactics we're talking about
sacking the e pawn to get pieces off the
board
okay so he's going to move like
g3 wait playing king g3
fabi
so bishop f1 or rook f5
oh no i'm not sure i said bishop one
initially but i
if you go rookie think that's a paper
tiger because of king h4
what
look at that king this it's always funny
when you realize that uh you don't have
to keep your king safe anymore or
passive
yeah that just looks really good for
white
these bishops are nasty
and then you're good here comes knight
h3 by the way yep
i feel like hikaru is is starting to
to see the light at the end of this
tunnel but bishop f1 is far more
resilient in my opinion yeah there's a
funny checkmate if you play king f4
rook f6 check
king takes e4
bishop g2 how ironic the bishop delivers
the check
that's a fun line right there
man that would be the first time the
bishop moves and how many moves
28 or something it's been a long long
time
it's like that soldier who hid
um during world war ii and when they
only emerged like 30 years later because
he didn't know the word ended
was actually really sad
yeah
i found that out like trivial pursuit
every marvel
movie oh that's a trope
i don't even know what we're talking
about at this point
but i do know that we got a lot of
people talking about this tournament by
the way shout out to 39 000 people
watching on twitch right now
that's a lot of people we know that
there are
tens of thousands of you scattered on
other platforms shout out to youtube and
others but 39 000 people on twitch by
the way we crossed 800 000 followers on
our channel today so if you are just
tuning in for the first time hit that
follow button we do appreciate it this
is where the biggest chess events are
covered this is where the big chess
stuff happens so if you happen to be
tuning in
to the
2022 feed a candidate's coverage for the
first time
first of all where have you been this
has been awesome we're moving to the
back half of the event so lucky for you
there's still a week left but hit the
follow button for us get alerted when we
go live all right let's also remind the
39 000 people
who fabiano carwana is he is still
headed into this round uh the the only
other person besides yonder pandashi who
seems to have a real chance of winning
this thing let's remind everybody of
just how great of a player he is
no stranger to the candidates fabiano
caruana stands as a pretty popular
choice for winning it all here in madrid
fabi won this prestigious tournament
four years ago in berlin
in his challenger match against magnus
carlson caruana came just one end-game
moment away from his first world
championship
i wasn't
wasn't playing my best chess today and
magnus so
i think played
played very well
soon to be 30 karwana's chess resume is
matched by few in madrid
born in miami with dual citizenship fabi
became the youngest grand master in u.s
history at age 14.
a decade ago he made history at the
sinkfield cup
winning seven straight games on his way
to a 2844 rating the third highest of
all time
precise calculation and deep knowledge
of opening theory are fabi's calling
cards the italian-american used both to
great effect in the fide grand swiss to
qualify for this event
caruana now aims to become the first
player since vishy anand to win the
candidates in non-consecutive years
but perhaps more importantly fabi looks
towards another shot at the world title
55 000 people watching in english
16 000 on youtube 39 000 on twitch and
we have tens of thousands in other
languages as well so welcome in
to the biggest tournament in chess with
the highest prize potentially at stake
you qualify to play the world chess
champion and maybe become the world
chess champion after a match so shout
out to johnny naradiski by the way for
the voice over on these amazing player
profile highlights we've been doing
they've been awesome i know that we've
heard them a few times but those have
been for the week but they're they're
great they're great stuff and right i
appreciate it am i supposed to agree
yeah yeah they're great thanks for his
feelings they're great no they really
are great uh anyway we we know
that
so much is at stake for fabiano and i
said throwing into that video that other
than yonda pomnishi who right now is the
clear leader if you need a reset on that
uh
it it seems to have become a two-horse
race but there's the guy sitting right
there about to make his move who's
saying not so fast
not so fast
because the crazy thing is if he beats
his fellow american here
and then fabiano
beats yonda ponnachi tomorrow to keep it
close
suddenly
we we officially would be back to a
three horse race in many ways and don't
count out richard report he won his game
yep and if he can get on a bit of a
winning streak himself he can uh bounce
back
some dangerous players in the field
and uh some players eagerly looking for
wins because yonda pandashi and fabiano
karwana collectively have had uh
well more wins than almost games
combined than everybody else uh right
now hikaru nakamura trying to solve this
bishop of one problem that robert
spotted a while ago although it seems
with accurate play this should be the
five-time us champions game to win that
being nakamura this is incredibly
difficult right just you know you need
to find your way out to
[Music]
avoid these brook pins and checks and
mates yeah mates that
i uh miraculously came up with but it
it's just not easy to stabilize here and
we've already seen positions with the
bishop going to d4 where you sacked the
rook there you're showing king of four
that check i don't understand like king
of four f6 is being i know but
the computer says it's the best move but
obviously the computer's just being dumb
because after king takes e4 bishop g2
wins
so in engine speak they always like to
repeat once and then find the best move
so they think that repeating once is
better than doing it right away well
traditional chess engines did not the
neural nets now do you know why which is
i actually do know why if you want to
know it's an interesting topic but
um the the neural nets which are based
on the machine learning technology um in
many ways of of course everyone knows
alpha zero deep
you know deep mind the project by google
and if you don't know it it's a machine
learning project that alpha zero burst
onto the scene and quite literally
changed the game beating the best
strongest computers but the reason is
okay spam this for recaro is that they
have a monte carlo tree system um which
means instead of just playing the
mathematically best move robert
the approach is about increasing the
amount of possible options which is why
they do the weird end game things where
instead of checkmating by force they'll
play it out even longer right so that's
why they now recommend this almost every
time um it's like it's like a contempt
thing where they they just want their
number one goal is actually not to win
the game but to like keep the game going
as long as possible without disrupting
the mathematically best way to play if
you said that like 30 years ago
the the person listening would have
thought we have reached like
technological dystopia yeah computers
are now consciously messing with you
gm larry kaufman will be like it sounds
interesting
wow that sounds like a cool thing i just
like you be like you know doc
in the
delorean um all right
bishop f1 hikaru nodding his head
he was about to make a move
but i wonder if it's it was if it was to
get fabby to sit back down
i don't know if he was like actually
thinking about making a move because
i've seen people do that i mean i've
done that a couple times just sort of
instinctually
you feel like making a move and your
opponent gets up but
cooler heads prevailed and now he's
thinking okay so
king f4 is not the best move because of
that amazing checkmate so regardless of
the tangent i just went on which maybe
was interesting for some of the viewers
you cannot play king of four to take the
pawn because you walk your king into a
mating net but regardless of the
engine's
suggestion the best move in the position
is
is
actually bishop d4
not king of four one that actually makes
a lot of sense now you give the king a
square but rook takes d4 and e3 isn't
that pretty terrifying thing to allow
oh my god there's king f3
ef bishop f5
oh my goodness get this out of here
but it makes so much sense oh yeah yeah
but it might be a hard thing to spot
well karo looks like he's a he's about
to move so if he's
if he spotted this idea and puts the
bishop on d4
i mean king h4 also seems very natural
to me but apparently the engine doesn't
like it
can't put my finger on why exactly well
we have an analysis board let's go to
there i've been wondering oh bishop
you don't want to let black any chance
that's so easy to miss yeah because the
bishop's been doing nothing forever
and ironically she said the bishop is
saving the day after sitting on d3
the whole game but it actually makes a
lot of sense now that i think about it
okay
so bishop d4 there's also this rook f5
move that we were looking at earlier but
i guess the knight can capture on e4
here
that seems scary i don't want to do that
all right i'll do it
yeah it look it looks good
yeah the rook on a2 is oh and
you're actually threatening to even flip
over here
which is super
irritating yeah this actually seems to
be going to cars away with some accurate
play
he needs like three more moves three
more very accurate moves or so
such a weird position
fabiano needs 13 moves to reach time
control so he has 23 minutes on the
clock but he will get more time if he
reaches move 60.
i don't know that this game will reach
move 60 if it car refines all the
accurate
approaches but it is a very very messy
position again we keep saying this
despite the engine saying that white's
advantage is massive and it is
you could step wrong in a many in many
different ways
i yeah
go ahead remember if only black's pawns
could be connected like these are the
worst pawns ever it's unreal how
impotent they're all the worst pawns
ever this is like when you're bowling
and you you think yeah yeah strike on
the first one yeah and then you you do
it and then you get a split like this
and then you're playing with that one
guy who you can't say oh i'm not that
good and then he finds a way to like put
enough spin on the ball to hit
to hit both like the ones that are on
the left on the right side somehow they
do right
yeah the rest of your night is ruined no
i'm just proud of those people why are
you gonna be a hater
because
i i went to bowl with you because we
were all supposed to be bad
i mean
we can't all be the dude you know
moving on
get the camera out of my face
[Laughter]
uh anyway hikaru is uh
trying to think about how to approach
this what's up i'm just thinking about
donnie
donnie yeah
i don't know i'm not getting it darko no
from the big lebowski oh okay big
lebowski yeah yeah yeah
the dude
i said they did before you just didn't
hear me oh sorry yeah
bishop oh hicaro found bishop d4 mm-hmm
this is tough fabi might take it and go
for the force there to guess that the
game
might end with king f3
well the position is tough enough that
it's
hard to find other moves right if you
rook g5 is the only other candidate move
i had in my head because taking
advantage of the fact that the bishop is
no longer here
if i can put the rook here you can't
take on e4 because the bishop would hang
so
i don't know what the response honestly
the response is probably just king f4
we'll just go for it i'm just going to
trust my instincts see if the engine
likes it and they do
because it has a dual threat one is
bishop f5
which is the worst
that is a show stopper
in fact that just might be
there's no defense you can't move the
rook on g6 preemptively you can't move
the rook because now the rook is hanging
and get this moving the king doesn't
actually help because bishop f5 wins
even if it's not a skewer
brutal
yeah bishop d4 was
potentially the cherry on top
for hikaru nakamura
fabiano has 21 minutes and he will maybe
burn all of it trying to come up with
his last resources here
while he's thinking let's let's back up
real quick and remind everybody there is
one other game still going on here in
round eight of the 2022 feeder
candidates if you're just tuning in
uh the order was john upon rishi
tournament leader a quick draw
protecting
his lead
against china's number one dingley ren
richard report won a fantastic game
against young christoph duda the number
one player from poland uh richard report
also was wearing a super sexy red jacket
was it red was it pink was it salmon
we'll ask richard and see what his
opinion was of the color but it was hot
i'll say that it was hot fire
it was a hot jacket
i'm comfortable literally
he looks good
has he won that game
man it's nice to see chess players
showing up in style can i get an amen
for 40 000 viewers come on all right
amen all right thank you yeah you know
it all right richard looked good i'm
going to say that
and then we sit here
we sit here with nakamura and caruana as
we know the biggest
the biggest game in in the round you're
looking at me and then we have baruch
and rajaba still playing over there i
feel like he's going to fill mugatu on
us
like richard report he is so hot right
now so hot right now
jacobian from now on yep all right well
uh richard report
also kept caught up with dina bell and
kaya but another player did
uh dingley ren after drawing his game
quickly against yon napomnishi caught up
with dina and here were his thoughts on
the round eight quick battle versus the
tournament leader
ding thanks for joining that was a
relatively short game today uh did you
have any intentions to have a bigger
fight
yes if we didn't play this jewish line
i'm ready for a fight
but unfortunately he is called for this
theoretical job
didn't you have any temptation to
deviate and and have some play anyhow
first i need to
be so late and
since he had a very good preparation in
opening
but actually if
if
i was not caught in preparation yeah i'm
going to play for a win at some point
but today i didn't have any chance to
win
how are you going to approach this
second half of the tournament that just
started
well just take it as a normal one not
the candidates just
and try to enjoy the tournament
what do you think about the time control
here it is uh very special not to have
any increments i think so this this
advantage for me especially in this
tournament since i misplayed
uh two winning positions
they're both
uh
in
in time trouble
uh
maybe i i'm not
get used to this
time control
but yeah it will put it it proved that
many settlements especially in time
trouble
thanks a lot dean thank you
yeah interesting thoughts specifically
related to the time control that may
become a talking point in this game as
well as fabiano is about to be under
time pressure again
uh if you don't know the storyline it's
been a big one because this is the first
major event the first candidates to not
have increment which is a standard thing
top players are used to to get a little
bit of time added back to every clock
and a lot of times guys you manage your
time
and you've had habits of managing your
time for a couple decades in your career
knowing that you can survive a scramble
because there's always that little help
not so in this term it's a very
different twist for them and we know
that it's been
something that a lot of players feel
have affected them yeah hikaru himself
said that he felt that he didn't well
first of all that java didn't hold
against him because there was no
increment approaching mu 40 to get that
extra hour and he felt that he didn't
beat jana pamashi because of the lack of
incrim because
way before mu 40 he felt like he needed
to speed up because once you get down to
the wire as we're saying you don't get
the 30 seconds added per move yeah which
is standard in most chess events where
every time you hit the clock your move
is made you gain 30 seconds so you can
gain a quick couple minutes by just
playing fast moves or by repeating moves
so here you don't get that in the
players some of them have been
struggling don you talk a little bit
about that because i think that some of
the spectators will say like you know
get over it right like come on like
you're chess players and it's not that
big of a deal but habits
i mean they're called habits for a
reason right because they're hard to
break and if someone play chess at a
very high level you know these guys what
it takes and maybe not playing the
candidates but like
it's not easy for a player to just turn
off the way they've approached the
opening the middle game their habitual
ways of tackling the critical moments
and now they don't have the time that
they usually have so talk about how hard
that is for a player to change their
approach well first of all you know they
did sort of get over and they're playing
the candidates yes they are they have no
choice and they played you know norway
chess before
uh before that which didn't have
increment
uh but but it did have some players
losing on time
um
you know partially your relationship
with uh no increment depends on where
you grew up
um so for example
you know in the u.s a lot of tournaments
at least in my youth
um that's kind of still weird saying
that uh but i just have to accept that
yes okay so a lot of tournaments in my
youth were like 90 minutes for for 40
moves that increment was unheard of like
the most you got was five second delay
yeah and that was already a luxury
so
when i
you know came to europe for the first
time and started playing i i had to
adjust the increment it was it was the
other way around there was no more
flagging
um and you know how much i like that
flagging losing on time yeah but for
someone like ikaru he also
grew up in the us and fabi but they've
just played super tournaments for so
long that they've become completely
acclimated to
the 90 plus 30
uh time control and that influences
absolutely everything yep like you make
the first 15 moves fast sometimes
because you want to gain those extra
sometimes like 10 12 minutes and then
you have 40 seconds to move so 15 moves
you make right you've already got seven
seven and a half minutes more right so
it really permeates the influence of
increment permeates throughout the
entire
uh first time control yeah and without
it you you really do have to change your
strategy and the paranoia of getting one
of those time scrambles which you know
these players understandably
really really dislike
as you indicated that paranoia is real
yeah they're not just you know
complaining about it for no reason it
really does cause mistakes but at the
same time
you know you could argue that it makes
it more entertaining and the more
flagging the better and nobody's allowed
to argue with that
right
right right
like you said you said they're getting
over it they are getting over it because
there's a happy million dollar prize
pool and a chance at the world chess
championship title at stake so they're
here they're not outside caring yeah
they're not picketing no increments
they're not they're not right
but but at the same time they are losing
on time now in top level chess for the
first time you mentioned norway chess
right and nobody's lost on time here but
we've seen huge mistakes because of time
scrambles like dingley wren
losing a winning position against him
over jabba meaning he lost the winning
position eventually drew so so it is
interesting it is
what i'm not blaming down the increment
yeah that was just uh i mean maybe he
does yeah for someone what exactly are
you not going to think
his mistake was that i totally used you
on that yeah yeah
not like we're calling dingley or
anything with that
but it could make him uncomfortable
throughout the game so it could have
impacted him along the way which yeah we
keep saying you need to be as objective
as possible but
i don't know i mean players they need to
get accustomed to different time
controls and different things and just
because it's always been a certain way
doesn't mean that's the best way yep
right tradition for the sake of
tradition
is not that appealing lingerman is
pretty recent too i think people a lot
of people think well this is how it's
always been like no we used to have
analog clocks and people didn't know how
much time they had left like one minute
or 11. i think we should have
adjournments honestly go backwards yeah
go back and think i know i just don't
think we should have clocked by the way
i didn't play at your level but i will
say i learned the same i had the same
experience and we all growing up in the
american tournament system had the same
thing playing increment was foreign to
me i remember when i first started
playing with increment because i grew up
you know not not being used to it so had
to adjust the other way in fact i lost a
lot of winning positions not
appreciating that i was better up on the
clock and played too fast thinking my
opponent there's no way they can hold
this they have
you know 20 you know 32 seconds right
but they could they were getting time
back and so there are obviously a lot of
dynamics that go into managing your time
because we
we can't just play chess for years on
one game you have to have a clock for a
reason but are you like in a company
correspondence thing where your game has
been daily games have been lasting for
years that is that is true um chess.com
has daily chess where you can have
multiple days per move and we're still
wrapping up the winner of i think the
2018 chess.com staff tournament
i was eliminated because i don't have
that kind of vision there are people in
our company that are just like taking
the max days per move we got to figure
this out and get rid of vacation time
for staff members that is another story
all right um i mean there were some
stories of uh correspondence games that
were paused you know
for the
uh second world war zooms yeah like this
game was played between 1940 you know
1938 and 1944
so well fabi is thinking trying to find
any last chance he can let's we talked
about rook takes d4 with the idea of
getting e3 because the bishop is no
longer there maybe one thing he's
thinking about is e3 right away
with the idea that if he forces this
back and he
does he have time to swing back to
freeing the bishop to get a trade going
i i would imagine no
but at least it's an idea to uh to keep
the game alive it's an interesting one
because you of course can't take the
bishop on
a d3 because the rook takes and that
spells a lot of trouble where white is
fortunate to be able to survive in fact
so
you're not taking the bishop there but
maybe you can
there's no threat right bishop f5 isn't
really that big of a threat because your
knight covers the bishop on
a g4 so maybe you can just play bishop
d4
she's like put your bishop back in a
nice square and i should be five you
move your king so now you're willing for
it you're saying yeah why not after the
trade
yeah too many weaknesses too many too
many active pieces the c4 pawn is
dropping the a6 pawn probably isn't that
much longer for this board either and
the king on f4 is not getting checkmated
he made a move he brought the bishop
back to d3
and hikaru comes back to the board he's
enjoying that players vip area doesn't
like to sit at the board while fabiano
was thinking today
i don't think akaro has spent very much
time at all at the board when fabiano
was on the clock
um
well he better not miss rook takes d4
now rook takes d4 is officially a threat
because after c takes d4 c3 runs for
example
actually king of four it's very strong
because it because it's another set of
eyes on e3 yeah so you're back to this
idea
yeah that stops e3 so unfortunately for
bobby that the most logical move in the
position it seems
organically naturally stops rook takes
d4 because of this new threat but if you
play knight d1 like i was talking about
before i think that does reel out or
maybe it doesn't even this even knight
d1 even my bad move works here
that's the worst kind of situation when
you set a trap and then you start to
realize that every single move stops
against it
your opponent will have to play like
even rook a1 probably defends yeah
you play it you set a trap and every
single move stops it um
there's got to be one that doesn't okay
knight h3 that's the one
that goes for this side that might be
the one that allows it still winning
takes takes
and no you can go for it i know rook b2
is probably the worst move on the board
because it walks right
is the one move
that walks into the trick that fabiano
is tr is laying the trap that bobby lays
with bishop d3
yeah what a vicious strap because rook
b2 is such a natural move
yeah that's and that goes to show that
hikaru's piece placement right he's
optimized
these pieces bishop's on d4 protecting
and protecting by the pawn on c3 the
bishop on g4 is a really useful piece
especially after king f4 which threatens
bishop f5 and plays it icaro has indeed
played on the board just don't rush the
move bishop f5 i don't think
that might walk into some exchange
sacrifices oh yeah
king of four
threatens bishop f5 you don't want to
wait it is a threat you could play
bishop f5 because takes takes e3 the
knight from f2 captures
on d3 and then e3 is also hanging so
the wheels the wheels come off here
right but
probably don't take that rook on he's
gonna say if you take oh you think you
can because g2 rook a6
oh king f8 rook e6 oh that is a look at
this that's you said sexy this is a fun
sorry this is a fun line
that we got to show
because in a rare
scenario i was keeping track of what
dania was saying in my own head and i
wanted to show the final position
uh so
this again is one of those lines that
shows that even in a line like that
white is accidentally winning so
unfortunately the wheels
have truly come off for black in this
position
we see kind of a frustrated fabiano
right there um
[Music]
i mean he knows he you can just see it
on his face yeah he knows where this is
going
i mean tremendous defense
yeah but yeah the the idea he found
running the h-pawn up was
brilliant and put hikaru on notice he
had to find all the right moves to keep
his winning advantage but it looks like
nakamura has
and something hikara has done well since
he's returned to over-the-board play is
when he lost to levon ironian in the
first game of the feta grand prix he
then beat him in the return game so
these top few players in the world ikaru
despite you know losing that first game
he gets his vengeance yeah and obviously
that's not easy because to this point
five on a car want five out of seven
he's won three games drawn four has lost
none
so
hey cara like sometimes when you beat
him you poke the bear and you just
nobody
wants to see a car angry
he's always had a mindset and attitude
don you've talked about where he just
it comes from many ways because he is
just the online chess king in so many
ways he's just so resourceful never goes
away it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
the opportunities he finds when you
think he should just be dead
and you know obviously he's played more
online chess that matters right the as
as more
money and opportunities are there than
maybe anybody
maybe that's also helped him grow is
this transition with kobe behind us
coming back to over the board chess he's
qualified for the candidates this
opportunity that he sees now to rebound
from her previous loss to fabiano his
mindset is there
right
and you know for a lot of people i think
they very naively thought that okay you
know when you give your car three
minutes he makes the most of the makes
the most of it but when you give him you
know 90 minutes or 120
you know some people thought what like
after a minute he's just gonna stop
thinking like that's no no like hikaru
is just as capable of putting that time
to very very good use
um
you know as as
as any other super gm even i see shown
he's better at putting that time to use
i mean his time management has been
superb yep and that's an often
overlooked thing he almost never gets
into serious time pressure yeah and i
think another element that he has
admitted favors him at least in
psychologically speaking is he makes a
heck of a lot of money in his quote
unquote other career as a streamer or
you could consider his main career and
that's really big because richard report
one of the big story lines heading into
this event was that he has applied for a
transfer to the romanian federation
because he has sponsorship and richard
has talked about how he doesn't make a
lot of money playing chess and he hasn't
played that many tournaments and you
know that's difficult he um you know is
trying to make a living with his desired
profession so the fact that hikaru you
know whether or not he wins the
candidates can just go back online on
this very platform
that we're on right now and make a very
very nice living that's a big deal and
he has said in interviews that he used
to put a lot of pressure on himself and
now he still cares literally but he
doesn't have to put his entire like
sense of self his finances everything
into each and every individual move and
that can be very helpful when you can
play with the clear head
it's funny because not only does he you
know you said he has the he has the
biggest most followed chess channel on
twitch by the way if you're one of the
40 000 viewers and haven't hit the
follow button for our channel do so
right now uh we just crossed 800 000
today but he has the most view he's
doing well and he said yesterday in
studio when he joined us that he's
already looking forward to getting back
to it he misses his community and his
mindset is like look i already miss it
but
that's not stopping him from delivering
a huge
huge wound to his fellow americans
chances to uh to maybe win the
candidates and and get himself back in
the running right that's his job we see
chat getting involved in this
conversation having a massive advantage
versus fabi seems exhausting
lots of props to fabi for this defense
even if unsuccessful
little forests for us
that's what we saw yesterday right when
fabi came in after a win and you see
hikaru is going to be skipping home all
giddily excited to record his game
announcements
she's been doing after everybody also
has a great youtube channel as you check
it
but i think it's often overlooked when
one side
plays a brilliant game that
you know chess is too a chess game has
two authors
and fabby was
a co-author he wrote the book
you have to read this sorry it's that's
not collusion but
nepotism for those who don't know the
nickname for yondapan machine carry me
out of this
that's bad even for donya's standards
this is the king of bad punches if it's
bad by my standards that means you ought
to be ashamed of yourself you need to
reconsider your life choices you need to
sit down and just ask with a notebook
and start
rethinking how you live wow and i've
been scolded for being too mean to chat
look at this
you know
constructive criticism
sometimes you go it's so bad
that you steal the show
but that was that was ugly that was ugly
there but we do appreciate chat
and uh everybody involved maybe just
you know to distract yourself read some
i don't know edgar alan nepa or
something oh here we go edgar allen nepo
oh man save me
the uh
i know that a lot of people have been
looking for who's going to win this
tournament but we might be finding nepo
on top of the standings at the end of
this one
fine are we still finding nepa is it
a refund finding nemo that was am i
allowed to even say the word disney on a
show without getting a copyright strike
these days okay
we're moving on
moving on um
finding dory was not a very good sequel
to finding nemo i'm sorry i'll be the
minority and say it
okay i'm just saying it all right
um
we're gonna have one game still going
even if this nakamura car wanna battle
comes to a close quickly here
uh because
rajab and farujia
looks as confusing as where we left it
a set of rooks have come off the board
along with a pair of knights but there's
still a lot of
a lot of messiness over there
yeah and all there is
trying to make a pun out of her jabba's
last name no
in russian means toad
uh-huh the first three letters kind of
mean red
red toad i'd say the chat doesn't like
it but we're increasing in viewership as
as this show goes off the rails solely
but surely they know we're about to head
into a car wreck where danny says
something highly inappropriate
and uh i'll beat you to the punch don't
worry all right well keen to g8 oh hey
car we have off let's head back over to
the nakamura car want to battle bishop
f5 is on the board and
he probably quintuple checked rook takes
f5 yeah imagine ruining this entire year
what would be amazing is if somehow we
get this position and hikaru takes on g6
that would be what the people want
and he we might for sure would yeah for
sure he would to end the game with a
forced mate that allows black to get a
queen if you missed the line earlier you
take your threading checkmate which is
why you can't get a queen and even if
you try to run out we still trap the
king
allowing
a brand new queen to come to the board
and rookie yate delivers the game here's
something
what are you gonna say the same thing
there's another way yeah okay go ahead
robert
i've talked enough no no you
you asked if we wanted something funny
so you can we both just telepathy here
well i feel like i'm really a part of
this inside joke too because i obviously
also see the win right so i'm gonna let
i won't argue with you guys as to which
one plays it though
i'll just let
you guys do it
so
all right i'll take the reigns after
king f8
uh rook takes c6
d2 first sorry oh sorry d2 rook a6 king
f8
white can play the very much in your
face move bishop takes e3
and after d1 queen
uh you go rook a check now this seems to
be counter productive what are you doing
letting the king out of the cage after
king e7 and suddenly g5 check
i think black was born yesterday he's
not going to the d file but you're going
to make him go to the d this isn't a
mate it's not as fun as dylan it's
almost stalemate after king e6 if there
was a pawn on f4
then after
king d7 or d8 king e6 i guess you could
play f5 check but you get the point yeah
so
there are more ways to win
[Music]
when you see checkmate look for better
yep when you see checkmate look for
better those were the famous words of uh
every great chess player fabi might
resign here actually it sounds extreme
but he actually might
he only has eight
minutes and 50 seconds to play what
would be 10 moves so
he's uh
he's got
problems here um
yeah it's too early to resign
you can't resign you got a material
advantage and technically he still does
it's just so easy for white now because
the e4 pawn is falling
and the bishop will take on e4 followed
by the knight takes the knight comes
into c5
and which means the a6 pawn falls and
then the b4 pawn becomes a runner it
just is all like pretty straightforward
okay so he's made a move
rook h6 rook h6
okay all things concerned not giving up
the ghost yet hoping for a blunder from
hikaru to let him back in the game
now i don't like bishop takes e4 as much
because this rook is annoying on coming
to h4 exactly yeah in fact that's his
trick
and if you move here for example he's
still finding tricks
yeah hikaru is is still having to work
to finish this you saw that little head
nod there
he's like all right
bobby's not going away he's got some
tricks here yeah but knight g4 i think
is very very strong because you you have
to keep the work on the sixth ring
otherwise bishop b6 yeah well yeah and
oh yeah okay your move is only slightly
stronger than me grabbing upon
but but you do allow rook takes at five
again or you have to as you keep saying
you have to check a million times that
this is still winning and you just bring
your king back and it is the pawn isn't
quite quick enough the rook gets
captured with check very importantly and
the bishop comes back to f2 or you stop
the pawn and you win the game but it's
one of those things that are so easy to
overlook because it didn't work a move
ago yep and now you just think ah it
didn't work then it won't work now but
it could he goes for it
no hesitation he's double checked that
rook takes f5 doesn't work despite the
discovered check and running of the
pawns
they have the running of the bulls here
in madrid
isn't that this is the running of the
pawns what isn't that in pamplona i have
no idea it's in spain
i'm just going to reveal that i don't
know madrid equals spain i'm sorry that
sounded like the worst ugly american
comment to make but i know that it was a
i knew it was a spanish tradition
complimented you oh thank
you i'm pretty mad so i think you should
get rid of
that reference
all right knight g4 attacks the rook
threatens to take with check it's like
seven hours into the show
the ship e6 check is coming if the rook
leaves the sixth rank
so that means i have to run to
see
six but then we're back to bishop to e4
as we said yeah
i think just all of black's pawns are
falling because they're split we
mentioned that earlier you pawn's best
friends another pawn you feel like you
can stabilize keep them protected but
here you need your heavy pieces to
defend on the bishop on d3 which has
been protecting the c4 and e4 pawns
first e4 is gonna fall and then once the
bishop gets traded then c4 is next and
once those go it's just very easy for
recaro
but fabio is not resigning for a reason
there are opportunities to blunder right
hikaru looks zoned in focused and bobby
is
also now under seven minutes to make
nine moves
but i'm just saying like caruana doesn't
enjoy getting beaten over the head
that's not what he's into you know what
i mean if fabi is still at the board
it's because he thinks there are
some opportunities
for first window and uh
so as long as we're here all of you will
be here as well that's right sit in your
chairs and don't go anywhere or i will
find you
42 000 of you on twitch but the
depressing thing now is is knight g4 can
drop back to e3 finally broke from a2 to
g2
finally
right danny
i've been calling for this square
since i was a young boy
dream is real
put that rook on b5 and now here i come
to the g file that's right
right on
this is all i've been dreaming about
since i was a little kid
i was getting active
lemonade
all i wanted was that nine weeks all i
ever wanted was a 93. i told dad i don't
want football i don't want your life
i want momma
i want my own king on e5 that's right
and you got your wish
i don't want your life dad i want my
knight on e3 you'll get your wish if you
wait long enough all right
robert has disengaged himself gracefully
from this
conversation
well if that night comes to e3 we might
get another visit from jebediah that's
jebediah not yet i ain't no jedi i'm
jeff jebediah with a bee
jebediah died
not to confuse a jedi
not to be confused but i wouldn't ever
claim to be something i'm not
yeah this is over
your little act is over
yes and the game is also over all right
we're doing my little action we're
having a great time here we don't want
to miss the final moments of this game
without you know let's go to the bird's
eye view again there is another game
still going also a reminder to the fans
that um
if this game ends in a victory for
hikaru nakamura we will much more than
likely have him in studio so you're not
going to want to miss that interview
we'll talk to him about everything that
was this battle his preparation his
mindset coming in
obviously what he feels he does to his
outside chances to come back and win
this thing it's not over if he gets a
victory
so we've got um we've got a lot of
things to unpack with hikaru and you're
not going to want to miss that interview
should he get the w
um that's like my
insurance statement to those who are
tired of jeb you got to stick around for
ricardo can we look at the fergie game
for just like sure a little bit hey
just check the position i know i have
the mouse but you have just as much
control over this show ah
this is a democracy here that's very
wholesome you're welcome let's go let's
go look at that game here we go
all right i've i've satiated myself now
we can come back
because all you wanted was to get
perugia on camera it's like that scene
in uh national lampoon's european
vacation where he's touring all the
landmarks and he has a checklist eiffel
tower check
palazzo in rome check f3 by the way
check to the queen check herself before
she wrecks herself get out of my king
side guard day you know that's what they
used to say in medieval times when the
queen was attacked really yeah good
guard day oh so there was a check for
the king like shot like shock shock i
think it's a french term gardei yeah
interesting i didn't know that
so gardena the queen queen has to drop
back to g6 only square right to keep six
protected
how do you assess such a position like
whose pawn structure is better slash
worse
it's funny because they both have clear
pros and cons yeah you don't like the
double pawns but there's a queen an open
g file a rook on an open f file yeah
that's c7 pawn and the
b5 pawn those are left alone so at some
point i feel like white can start aiming
towards the queen side
conversion time pressure again yep 15
minutes to make 12 moves
that's that's not an easy task
a little more than a minute of move and
while the position is not as as crazy as
maybe what's going on between hicaro and
fabiano sometimes that's even harder
right because there's no concrete things
to calculate this is full of subtleties
here's what i tend to think about these
positions and you can say this is
instructive for for chat or not but like
i know my pieces are awkward af right
now but
what is what am i visualizing like
what is my goal position because before
i can calculate my way out of this
situation where they're weird you have
to i have to know where i want to drive
the car right so but that's what i'm
struggling with is like
where do i visualize my i mean i know
there's obvious things like yeah
imaginarily put my queen on d7 that'd be
great it might not even be very good by
the way 905 discovery but you feel me
robert so what's the goal for white to
kind of coordinate untangle here yeah i
guess one of the big questions is what's
black's plan right so in coming up with
your own plan you also want to take into
account what your opponent is thinking
so
there could be an annoyance like rook g7
at the right moment just to eye the pawn
on
g3 and i think that the rook has done
its duty on e3 right now that the palm
goes to f3 e4 is already defended c3 is
not going to be
targeted any time soon it's a little
back yeah so maybe bring that rook back
just to step one
and usually figure out where does this
queen belong is the queen going to
venture up the queen side and go after
those pawns or should the queen help in
the king side defense and the rook
maybe goes the a file at some point i
like that a lot it's not
i'm not really answering your question
directly because i do think that there's
no
clear plan for white just yet but i also
think that black doesn't exactly have a
clear plan so i'm just gonna start by
making sure that my king side is safe
before i start looking over the queen
side i love that rookie 2
was a move because now it makes you meet
anything they try to do here play tickle
on either file and the rook can help
with defense which makes the queen feel
a little more
frisky to kind of
to get active over here right it could
also go to a7 with the additional
benefit of being able to then drop back
to f2 or g1 should
you know more more hands on the king
side be necessary i like that but
alireza is really wrestling with the
absence of a plan here and i think
that's really bothering him and i think
it's been bothering him since the first
time control you could just sense it
that was kind of why i asked the
question the way i did i was sort of
trying to say maybe this is why he's
struggled with time management here this
game in general has lacked a clear
vision a clear goal
um
and
now
now rookie 2 looks like a good move but
you still then have to make sure you
calculate well what your goal is for the
queen on the queen on the queen side
i'll give you another idea maybe white
can throw in the move c4 at some point
i think we're being cued to go back to
this game is there something that's
happened over here
we'll head back over a couple of moves
not sure what happened there
knight e3 so rook hd 693 rook b5 it
looks like yeah
wait
90 oh 93 oh my knight came to e3 your
lifelong dream was so good you weren't
even there for it
i don't want your life dad
um
the knight is on e3 i like your tone
what i don't like your tone
the rook will come to gt if the rook
comes to gg wait icaro is a little
frustrated we'll see
but
he's picking flavors at this point um
yeah wonder
where'd you do rook b7
didn't even just move your bishop and
put your knight in f5 it just feels like
or bishop e5 i mean i need really
anything
yeah
should be five bishop e6 knight f5 i
mean
you're coming in from all sides
and you have to play rook b7 because
otherwise you dropped g7 and probably it
made it soon bishop c8 yeah come in oh
king e5 is just mean oh my god i have a
line bishop c8 rook c7 bishop takes g7
wait what's going on oh knight f5 at the
end but both bishops are hanging which
is kind of cool wow if you take here
there's a discovered check that wins the
rook
if you take on g7 at the end of this
massive trade white
brings the four camera down
with knight f5 check to take the rook so
that's a real problem
completely unnecessary but demonstrates
the extent of white domination yep
and the car looked like he was about to
grab his rook
yep
he's so much time so much time faviano
does not have a ton of time five and a
half minutes for eight moves
he also doesn't have a lot of options
left on the board to keep this thing
spicy
yeah we're a few moves away from
resignation
yeah and fabiano looks you know
he's looking off the side like where did
i go wrong like how did this get out of
hand so badly yep and for hikaru i mean
he's always looked confident in this
game he was confident here in the studio
saying he's playing well but during the
game
from the start where he got that
imbalance
it wasn't entirely
evident who it favored but hikari just
by body language by the speed of his
play it did feel like he was in his
comfort zone
no that's what i was saying earlier it
seemed like he understood not just
whatever theory and prep he brought to
the table concretely but he had a good
feel for this position from the very
beginning it's evident by how quickly he
was able to play the advantage he earned
on the clock obviously the position on
the board
says that he knew what he was doing
and h4 b4 we talked about those two pawn
moves both brilliant ones
and uh
he's about to make this thing a mess in
madrid
wow and you know what else he's done
well recovered from oversights
i mean he hasn't reacted emotionally he
missed a couple of things this game i
think similar thing happened in his
first win against timur
he's just cold i mean knight h1
uh was incredible and then of course
h4 and then later on when he missed h3
you know reacting immediately with rook
a2 and bishop d1 rattling off these
critical moves it's not about playing
perfectly nobody plays perfectly over 60
moves yep it's about the way you react
to
adversity during a game and he's reacted
tremendously well bishop c5 is perfectly
good enough
well not a lot of people saw this coming
just which in hindsight maybe you know
we should have thought differently
hikaru has been playing well he had the
white pieces but fabiano playing as well
as anybody besides yonder palm rishi you
know you just you felt like he was
uh on form and would keep it that way i
don't know that you blame bobby for this
game i think you give hikaru credit
right he'd be scoring his first
classical win against fabiano in seven
years
i think the maybe the one thing you can
regret not necessarily blame anybody for
is the opening choice because fabiano
he's been very solid all tournament yeah
and now he
got into position that was like very
hectic yeah and
he didn't have control of the game yeah
so i think from that perspective it's a
situation where like if he could go back
in time maybe he would have played a
petrov maybe he would have played
something that just gives white a tiny
advantage but at least you don't have to
figure out wait who's better here
because i don't know if rook and two
pawns is better than two minor pieces
yeah it should be but here it's not and
what's my actual plan so i do think
there is that element to the calculus
but as you're saying you do just have to
give hikaru a tremendous amount of
credit and respect for coming into this
game giving it his all and just
outplaying fabiano caron that's the long
and short of it well and then because of
what you just said like there's no way
to not take the next step of the
storyline so if that's the case and an
opening choice might be the only thing
you could regret why did you make that
opening choice is it because of what
happened yesterday with report losing to
yon upon machine you're a half a point
behind maybe you're not as confident
that you're gonna be able to win on
command against yan and you felt like
well if there's a chance for me to mix
up a game it might be this game and just
not that not that he was necessarily
trying to beat hikaru with black out of
the gate
but he clearly chose an opening that was
going to offer a mess right and so that
that's what you unpack the story lines
right you look at the standings and you
wonder if he was and i'm not saying that
was you know a totally subjective
reasoning but they're
you know was that part of the thought
process you know looking for an
opportunity to create a mess on the
board i don't know yeah i mean this is
the fact that we're having this
discussion i think epitomizes
the
just importance of having for example a
really good team of seconds and a team
of seconds who i think a lot of people
think that the process of choosing
openings to see caro goes down the
correct blind king e5 is just about you
know turning on stockfish overnight and
then choosing the line that gives the
best evaluation like no there's
there's a menu of 30 different options
all of them are good objectively
and uh it's incredibly hard to choose an
opening based on your style based on the
tournament situation and uh you know
mistakes in the in the choosing of an
opening are very common even by these
incredibly elite players and yeah
hindsight is 20 20. so yeah
i think we will learn and move on i
think i said you know the other day
are
that
looking ahead to this matchup right that
hikaru nakamura has shown
a
string of long preparation but not
preparation that necessarily had the
ton of bite if his opponent handled like
dingley ren play that perfect game
but fabiano caruana dingley red they're
capable of playing that perfect game to
withstand that preparation but this was
such a different type of game the style
of the game
it's one where you know all these
players are pretty universal they can
play any type of position but kara
nakamura plays this type of position
exceptionally well yeah and it it's
showing so you know it's hindsight is
2020 it's very easy to sit here and say
this and that should have
been done differently and i think for
fabiano because the tournament continues
or just because he's going to lose this
game doesn't mean the tournament ends in
fact he has destiny in his hands if he
can beat yon upon rishi tomorrow but
ultimately you're going to regret some
of the choices today you're going to
lose this game for sure because hit cars
just playing perfectly right now the
knight g4 just to attack this rook on f6
because the rook goes to c6 then your
bishop can go to d7 and
one of those rooks is going
there is one more resource though knight
g4 i find it very admirable fabi is
still fighting
even you know when the result is
essentially not in question
always making sure hikaru doesn't get
careless right and takaru is showing the
poise and focus of someone who
doesn't look like he's about to get
careless but that's what we've been
saying at the beginning it's totally
winning for white but there are
opportunities to blunder here and unless
fabiano thinks those are gone he's going
to keep playing right so the fact that
he's still sitting at the board means i
was joking about the viewers not going
anywhere means that we still have
something to look at and talk about and
by the way again reminder to 43 000 of
you on twitch and tens of thousands
elsewhere that
regardless of this result what robert
just said is true fabiano will get his
chance no matter what against yonda
pandashi tomorrow
tune in games start at 6 a.m pacific
time 3 p.m here in local madrid time
and
he has the white pieces so the
candidates is not over and it just adds
more drama to the match-up that is the
american
uh tomorrow the the leading american
going up against the tournament leader
there and yonda palmishi so um
wow yeah wow um
those are
the round nine match-ups before you
for tomorrow
fabiano caron as we said will get white
against yonder palmishi and as robert
said he has never won
a classical game against yonda pandashi
the previous challenger the most recent
challenger to magnus carlson but hicario
hadn't won a classical game in seven
years against fabiano
we just had a global pandemic things are
weird in the world now who knows maybe
maybe maybe tomorrow bobby figures out a
way to crack the nut that has been
yonder pomnishi and we saw on the
graphic as well that hikar nakamura
plays the black pieces against team over
jabba yeah java hasn't won a game of
classical chess since 2019 yeah he's
struggling in this event
hikaru is i think it's three wins zero
loss in a bunch of draws so
he car was a good record against her
jabba so the black pieces maybe he's not
to be deterred and he's saying at this
point in the tournament i need to keep
winning so i'll take my chances
although the way timur is playing he's
he's so tough to crack with black with
with black i mean i don't
probably the last loss with white has
come even before his last classical win
in 2014 or so
fabiano is all in now on the sack that
we've been waiting for
like we said running of the bulls not in
madrid
uh but this is the running of the pawns
in madrid
probably not running very far yeah the
king simply slides over
and after e2 pretty sure you just play
bishop of two right away yeah division
of labor there is important because the
rook has to be kept for taking a6 i
think yeah so king e5
e2
and then bishop f2 will stop the pawn
yep king e5 e2 bishop f2
you keep the rook here
and that might be what gets fabiano to
resign right there
and the bishop on d3 did its
first job in forever i guess it went to
f1 at some point but that bishop just
has been such a bad piece it's
unbelievable honestly
yeah it really is
that's honestly the the narrative that
unites all stages of the game because
nothing else has remained the same
except that bishop
are there any other
tricks here for black that
of rook b8 try to swing around and make
some counter play happen
wow the engine likes rook takes a six i
don't know if i'd have the
you know the cojones to play them
yeah
wait why is it good he said just push
your b-pawn at the end and so you allow
the piece
and then you just win with the b-pawn
that doesn't seem like something we're
going to see here right you just put
like a bishop on e1 and stop the pawn
but no no let's give up the people why
would you do that why would you keep
your extra piece even king d4 to me
feels like the most human move because
if rookie 8 then all playback should be
one
right and if not i'll take next but all
right computers
i for one welcome our artificially
intelligent overlords
welcome to 44 000 people watching on
twitch hit the follow button while
you're here the biggest events in chess
are on this channel right now this is
the most important tournament in chess
it is the candidates and it decides who
will challenge magnus carlson for the
world championship title
and the player on the top of the screen
there 500 caraway he did just that in
2018 he drew every single game in
classical chess he didn't lose a single
one but unfortunately for him the
quicker time which was that's where
magnus got him and hikaru nakamura i
doubt he needs too much of an
introduction to our online audience
because he's likely their introduction
to the game of chess or they've been
following him for many years and the
tales of his retirement have been
greatly exaggerated he's not just
retired in his decline yeah he's not
just
unretired but he's playing amazing chess
he's he's been gaining a ton of rating
points his performance rating and his
events have been amongst the highest in
the entire world yep so hikaru nakamura
i mean he's not just making fans because
you know his online personality there is
that of course but it's also his great
chess playing
and
let's not forget and i'm really jumping
the gun here but ikar's record with
magnus during those rapid tournaments
during the pandemic yeah it was really
darn good and i think that was the first
sign that
you know he's not done with classical
chess
even though that was rapid
well he's a maybe a more confident
player than he's ever been in his career
he feels more at home as a streamer you
set it himself he has a community behind
him it almost like he feels like the
pressure is off in his career like he
made it he did it he arrived right
financially secure i mean it matters and
it's true right whoa whoa
one second no it's gonna go back up
right
one second
what is the idea wait it allows rookie
oh
my goodness no but king no
no but that idea is actually quite
dangerous king d4 rookie 4 check
king c5 rookie 5. analysis board we
shout go to king d4 obviously winning
but
king c5 this is this is still just
rookie five
oh and if i take your bishop b4 yeah and
if i go back you have a draw
uh
wait no no if bishop before i have king
d4 no rook takes d5 checking rook d1
it's not so simple oh my gosh
wait even this is winning i think
because you're going to get to the c4
pawn but this gets really complicated
wait
did the car just blunder that
that that's an easy thing to blunder
because it's a retreating move robert
says this all the time right you can
miss moves like this
because this is a warm and cozy move you
play it to feel warm and cozy right but
it turns out
that the fact that you put the bishop
there too early might allow a shocking
repetition now the king can still
you know if he goes up to starwood like
right now if you go to the game position
if he goes up to
can can we go to king d6 yeah whoa that
would be a mistake did he go i think he
went back right
you went back to f4 but i was gonna say
but g5 check oh my god
wait a second wait check
oh and if you take you're just gonna
play rookie five so king g3 is forced
but then rook h8 rook h1 and all of a
sudden black gets tons of counter play
oh
my goodness everywhere rookie fought
okay fabi has to find g5 check now the
time oh and this is move 60 he's gonna
get 15 minutes
well this is exactly what we were saying
is maybe could go wrong
is that as long as fabiano was playing
then there were still chances the g5 is
child's play i mean he that move is
automatic well he's going to be his 60th
move though and he only has two and a
half minutes so he has to find it
something went wrong here it's funny
because we were just
i was just sort of accidentally saying
that i the most the best move was this
in hindsight because
yeah this was winning
but actually on rookie eight
i guess that brook takes a six line it
was only because it rotates if you did
it my way it allowed the same thing so i
was wrong on that the
oh my god has to find g5 check and the
reason that's so good is because it
forces the king onto an undesirable
square and then this idea of rook e8 to
h8 to h1
and white is like super tied up it's
still winning of course but
it has gotten exponentially more
complicated i'm not going with of course
anymore this is one of those positions
where there could be some sort of no
progress to be had from whites per
second maybe you have to be precise like
and that looks like g5 was just cheap
on the board it's move 60
oh man i thought i was going to get to
dinner in 20 minutes
and hiker plays king g3
and now fabiano gets more time right so
we see that he has minutes rather than
seconds on his clock and let's not rush
because rick h8 we see the evaluation
bar going down what if can we start with
the move rook to e5 just to force that
knight away the knight to go into c7
looks very beneficial for white because
you're just gonna win the a6 pawn but
after the rook slides to f5 now that
knight's very far away oh and you're
gonna somehow contain it maybe even with
your king at some point yes maybe my
king can help stop the b-pawn while your
rook is tied down to defending the
bishop over here
and
this is just
like getting kind of well maybe there's
some drawing mechanisms as well where i
put my bishop on e4 and give a bunch of
checks like this is really complicated
all of a sudden i just don't see fabi
fine i don't know i mean
he's resisting a hard move to find it's
but it okay like
i just still may not believe
what the allure of rookie trade is so
high right
but let's look at that again rookie five
hits the knight
the one thing that i think is like a
human way to find rookie five in rook f5
is that in addition the fact that it's a
super concrete way to go after getting
the pawn this idea of cutting the king
right from coming back is kind of an
intuitive one to see from like a block
hating perspective right we've been
talking about what are the goal
positions you can get that make it hard
for your for your for your opponent to
come back that and that's an interesting
idea
right i think that's one that a human
could could find and you know what peace
i've been hating on all game
do you know how important i apologize i
apologize to that bishop that's right
i'm apologizing but for so many
different reasons it protects e2
obviously but it stops the rook from
going to b1 so if the rook is tied down
on a1 defending the bishop on e1 when
the king walks its way over for black to
the queen side to stop the b-pawn
there's never
an option to get your rook behind your
past pawn because that's how you would
win and if we actually just like
try to make like knight to c7
rook f5
knight takes a6
rook f1
vr k1 king to e6 i believe yeah that's a
great point you would love to play rook
b1 at the same moment yes and so here
you go king d some d5 d6 whatever and
after here there's no v1 you b6 if we
just show it yep king c6 you would love
to play rook b1 it would be such a good
move but you can't do it there's this
bishop on d3 covering the square and
that means you're going to lose your
pawn over there on b6 so the king
actually stops this pawn this is
unbelievable geometry
all of it starts with rookie five fabby
made a motion
of making a move but now he's there he
goes again
he's about to move the rook we just
don't know to what square yup
you know why i think bobby can find it
do you remember yesterday he talked
about that g4 move
yeah yeah like out of nowhere yeah yeah
he is clearly
you know in great form and in this game
it for most of it it looked like he was
just getting outclassed but when he has
these you know puzzle-like motifs
i i i think it's within his wheelhouse
it's very difficult we have the engine
off the side showing us that rook hate
was incorrect that leads us to a
different position
but the idea being that the the pawn on
b4 can't just run and become a queen and
the rook on f1 ties white down
completely i'm i'm like in my head
trying to figure out how white can play
for a win there
to me the hardest move in that sequence
to find is king e6 actually
understanding that that b4 pawn it's a
protected pastor understanding that it
can just be contained by the king like
that yeah there's something about that
that seems
just so hard to visualize yep okay here
he goes
oh my he lands that e6 yes
wait he plays rookie six
not rookie five rookie six similar idea
i guess knight c7 he's gonna go rook f6
yeah so he has the same idea in mind
which is if we get basically the exact
same line could transpose actually we
could actually see a transposition
but because you don't attack the knight
that's the difference everyone you're
not forcing knight c7 so rookie 5
forced the knight to move on your way to
f5
rookie 6 does not force the knight to
move so icarl could find other moves in
this position besides knight to c7
it does protect the pawn so it might it
might make him play 97 anyway right
because because knight c7 is only way to
win the pawn now that the rook can't
take it
but
and they've never seen the eval ball
right yes they have no idea because you
may think he's just playing rookie six
just to make a move and then knight c7
is winning like if hikaru assumes that
he's winning
and for the for a large part of this
game he has objectively been in a pretty
much borderline winning position they
just plays knight c7 nonchalantly but
the point you made before danny
instead of knight to c7 maybe king f2
maybe bring your king back around
because
when this rook eventually finds his way
to the first rank the king go to e3 and
to d2 that frees that rook on that
wasn't a one in the other variation now
it's free to be more mobile the risk of
that is of course the jeep yeah
go ahead down you yeah no i didn't mean
interrupting but yeah black will play g4
at the right moment and there's a lot of
moving parts to keep track of your white
for example if you leave the rook on a1
and black stroke gets to h1
even if you park your king on d2 black
will be threatening g4 g3
and let's not forget the black actually
has two pawns for the piece so the
material advantage isn't actually as
vast as it may appear yeah
so
this is nuts
that's a human move to play though
robert if you're afraid of what happens
if you start calculating lines on knight
c7 rook f6
and you go hey i really don't like that
world where my king is cut off in
communication from my bishop
i mean i think this the
intuition is that white should just be
winning because the g pawn is not going
anywhere
you have this past b pawn with knight c7
knight 666 six that just seems like it
has to be winning yeah you as soon as
you get a pass pawn you think i i wanted
but somehow this bishop on d3 covering
b1 is so important the rook cutting off
the king on being on f1 while pinning
the bishop over there that's just like
the perfect geometry for black so
somehow the position is still
one where white should be better but
even here plus three when you're up a
piece that still gives hope for some
kind of fortress or some kind of ability
for fabiano to tie white's pieces down
and
we'll see if progress really can be made
okay so did carl about to make him we're
about to move but one thing you're
you mentioned that the players have
never seen the eval bar they don't know
and maybe they don't even know how
tricky some of these moments might be
with those potential weird booming
blockades we see for black he's about to
grab his king he likes this king f2 idea
but i was going to say that one thing
you're kind of nervous about if you're
in hikaru's camp is he has a time
advantage at some point you want him to
just like use 10 minutes to figure it
out right maybe he doesn't appreciate
some of the sensitive nature of this
moment that
there's some weird chances here for
black
if this rook comes to a
spot like h1 and this g pawn gets going
like that's what he's going to do yeah
there's no other pathways the only
avenue is through h6
and you have no time to waste literally
and figuratively but let's not forget
they do have increment now yes that's a
huge difference for fabiano because we
keep talking about as they reach the
first time patrol the second time patrol
he has mere minutes left now he can
build up some of that time on the clock
so every move that is made now that 30
seconds are added to the players clocks
it's really important for fabiano who
only has 13 minutes left
oh my gosh shaking his time are there
any other candidate moves
that might be
attracting
him with their siren song
rook d6 is the only one because it
attacks the knight
if he wants the rook to get to f6
attacking the knight is the way to do it
uh-huh but rook d6 i think the issue is
that the rook can come to 85. that work
is free to go oh
now that the king has done the job
yeah that would actually be
okay
and therefore h6 now
i think the problem is your g5 pawn is
loose and that's what i'd imagine king
can i get away with king e3 i just i
know what you're doing you know rook h1
rook f1 so i want to free my pieces and
bring my keys i just want to do it and
see what happens in this line okay
why is this so easy for white which
takes one six and then stop the jeep one
of your knights
and
oh you just come back oh and now the
pawns out yeah 93 also threatens bishop
takes g3 because bishop takes g3 was not
possible to move ago
because rook d1 was a big problem
okay but fabi is taking
a very significant amount of time on
this move but he's also i think trying
to appreciate how critical the moment is
though because he has increment
and the game has changed so to speak
he's like
uh i i need to make sure i play
accurately i've got increment coming to
me later i want to make sure i don't
blow my chances right here right now
and and i completely understand hikara's
decision making that's the thing right
it's very easy for anybody the fans for
us to be like oh how could that move be
made but what a car has just done bring
his king to f2 e3 d2 so it has a home
rather than being cut off from the rest
of the board that is like a perfectly
sensible decision just happens to be the
wrong one in this game and for fabi he
needs to tie down
white's pieces anyway and then push that
jeep on because that g-pawn is a pass
pawn pass pawns what do they want to be
pushed
the pawn gets to the other side of the
board it becomes a queen
a knight
or a bishop or rook oh my goodness and
there's so many beautiful things here so
if you play rook h6 right
you
you're gonna go rook to h1
and if you say go
i think
i'm trying to figure out how to let's go
a rook a1
okay i guess rook h1 happens
and then i go king to e3
g4 right this is the problem is that
as long as this rook gets to f1 a king
f4
right you're going to try to win this g
pawn but i can give you the g pawn
because that's a rook f1 check king
takes gp like a fortress you have no
progress for the same reason
even if you go here you're not
threatening to retire
and even if you win a6 yes it's still a
fortress as we discussed previously
because the king like king e6 which
allows knight c7 takes asic that g-pawn
is not important what's important is
that white cannot possibly get out of
this pin on the first rank
and you can't bring your knight around
to even attack the rook because the
rook's not actually on pre because once
i take back i get a new queen so this is
exactly the kind of position that you
have to look at because the eval bar is
going to say white's winning but this is
where humans in a rare way can maybe
be more effective in their approach to a
chess position than a computer because
if bobby can visualize
something like this dania right if you
can see it in his mind's eye
he might be able to hold despite the
absolute insane insanity of that
statement that that black is going to
hold this end game it's the most
beautiful piece i'm saying he goes and i
think he's about to grab his rook and
where is he going to move it to h6 oh
he's looking for this idea again the
forcing line that we could see here is
king e3
rook h1
king d2
or rookie one first
no it was uh so if the king goes up to
e3 then i think you need to start with
uh the g pawn
okay you have to push first
somehow that's wrong okay but then the
idea is that the knight will come back
that's a problem
that's a big problem so that's actually
really important
huh
wait a minute rook h1
king d2 g4
but i think we've seen this where rook
takes a6 and yeah now you have time
because
it stops why didn't we factor this in
the first time around
yeah what did we what did we calculate i
think i just threw in like a random rook
a1 just to do the geometry
but k3 is obviously a
better move
so after king e3
maybe i need to keep my rook on the
sixth rank to keep my a6 pawn defender
for now because if you're gonna go after
the a6 pawn ah so you need to wait for
knight c7 i think so yeah so
let's say you're a rook e6 check oh you
can't go king d2
or can you why not because i ripped d6
oh and bishop b1 yeah oh my
god bishop this is unbelievable you
can't go king d2 because of rook d6 oh
my lens and that forces repetition and
that's the secret
you can't move your knight bishop b1
check wins the rook if you protect what
you're doing
but there's bishop e4 and i just win
your knight your pin piece is gone
unbelievable
wow
how many ideas are manufactured by
black's
two pieces one of which
of course has been consigned to
an ignominious
all of a sudden bobby roberts
looks at another game that's we haven't
seen him do that in two and a half hours
right exactly
i wonder if he's looking just because he
feels like he's still going to lose
because sometimes you do that you
finally stretch your legs like okay this
game isn't going away or is it or we see
that bobby on a perch
where he's now feeling good about
himself and you can see by hikaru's face
and his eyes darting from you know this
one side aboard the other
he looks a lot less sure of the position
that he did before and you know we have
the evaluation bar verifying that he
should be less confident but he's i
think seeing some defensive patterns for
fabiano well i i mean i think inevitably
you see the contours of the this
counterplay is scary we're not talking
about we're talking about counter play
that if things go really wrong
i mean black spawns get pretty close to
promotion and he went king to e3 and now
rookie six checks you have to find six
oh he played constantly or no he did he
played immediately he played rookie six
it's already on the board and that's why
he got up and and took a breath because
he sees the idea
what about king d4
what if you run to c5
cable connect okay car made a move
but king d4 can i bring my we saw this
idea
we saw this already
this is the idea
right because you have bishop e4 but can
do rook takes a6 and rook d6 ah this is
different than before or i think we may
have looked at it but not extensively we
may have just
determined the black as counter play and
but who wants to get to this point no no
no nobody just looks so go back a couple
moves because okay car has not made a
move after
go back more
one more
yeah here can i go after the bishop
again
start the whole process again rookie six
oh my gosh rookie six and start
that year because the king on c5 does
not actually give away anything the king
is not going anywhere it's just stuck
on an awkward square
this just feels like such an improbable
defense he went back
he went back down he goes back to f2 and
fabio goes right back to h6 gains a
little bit taro's gonna reset here and
say like all right because what he
clearly just saw guys is he saw
he saw the idea for the first time
probably of this i think that's what he
had missed right
because this idea is kind of hard to
spot that like the knight moves and
suddenly there's a discovered check with
the bishop coming to b1 winning the rook
and without without it the game would
have been over yeah and so i think once
he saw rookie six on the board he's like
oh okay my whole idea of this plan was
to go to d2 and now i can't do that
so i'm gonna rin i'm gonna go back which
is the that's the mature thing to do and
say all right let me rethink about this
for a second but net quote unquote win
fabiano you gain an additional minute he
doesn't have that much time remaining
and and these positions for the rest of
the game are going to be critical and he
may only have one precise move a rookie
six check or you know just broke back to
e6 at some moment continue to protect
the pawn on a6 so the fact that he
gained a min on the clock that's really
good news it's not a position where car
wants to repeat to give fabinho more
time
yeah that's an amazing point and
remember everyone
increment is now
on the table they have reached move 60
so they're getting 30 seconds back with
every move that they make
which is massive if you're trying to
hold an end game i mean hikaru said that
he didn't think tamorbaja loses to him
earlier in this event if he had
increment well here
that might be the case where fabiano
holds this game because he got increment
this is this is
on something unbelievable
unreal i'm trying to wrap my head around
this position like this is where just
like the chess player in me i have to
remember that i'm commentating in front
of a lot of people because i'm just like
this is fascinating that white has a
knight
for just right here
two pawns but it looks like the a6 pawn
can fall in there they're not very good
pawns or the past pawns are yeah they're
93 but it's not normally what robert you
would say is like you know it's like
connected past pawns or something right
and back goes the knight okay okay h1
because rook f1 checked this this was
the idea that we're worried about
because if this rook lands on f1 you
can't take it right if you take it black
it's a queen and then carver sees that
he wants to go knight e3 to g2
but he once says okay i'm going to
delegate the knight to defend the bishop
and then i'm going to quickly go after
that a6 pawn but of course black still
is the g pawn but the problem is the
moment you do that after rook h1
knight g2
now
all your pieces being tied over here
that's so weird the problem for for
bobby is that this pawn is still hanging
and if that pawn is captured bingo
we got a baby girl britney coming to b8
oh can we do the g4 thing again and if
you take on a6
so i'm gonna push my g what push my g
pawn
and if you take the pawn a6
can i get away with something here like
a bishop
[Music]
i can't before is a nice idea it tries
to get the knight so you can win this oh
my god there's some mating ideas like
for example if you put your rook on f3
and then your pawn on g3 you will be
threatening me one gosh so rook h3 oh my
goodness
and you see the evaluation says
immediately it's even because the world
cap 3 check followed by g3 we can show
let's say b5 just to show the mechanism
check and g3 and black is actually
winning holy crap
that is not not a combination of words
you thought you would ever say again in
this game after like move 30. hikaru has
plenty of time to make sure
that something like that would which
would be a crime hashtag rhyme time if
akara was to lose this game but fabiano
was like i'm okay with that i'm gonna do
everything i can
to mix this thing up
and if he sees this idea
of corralling the king in that way with
the rook and the pawn
i mean this is all so bizarre
right and
this is something right pattern
recognition is such a big part of chess
this is a type of position that neither
player has seen before so it's hard to
rely on your memory or
my ipad this is freaking out that's how
amazing this is but it's hard to rely on
tactics or things that you've studied
right because you have six checks you've
never studied this position before and
rook f6 check apparently it's inaccuracy
right hard to call anything at this
point a blunder even if the evaluation
bar goes through the roof down to zero
whatever but you just have nothing to
rely on so he's going to bring his rook
to f1 and he's trying to get the king
onto the g-file but apparently that's
counterproductive because it eliminates
the possibility of that mechanism
so crazy because we're seeing these
mechanisms partly because there's a
conversation we're having bobby has no
one to talk about this game with right
so like
so
that idea almost we we almost arrived at
that idea be a process of elimination
right that's a very different process
than what's going on in a chess player's
head he does see the rook f1 idea
and what he maybe
does see is that
does he have a different type of
blockade now is he coming back to f6 and
just saying hey i've cut off your king
oh but you know what 529 yes white can
move the bishop out and then put the
knight as the blockader oh
so he's got to keep the rook on the
first rank
so rook h1
but then still bishop f2 right and then
just knight coming e1 and the problem
bishop f5 well well
the problem for white just generally
assuming for black generally speaking is
the bishop gets f2 you're running out of
checks yeah because you're never getting
to g1 and so the knight and bishop that
configuration takes control of so many
of the important squares and then the a6
pawn finally will drop so letting the
king out to g3 the whole mechanism that
allowed fabi to hold the game was by
putting that rook on h3 at the timely
moment so the king couldn't get out and
you could create that checkmating net so
this is
oh my goodness
i mean what a game
and not to add insult to injury not only
is the knight a better blockader but the
bishop as you said a better defender and
actually something that helps in the
full board for this b-pawn to get going
super fast
so that is an ideal future for hikaru
nakamura's minor pieces if he can
coordinate it
i think we saw a little
betrayal of emotion there by bobby just
very subtle i don't know if i imagined
it but
i feel like he missed some sort of a
detail here
yeah but i wonder what
he was relying on because right he
doesn't have that many moves overall
just not that many pieces remaining
bishop can't move because the e2 pawn
which is black's only hope would drop
the rook
doesn't have too many sweats to go back
to f6 but then that bishop f2 move of
course comes in probably knight t1 and
it feels like the regrouping has
finally been done by hikaru there's one
other idea rook h1 bishop f2
and then bishop f5 threaten mate on h3
by the way and then hope he doesn't see
it hope he doesn't see it playing on but
knight e1 is bad here because i still go
rook h3 and then all of a sudden your c3
pun hangs oh my gosh
never ends
okay very good
i was testing you this whole time i saw
that idea an hour ago right um of course
of course but you did you did finally
see i know actually that's fascinating
bishop h3
um
bishop f5 threatening rook h3 and you
don't want to go bishop e1 back we just
we're trying to free them now we're now
we're in draw mode rinse and repeat or
work history first which is exactly what
we want in the other one and then you
transpose that back to this idea where
you've accidentally fallen into the
mating hole my favorite type of accident
rook f6 f1 h1 h3 and three
oh of course rook f6 world cup one rook
h1 rook h3 um
it's quite obvious really it's not too
much to calculate here at all
uh okay this is actually not out of the
question though because hicaro has
achieved what he thought was going to be
the final goal position right the final
boss
get the knight on g2 get the bishop on
f2 and then finally i have my blockade
but this idea of rook h1
and then bishop f5
might be fabiano caruana's last stand
and he's on his last few minutes so
if he wants to mount this last stand
he's got to leave himself with at least
i don't know
a couple of minutes
yeah he's now under six minutes again he
does have increments so we haven't been
paying as much attention to the sudden
death that will be the clock uh sudden
death chess more exciting than sudden
death dodgeball you heard it here
um not sure i agree patches
if you can dodge a wrench you can dodge
a ball
i'll be here all week everybody i've
been struggling to die
what what
no you were as sharp as a viper there
nice
hi everybody we're having a great time
we are don't judge us
we're six and a half hours into the show
come on fabi that's a chat a featured
chat they're rooting go hikaru keep
pushing we are split down the middle
americans rooting for and against other
americans in this show we have how many
we got 49 000 of you now on twitch we're
about to hit 50 000. go tell your
friends to come in and watch and hit the
follow button
that's right
let's go
bobby is insane says slim dot bobby is
insane honestly regardless of what
happens
i thought this game was over two hours
ago
i literally had dinner plans that i will
be canceling if you're watching the show
you know who you are
and go danny go danny oh my god i love
you i love you turtle
i love you is that terrific
my favorite character in entourage did
we just
do we just have a moment
how do you guys like watch all of the
same shows and movies and stuff i i have
a skill
um just one of like displaying that i
know knowledge that i don't it's a phd
in bs i earned it years ago i actually
watched i have several of them i watched
about three episodes of entourage in my
life but adrian guder is actually very
active chess player plays on chess.com
every day shout out to you adrian he was
the like emcee at the 2016 world
championship yeah so adrian shout out
buddy but um
anyway i i've only seen a few episodes
but i i have a good memory so i remember
characters and then i just pretend like
i've seen the whole thing yeah that is
something
like three yeah so there you go we're
just robert's the same way
what no sounds like a great show here we
go rook f6 we don't know he's lost the
thread we've lost the threat bobby
doesn't see the idea of rook h1
carl must be breathing
a serious sigh of relief he's going to
play bishop f2 yeah quickly did he want
a fonta
wanna fonta don't you wanna
hey guys can we get some fonts in here
around for my visa amigos
these amigos
oh my god a cold
soda right now would be amazing but
that's not pineapple if i'm looking at
hikaru's can correctly there's bishop f2
and you could see the confidence with
which that was carried out you know what
he did invite everybody he screwed it
into the square yeah he did he never
knows he's back
i'm gonna be a bit of a jerk oh and i'm
gonna ex i'm gonna say that i'm a bit
surprised that fabby didn't keep his
rope on the first rank because i feel
like that's the juiciest defensive
approach because at least there
you create you know the
the potential for for some sort of
tactic now
oh no
he knows it's over that means you know
it's over when it core grabs his coat it
means he knows he's out of here
in t minus 10. you know why because he
never wears his coat longer for 10
minutes because he starts sweating we've
talked about it and it gets too hot for
him
so it's over 91 occurs and he's got the
position that's that's actually got to
be super freaking intimidating if you're
playing a car when he puts on the coach
yeah he knows this one is done and you
know something i was thinking about for
fabiano because he has to play on the
pawn machine tomorrow yep and on one
hand you have to kind of be like all
right i found some cool defensive ideas
right that's that's what flavion did
well
but
miss amigos
bontas pass them down yes yes but i
don't actually want a fauna i don't want
to either yeah plus and font is not
sponsoring this show so i don't drink it
if i'm not sponsored yeah but i don't
know what i will do though since we
broke the fourth wall i will crosstalk
even a lot over this you know open it
yeah i'm kidding all right open it well
you weren't kidding they're not i make
jokes about the lack of sponsorship if
you're a sponsor out there i have
but i don't actually want the fauna so
this is so good i'm sorry sour
commentary
it ruins the recycling the marines are
saying it also probably hurts people's
ears oh sorry
the first time i've ever cared about
chat
50 000 pk
50 000 people are tuning in
on twitch
cheers to you we have we are witnessing
it's so hard to say this because if
you're just getting here the action from
madrid has been hot the weather is hot
outside the action on the chessboard has
been pure fire here through the first
half of the candidates and the back half
looks like it's not going to disappoint
in any way this is the first round of
the back half we still have an entire
week of chess ahead
and the other game is still going by the
way by the way the other position
rising
is
in the world is still trying to get a w
his first win in the candidates uh the
youngest player in the event against
taymor rajaboff the oldest player in the
event but we're not talking about that
game because the battle of the americans
is where the action is
coming into this round fabiano caruana
trailed yondu pomnessy by only a half a
point but his countrymen might be able
to uh cause real problems to his hopes
if he gets this w but for hikaru that
puts him right back in the thick of it
and we're suddenly talking about a three
horse race again yeah no and
he just went rook a5 he's feeling good
about his chances he can go after the g5
pawn that g pump was supposed to help
out fabiano but now he's on the verge of
losing it the knight can come back to e1
bishop to e3 all that kind of stuff and
fabiano's running out of pieces running
out of time he's running out of hope
yeah
i mean we said that before but this time
we actually mean it because there are no
squares there's no infiltration of
course everything's defended
and he carves posture
what he's wearing all of that is an
indication put on his coat yep they say
it's the hope that kills you that's the
death sentence
oh
did i say
no i don't know what you're saying i
don't think i want to
yeah
[Laughter]
you have to believe
by a two-to-one majority thanks ted
thank you i mean you got to be a
goldfish bobby tomorrow he better be a
goldfish and forget this game if he has
any chances to take the top prize here
at the candidates because tomorrow
fabiano caruana plays yonda pomeshi who
will be the tournament leader clear
tournament leader and he's maybe going
to have to get a win so if you wondered
what you were doing on monday you
weren't going back to work
you were you were changing your plans
time to call in sick now because you're
watching the candidates
oh man
wow
what an incredible game
and chess is
it's such a rich game it's unbelievable
how one game can can produce this many
ideas like i never stopped being
surprised at that even after
20 plus years you know chess is a lot
like what my doctor said about
fettuccine alfredo that's too rich for
my blood i don't like that
i squeezed it in because he just said
rich i'm like just on fire
he's headlights
three by the way
um
you're gonna get gray hair and be a good
old nade over there i would never go to
the dark side no i don't know about that
this ted doesn't have a southern accent
have you not seen that lesson no oh my
god
like i watched seven episodes of the
lincoln lawyer on the way here i watched
the last dance
like i watched a lot of shows the answer
is you did
[Laughter]
okay no we're gonna we'll talk to don
everyone don't judge him right now he'll
see me after class yeah meet me after
okay bishop five played by the way fabi
does find the right block hating idea
with the bishop and pawn the problem is
the rook is no longer
where it was meant to be on the h file
which allows these pieces to start
coming to life
the knight now is actually
getting out of the way of the bishop
again so we can come back to d4 or is it
e5 and it puts pressure on g5 so it
keeps the bishop stuck so all those
ideas danny are available so bishop e1
the rook is too passive for black right
the whole mechanism relied on the
activity the past g pawn but now g
pawn's not going anywhere and the rook
is just tied to the defense of a6 so i
think that fabiano's running out of
plans here
and
just one of these games where i wonder
how much hope he felt though that's what
i'm really wondering because with the
swings of the eval bar we can see what's
happening everybody at home could see
what's happening but do you think that
there were a few moments there following
me on over father's like wait a second
i'm actually holding this game and then
he goes
i think it's there i think it's possible
i mean
i think hikaru you know was
finding the right ideas to make it to
make it not so clear but there was there
was a moment there where you kind of saw
fabi
getting a little bit perked up about
what he was being given you know where
it was most clear was right around that
rookie five opportunity there like
rookie five rookie six he felt like
there might be some opportunity maybe he
was visualizing the blockade that you
have with book f1
but obviously
you know no judgment that he wasn't able
to figure out that idea there but it
maybe maybe it was in hand
and when he carver repeated like king e3
and he found rookie's six check that was
another moment when i'm sure
fabi could sense that hikaru was was
getting nervous
but yeah he had to find this mechanism
of the rook on f3 and the pawn on g3
after six hours of
unbelievably intense defense i mean yeah
we gotta cut the cut the guy a little
slack
and carter put on his coat
but if bobby keeps the pesky defense up
will we ever see
a first ever which would be jakarta take
office code and realize not over yet
well he went knight d4 he's attacking
the bishop he's attacking the pawn e2
that forces the bishop back to 283 but
what does white do after that yeah
that's my problem is okay bishop comes
back to d3 and
maybe i mean if
if the bishop comes to d3 and you start
going back to the idea with the king
i think
rookie five though right ah rookie five
king f6 and then you just move your rook
somewhere where
yeah but if you move the rook anywhere
knight takes e2 is coming right just put
it on e3
i'm watching out for rook
i actually looked at it cd4 c3 bishop b1
c2 and bishop b2 rotating c3 yeah
yeah
i just i actually didn't even see rook
take c3 but i saw that my bishop could
stop the pawn
so king f6 rookie three okay let's look
at it for gfc five or something rookie
three forget it just so everyone knows
the international master in the room
didn't blunder even though this is
easier i saw this this was my win
okay
but
with fobby playing
king of six is it
oh oh wait a second he took it out
he took it off i think he just got warm
i ched i said it he puts it on when he
thinks the game is less than 10 minutes
because otherwise he starts to get too
hot in the room you did say that i did
what happened
you were correct
clip it ship it
clip and ship it everybody
all right but seriously you can put the
rook on e3 or e8 i think if we're
worried about what takes d4 tactics and
how easy is rookie 3a5 be a
rook a6 and knight take c2 rook takes a5
oh my gosh that is like never ending i
mean you still have to win that you know
because the pawn is on a light square
was not about to move the rope too he
was about to play knight f3
you might even see a knight in bishop
checkmate to culminate all of this
i think fabiano would resign but he did
go knight f3
by the way if if icaru goes on to win
this game and we do have him in studio i
will be
teasing him about the coat donut do not
worry chad
i think this is actually an excellent
move
because it invites rookie six icaru will
take take g5 and then
easily surround the e2 pawn and all he
needs is one pawn the c3 pawn yep to win
the game and that's the pawn he needs
unless somehow the b-pawn becomes an
eight that's what i said yeah no but i'm
saying yeah i just want to say unless
somehow the b-pawn becomes an a-pawn
there are outside drawings oh it's i
still have the c3 pawn always which oh
code coming back on so now it goes back
into confidence i don't speak
good anymore
[Music]
one from steph curry
oh yeah
drop the three
drop the shimmy
bobby is dropping low on the clock right
now he's about to be under a minute
um
which we've been talking about the
problems on the board
that is a big problem off the board he
looks like he's going to resign yeah he
looks like he's
finally out and as we see it omgs are
snaps
we do indeed wow have a victory
for hikaru nakamura in round eight of
the 2021 feed a candidates
hey caro
and i
i can't quite read his lipstick there
but
i can't read them either i'm wondering
what part of the game they're focusing
on it's it's much earlier
i can't believe they have the stamina to
analyze at the board after that
unbelievable struggle
all right let's go let's go rest they
said yeah what a game though by hikar
and nakamura yeah seriously he might
have had to win it like 40 different
times but that's because fabiano carwana
gave him everything he could handle but
when all is said and done hikar used
those initially two minor pieces versus
the rook that dynamic he just seemed to
understand it extremely well he scores a
very important victory and for the first
time he has risen above 50 percent and
that's nothing to sneeze at because this
tournament is ridiculously tough and for
the first time in seven years hikaru
nakamura defeats his american rival
carwan in classical chess and no better
time to do it donya than the first round
of the back half of the candidates well
so remember at the start i i invoked
that alekhine quote that you got to beat
him in the opening middle game and end
game in this game hicaro had to
basically win three games just in the
end game yeah i mean this was something
else
and
it's going to take some time for me to
process all of what i just saw
well we we we have one person now a full
point in the lead that being yonder
pomnishi who drew his game much earlier
today we have two players neck and neck
right now wow um in second and third
those being the two americans and as you
look at hikaru's upcoming matches
knowing that he still gets three whites
he has four out of seven
whites in the back half
this is not over no and actually he has
some spots where he can really punch
because report we talk about every round
not the best opening theoretician hikaru
nakamura comes with extensive
preparation very thorough and he comes
with ideas that are honestly difficult
to meet so that round 11 game in
particular also around 13 duda just lost
his second game he hasn't won a single
one hikaru gets the white pieces against
him and let's not count out tomorrow's
game look at that record three wins zero
losses so hikaru has a pretty nice back
half of the tournament considering his
history with these players everyone is
tough there's no walk-overs here but
still when you look at the list of
pairings hikaru now all of a sudden he's
like i'm right back in this
indeed he is we still have a game to get
back into here in round eight which is
which is a little strange but we are
also going to be joined by hikaru
nakamura in studio you obviously do not
want to miss that interview
don't go anywhere believe it or not
there is still more ahead here in round
eight of the 2022 feed a candidates
tournament in madrid
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more
try it for yourself at chess.com events
i was told by the locals of a chess
school and there's people out there we
should go we should go while they're
opening the door for us let's go let's
go school of chess don't cost nothing
dodging traffic
a game as old as chess itself
and half as dangerous
this is the most dangerous part of our
career
game on gotta give the people what they
want game on keep going don't stop
so we tell them that chess education
gives you better life decisions as we
get hit by a car crossing the road in a
non-crosswalk
at 5 20.
5 20 what time we got
start
dude
stay and crash of all the places we
could film in spain the fact there's
going to be a class and we're here
we can film other stuff but we got to
stay for that yeah i agree people say
crashing weddings is fun we're crushing
a school
if the chest is not taking place
check it out
flamenco dancing huh you think of what
i'm thinking you want to be my partner
are there partners in flamenco we're not
even graffitiing a building we're like
trying to help local kids and yet
somehow i see this going poorly
this would be like you know
being at the public courts and like
federer comes
we are walking quickly i heard the word
siguri died and i was like no security
dodge mike levy not yeah
the police not
but we got to go
you know they obviously kind of knew
that we were
you know we kind of knew we were a big
deal they opened up their arms and so
this is why when we were kids our dad
told us to say open sesame yeah which
gets you into the building but if you
say open address you do not get into you
don't get in the village no no it's open
sesame you got to remember that dad was
right i play a lot of it yeah i love it
you could have gotten us into the
building you play on chess.com yes of
course do you know who that is
no
you don't need to no you just need to
use the app he's the face of chess.com
do you have a diamond membership no
that's like the paid membership yeah no
i'll give it to you
seriously yeah for now you get a pekka
there you go
so just
next time you're on the site just send a
message to support and say i met danny
in spain
say i met danny and danny said he would
i could get a diamond membership okay
all right i love your work
i love your work thank you bye-bye so
it's funny danny we were sold a bill of
goods they flew us here to do real work
yeah and i realized our entire job is
just to go around getting out of the
stickers honestly let's oh well there
you go i can't even do that well
[Music]
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing the chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kit is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos to the world champion of
chess must come through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
the candidates is all about leaving a
legacy what you guys can't see guys and
gals whoever you are watching the show
is that robert hess likes to say the
last few words of that video under his
breath every single time and i still
don't know it's because if he's a secret
fan of the script or just making fun of
me
you want to come clean buddy it's your
chance there's still 38 000 people here
that's right well before i answer what
do you think it is i know what it is
i'm supporting you making fun of me no i
listen to your voiceover work yeah yes
so i'm supporting you oh okay and you're
calling me out in front of everybody
johnny's also had some great voiceover
work i hope everyone's enjoying uh the
show that we're we're putting on here in
madrid uh the team
worked super hard and we're gonna
continue to to bring you all the action
as these players do the real work on the
board and we appreciate the show that
they put on daily can i just say
something really quickly please these
two players are in last place and they
are fighting and they're fighting so the
fact that they haven't just called it a
day may repeat a move made or maybe that
will happen
but there are 66 moves into this contest
they're at the bottom of the standings
and they're fighting every single turn
for an advantage for somebody to come up
with an idea and make a mistake so you
have to give credit to both
frugia and vajava version we know he
comes in with a reputation as a fighter
he's very young for a job of somebody
who hasn't won a class game in a long
time but he's clearly here to fight
to the very end
it's true and that's what we want right
i mean obviously there's a lot of talk
at times when top level chess doesn't
deliver the decisive results that people
want
but
it shouldn't be a discredit to the fact
that chess when played perfectly often
is a draw but these players fight tooth
and nail no matter what and they are
putting in so much effort to entertain
the fans we have not put in a lot of
effort to cover their game with all do
we were doing the best we could we're
going to dive into it now stick with us
we'll see if some instructive stuff can
be taken away from perugia and rajab's
interesting piece dynamic and of course
at some points we will be backing up and
looking at all the things that were this
wild wild round day from madrid
janja why don't you help set the table
for us because
i might black out here for a little bit
and stop paying attention i am a little
tired what's going on in this game i'll
draw some arrows
give a you know wider summary from the
start so this was an italian and you can
identify the structure uh which
solidified from a very early period in
the game so much so that wine actually
took the bishop on e6 before either side
had castled
so we had this structure
uh in which black attacks down the
f-file while you're doing this i'm
actually going to go back and show that
trade because why not it happened yeah
long ago and by the way we didn't say
this in real time because we were on the
other game
this was the novelty in the game which
is weird to say clearly in a position
been played before but go ahead
so
ultimately both sides castled and they
transposed back into more conventional
waters and rajava
orchestrated the sort of classic king
side play
uh ali raza putting a rook on a2 as is
traditional on this line defending f2 so
they had this long period of maneuvering
they traded dark squared bishops
and both sides kind of posturing for a
position who can
kick the other side's knight so they go
on and on and
on and of course
tons of
depth and subtlety in every move yep
so they go on and on and b5 but by the
way this was yeah let's pause here yeah
i actually had a heads up thanks to dina
okay dina bilankash you mentioned this
knight f4 check knight h5 to f4 now
after pawn takes f4 e takes f4 it's an
idea we had discussed in many different
types of positions but we hadn't
actually gone back to this point where
the h4 pawn likely will fall and that
means that there's an attack going and
rook h3 does actually defend it but then
h5 traps the knight on g4 so it's a very
awesome tactic and that would have given
the java some good chances
it's interesting he didn't have
his wits about him at that exact moment
but turns out earlier in this game
there was a moment
he didn't own it that's really fast
spaghetti
but some of the hardest tommy cheddar
bob
any more references that i want to
understand you can keep going because
your boots are growing roots better
hurry up
so
having missed knight f4
uh rajab instead decided to create
attention on the queen side
now
that would serve
as a very important moment later on in
the game when the a file opened and
created yet another theater of tension
so you can see the maneuvering you know
we could talk about this for hours but
ultimately alireza pushes d4 very
committal move oops sorry about that all
right that was just a mouse slip of the
of
the mouse and at this point they're an
acute time pressure this is like move 35
so both of them have a minute so they
blitz out the next couple of mover
jawbooks between a8 and f8 and purusha
does the same
and we thought they might repeat moves
but ali reza
going for broke with knight takes
stepsix barely making move 40 and
kicking black's queen out of c4 but this
pawn structure is really fascinating
look at how well defended black center
is robert you pointed out the e5 pawn
the possibility of f6 f5 and if anything
i almost thought that black's position
from a practical standpoint is for
choice
yeah but ali raza managed to stabilize
the position and i think the position
was equal for
the longest of times
but just now it looks like reza may have
been may have made some progress
but they trade another pair of rocks
and on and on they go or a job of
inducing a weakening move f3 right it
seems like ferrus is completely tied
down but he finds a way eventually to
activate that knight on f1 and i think
that was something where jabot may have
fallen asleep on
well that night went everywhere
absolutely everywhere
crazy i don't even remember which knight
that is like do that's that night start
on b1 or g1 it doesn't matter anymore
we've lost track
back to d2 and then back to f1 and back
to d2 again my goodness
so
this is where java fell asleep the move
queen e8
i really really dislike after after uh
queen d8
he's allowing that knight potentially to
get to g4 and if it gets the g4
you plug the hole along the g file you
press your h6 and you start creating a
little bit of uncomfortable pressure and
that's this is when you're very happy
that black has those double pawns
because with the knight on g4 you'd like
to kick it with a move like f5 but you
don't have an f pawn yeah and so that's
actually very annoying queen to e2 at
some moment might spy on the b5 pawn as
well so java brings knight back to he
spent a ton of time yeah no he's just
realized that knight g4 was such a nasty
threat and white can expand at some
point g3 to g4 is not out of the
question and then maybe even up to g5 so
it's like slow progress but it feels
like black is kind of just stuck and
waiting around to see what white does
whereas for ruja he has a number of
different plans and potential targets
slow progress but it is progress right
now for the youngest player in the event
if ferrous was to get his first win that
would be huge obviously for his
confidence for
his
family his feelings his fans a lot of
f's in there that would be it'll be good
for perugia to get to get uh
his future another one back on track but
okay
uh real quick hikaru nakamura exhausted
from his game actually will not be
joining us in studio we we've just
gotten word of that so disappointing
news and apologies to the fans it was
uh a plan and we thought a foregone
conclusion but turns out no uh he did
catch up with dina bellancaya so we will
have that interview at some point
um
so forgive us for that we will focus on
this game uh but uh
we do have all we do have another
interview to play as farouja
thinks about how to tackle these moments
before we get into the final time
scramble of the day why why can't i say
that with certainly because it's the
only game left so this will be the final
time scramble of the day ensuing here
with seven minutes for perugia and under
six now for java but dina bell and kaya
caught up with the other winner on the
day not named takara nakamura his name
is richard report and here's what he had
to say about his stylish jacket and his
play on the board
what made you
choose this opening today
i don't know i just chose it in the
moment i didn't really look at chess
after yesterday's game
i didn't even open just base actually
so i figured um
yeah i saw that he played e4 e5 knight
f3 okay nice f6 f6
so i figured um
it will be hard to lose in 15 moves if i
protect the pawn
kinetics g5 was quite ambitious because
he could just trade queens and is
totally fine
but also afterwards he wanted this
rookie 6 so i kind of i had this minor
trick with rook given to prevent rookie
six
and then i think things just started to
go really badly for him i think after um
rook ae7 where probably rook f1 was
stronger or i don't know but also looks
very strong but queen f3 as well i think
is pretty pretty decent and yeah
suddenly uh his king was stuck which was
very strange because the whole point was
that his king is running out with f8 to
e7 and then he played okay
e7 to to block this route of course he
wanted rookie six rogue g6 but i
prevented that and
yeah i think the position suddenly
became very very dangerous maybe even
more than that
having seen this both games yesterday
and today uh would you prefer still it
to be to draw so you like the way it
went afterwards
i don't think it's so fair towards fabi
that i i lost um i like this toyan
so i would have preferred to um
to have to draw let's say but of course
today's game
was total
desperation or some some some sort from
my side
of trying to get a game without opening
theory
um being a factor
so
i guess you can do this any day on this
level but usually it's not supposed to
pay off so i love your jacket what made
you worry today
i would like to say something you know
overconfident but actually it was my
wife she insisted on me wearing it
yesterday which
proved to be very smart that i avoided
that because it wouldn't have been fair
towards the jacket
so yeah i chose to do it today
our audience was wondering is this red
pink or salmon color
i believe it's pink but i guess it's up
for debate
any uh particular strategy for the next
games
nothing
i will i will think about my outfit
to confuse
that's the winning move thank you
richard
thanks
is he not
just i want to unpack every single thing
he said what a great interview he's
incredibly likable and you know it might
be good for him to have no plan because
he came in today with just
no opening preparation just to get a
game it worked out well for me he
actually played quite nicely but the
part i think we want to discuss is where
he apologizes to fabiano where he
essentially says you know yesterday's
game my loss to yadapamishi when i could
have just made a draw he's like that's
not fair he's the word fair it's a
fabiano and
it's a bit loaded of a term and
obviously he just wanted to play his
game but it did change the tournament a
lot
whoa sorry i think kelly reza might have
just blunted a pawn
okay but we're going to give it a second
but i was also going to say how crazy it
is that
richard didn't do any preparation and am
i allowed to say badass i'm just going
to say anyway i said badass yesterday
actually okay great
badass it is that he just comes decides
what to play on the spot on the pet drop
juice is an offbeat line and just
checkmate's the guy no but seriously
like that's maybe what he should have
done against yon and again in hindsight
obviously 2020 i want to unpack what he
said too we know that report and fabiano
are pretty good friends for those who
don't know so uh his i think he felt
just genuinely bad about his own
performance and that it wasn't fair to
the race going on between caruana and
upon rishi but like you said fair's a
loaded term chess is an individual game
and you have to make the decisions for
yourself but
he also confirmed by the way the jacket
is pink that may have been the biggest
takeaway from that interview let's make
sure that that has been stated for the
record but all right you're right that
was a huge move this move king h3 rajab
oh
so knight takes e4 i think ali raza
intends knight g4 but if i'm calculating
correctly there's knight takes c3 in
that position
oh my goodness it's actually a crazy
line so let's look at it if you can
bring up analysis board that knight
takes e4 right taking advantage of the
fact that pawn on f3 is pinned and after
knight i'm just going to show real quick
for sure the queen is lost and so knight
g4 the point is that
sorry knight g4 g4 is also possible but
if you go knight to g4 you're trying to
say your knight's under attack and it
looks like
if you move tonight i fork you right but
knight takes c3 is available and queen
c2 check looks like it just picks up the
knight but you have queen f5 blocking
the check saving your queen from the
fork and in fact pinning this knife but
this has been tomorrow's problem all
along he just doesn't trust his
calculation at all
and and he doesn't end up taking risks
in these situations
and i think
he gave alireza a pass there with king
h8
wow yeah and he you know after knight
takes e4 there is the move g4 and we see
the evaluation bar off to the side of
the screen here it says it's still level
i have to move g4 but you have to take
those chances right and that's your
point and instead he was king
back to h8 in the game he's avoiding all
sorts of pins and checks and forks but
that move might just be a little slow
because white can push the pawn to g4
it's an idea we mentioned earlier and it
just feels like now white has all the
momentum the white absolutely has all
momentum g4
you can't quite yet but you're not far
from being able to play g5
you've got to figure out how to how to
get your king in a different spot first
but
there's g5 there's h5 knight g2 knight
h4 give me that g6 square and now yeah
that rook on g1 is not needed there
anymore slide that one over to the a
file we were talking about black
controlled the a file a long time ago
but that's been hours at this point
there we go so is the b5 pawn hanging
i oh or did he go knight g4
wow
knight g4 i thought about this briefly
the point is that after you trade yeah
white's pawn structure looks ruined but
you get the f-file you might even get
the a file and the b5 pawn is very
serious weakness and white has this big
pawn majority on the king's side so a
lot of rook end games are actually good
for white yeah because of g like g5 and
h5 yeah that's actually super deep and
the main point here is the g4 punt does
look loose but when you your rook ends
up going after the queen side pawns
black will need to use either the queen
or the rook to defend those pawns
because the queen 92 keeps everything
defended for white and that will
distract black's pieces from the g4 pawn
which will free up white's queen that's
a really really nice move knight to g4
i also really like the instructive just
quick hit from danya this idea of
playing g5 in brook endings where after
black takes it you don't take back you
advance h5 and then come into g4 with
the king that's a bit abstract for the
slightly more advanced chess playing
viewers i'm not going to break it down
further but that is a really important
uh
pawn sacrifice maneuver that should be
aware of in rook endings
taymor does not
or he wants to trade on his own terms
that's a nice move
you have to give rajal credit but you're
right on one hand that he's maybe not
playing ambitiously but he also
understands that changing the structure
is maybe not beneficial for him so he's
keeping the status quo and that's a hard
move to make right instead of just
taking and doubling your opponent's
pawns he says you take me if we're going
to trade it's going to be on f6 right
and this is actually better for black
than helping white with the structure
because these pawns kind of remain
under the gaze of black's major pieces
and
leads to some lack of clarity you'd like
to almost have your king over here
defending them but if you try to come
back this way black actually can maybe
sneak sneak upon because the pawn is
pinned so
rajab is very good defensively he's very
good at keeping the waters murky and and
making his opponent's life difficult
he's
proven to be not so great in some of the
opera some of the aggressive
opportunities he's had in this event and
really frankly over the last few years
so
um
he's still holding on but i i'm with you
robert that i i think ferrous is
probably the only person who could win
this game and look at the clocks by the
way they're both at around four minutes
they are gaining 30 seconds per move the
increment is playing a huge role towards
the end of this game here but look at
those queen side pawns you can't go and
steal b5 because then black snags the f3
pawn and that puts the white king in
danger so
the b5 pawn at some point will be a
target and as
danny was just pointing out that you
unfortunately can't bring your king back
to defend uh before going after the b5
pawn because of that pin on the g file
so you just i think use your rook first
and then eventually bring your king back
around to f2 yeah i liked your idea
before but now with the knights gone
i'm worried about g3 again this queen
can continue to poke at the g file that
means that i'd have to play g4 and maybe
i mean
it's just
adding the time pressure
to the
trickiness of the moment
yeah i mean g4 is very risky it weakens
f3
and if you're not careful with white i
mean you could allow some sort of
infiltration you know g4 might allow
queen f4 you pointed out h5
so you can't be too cavalier about yeah
what you do on the king side your king
isn't that safe but alireza here he goes
those are the switches i also there's is
ever an idea for black to play h5 first
and then here that come with certainly
it's too committed that's certainly an
idea but you have to watch out when you
put the pawn h5 because maybe there's
like a timely f4 or something that you
have to look out for but
i think h5 is available because the
queen always slides to g6 to defend it
so
maybe not an unreasonable move from
rajabo's perspective
so what is the threat exactly
i haven't figured that out yet
okay
queen g6 rajab says i also don't see a
threat so either bring your rook back to
g1 i see black stripes
you see black's threat i believe i do
chat do you see black threat this is
your opportunity
i think that what right now what ferg
needs to do is he should play g4
and we were talking the f4 square being
vulnerable but white can slide the queen
up to e3 any queen trade is going to be
a problem for black because whose rook
is better this rook on a1 so i don't
think black can afford a queen trade
anytime soon so you play g4 you play
queen e3 maybe slide your king over to
g3 and you actually keep everything well
defended here and that's going to be
very annoying because i think that
black's best bet is to shuffle but at
some point this rook will start trying
to pick off pawns
that's a great point i like it
yeah and the problem is the black pieces
are also going to be tied down
to tying down white's pieces like
you move your queen away from f6 then
widescreen gets active so it's like a
mutual standoff and
white screen can handle it together
balancing
advice this is moving in
direction agreed we could see the first
victory for the youngest player in the
candidates
here in madrid
what a tough position to play with just
three minutes on your clock because for
example for black the h5 move that you
mentioned i think it's actually a
mistake here because you just play g5
and now white has a protected pass pawn
so
a lot of trades will just be good for
white because now
you're gonna always have to look out for
the pawn you're distracted by it and
white can focus on the other side of the
board so maybe it's viable but it's
something you really need to consider
before playing and when you have three
minutes left you don't have the time to
calculate
yeah h5 you'd love to play it
for the idea that you'll get a mating
attack but if you don't get said mating
attack you just gave your opponent a
winning advantage in any type of end
game that might be around the corner so
um g4 puts a ton of pressure on her java
if he's about to go lower than three
minutes for the first time here in the
last time control they will not get any
more time on the clock there's no more
benchmarks to reach as far as getting an
additional hour or even 15 minutes but
they do get 30 seconds with every move
this position suddenly looks terrible
yeah it's one of those funny moments
where like
as less pieces were on the board
ferocious winning chances have increased
steadily right with the knights with the
pair of rooks every piece that's coming
off
whoever controls this file and whoever
controls the pawn breaks robert has says
this a lot is usually in control over
the game right and white controls the
pawn breaks on the king side because h5
g5
black can't really i mean this is the
only thing that i come to then is like
how do i make a mess of this if i'm
losing but d5 is never going to work
because it just
favors white right here and it also
opens up the b1 h7 diagonal so if you
ever get a situation of the black king
on h7 due to rook a check and white
could park the queen like on d3 so
you know so it's not just as you said
impractical to open up the center okay
so java mrs queen back
adopting a fully defensive posture which
is probably what he has to do and
i mean two moves come to mind i
mentioned queen e3 is my first idea but
rook f1 defending the only weak point in
the position that threatens queen takes
b5 right the queen can't take that pawn
that's been hanging there for a while
because of all the threats that black
has created on the king side so rook f1
does open up that threat of queen takes
b5
rook f1 would defend the f pawn maybe
force for javoff to come to the diagonal
but that's my problem with rook f1 is
what's the follow-up right
i want my rook to be at its best over
here i might play f4 at some point not
out of the question that i just started
i think he's gonna go queen e3 yeah so
it's likely when you say it for you add
stress to my life
you okay i'm better now because you
stopped talking about playing up four
and opening up your own king
um
also better now that york meyer is in
chat shout out to
york meyer hanging out with us
how'd you know that i just got a message
here oh i was like i got people in my
ear
yeah i'm doing my best to put on the
show
olly reza is taking a while on this move
yeah also now under the clock looks like
queen e3 yeah king age seven quickly by
roger to defend h6 and now the question
where to go
with the rook anyone do you go rook a5
try to induce c6
do you go
to a7 and pan for gold
yes to both a5 is where he stops
inducing c6 gives new weaknesses right
that's the whole idea you get those
pawns every it's like this you just say
come on
every time
a pawn pushes forward it can never go
back which allows a major piece with
evil intentions to attack from the side
to attack from behind
and because this king is not as safe as
it looks everyone the king is safe as
long as the queen and rook are here but
if they get distracted and that seventh
rank opens up you're also just poking
and prodding for the potential to
massage a victory home here
and i could see a zoo song happening
where like black just runs out of moves
so queen d7 played you can play queen d3
just to go after the pawn on b5
i would also think i'll bring my king
back into the game king g3 at some
moment just to
you know
stay protecting the f3 pawn with a piece
that's not the queen he starts with
queen d3 so he really really wants to
provoke c6
it's a true time pressure affair here
with the 30 seconds they're getting but
predicted these players won't won't ever
get back above five minutes again we're
gonna be under five minutes for the rest
of the game and i'm not sure i've made a
move or no not yet but i was saying rook
f7 which looks like it's a way to
protect b5 tactically you might still be
able to take on b5 i understand black's
going to take on f3 we can have seven in
the end that's actually a really good
point and then you staircase staircase
toward the c7 pawn you can exactly
staircase towards the c7 point you can
also play g5 that's my first instinct
just push my pawn you've double pawn
comes to the mating now
and i'm just gonna yeah go after your
king love it love it yeah actually it's
funny rook f7
is a move that you would play like in a
blitz game right after queen d3 you see
rook f7 and you play it because often it
just feels like you can never take a
pawn that allows me to get a check
but actually that would go very wrong
even rook f7 king g2 actually is an
undesirable outcome for black because
that will force c6
yep
very true a drop of under two minutes
now and he really doesn't want to play
c6 and that move
nobody plays c6 you just know
you know
you know the f4 move that you didn't
like before don't talk to me i'm still
oh look at that i'm going to show it i
was actually just looking at it because
after this you have an e5 discovered
check and then
the game is then oh and i think you just
succumbed actually you can play anything
rookie 8 now is also winning in addition
to this and he did succumb to playing c6
which means if you're ferocious you have
weaknesses and look at this master class
[Music]
comes back to the deep guy everyone stop
what you're doing i know it's been a
long day we've had some amazing chess
but you might be witnessing a master
class here for molly reza perugia this
whole concept inducing the weakness
quickly
comes back heading over to the new pawn
that was not a target before and is now
and the virtuoso placement of the queen
on d3 to create the pin stopping d5 and
defend f3 and the queen has easy access
to other important squares such as e3 so
if java moves his king back you could
consider the move queen e3 for example
yeah to hit h6
look at that move trying to say the
queen can't take d6 yet because f3 falls
with check he is right about that
but that d6 pawn is going nowhere grab a
snickers remember those commercials when
you were hungry and if you didn't get
fed you acted like a diva well i've been
home you're not you're hungry i've been
very hungry
for several hours
well
right now queen went back to f7 so d6
not
able to be captured queen e3 keeps that
queen f4 i could see he's hopping around
his rook though
what does he want yeah where does he
want to put that rook
he also only has three minutes and a
half for her job off i think he wants to
go back to a6 just to
just to mess with him a little bit
bother
the c6 spawn a little
it's a really big moment for alersa
because this type of position there is
an advantage for white but you typically
have to just like be very accurate
because if you make one inaccuracy all
of a sudden black is equalized on the
spot yeah it could be because white's
king is on h3 i know danny you've been
saying leave that king alone don't open
it up anymore but black at some point
might try to strike against that king
yeah definitely if you move your queen
to the wrong spot if you allow h5 in the
wrong set of circumstances
okay so he goes queen e3 i really like
that movie solid solid chess not trying
to play hero ball just defend all the
squares first
defend f4 so there will not be any
creepage if you will of this idea of
prying open the white king what do you
think of white going h5 is it worth it
i've been thinking about it to freeze
that pawn where it stands and eliminate
the counter play sign me up all day
that's that's less stress yes it also
allows the white king at some point to
just run away like if the queen ever
goes the queen's gonna have to move at
some point from f7 especially you put
pressure on d6 or if a rook comes to d1
and a pawn's in h5 you go queen e7 and
now my king could finally run away
without hanging one of my yeah like that
definitely gives you the freedom to do
that or drop of under a minute the the
problem with this is like if you misstep
somewhere else and you you took away
your own ability to change the structure
later on maybe create a pass pawn with
some of the tricks we were talking about
like a rook ending where you sack a g
pawn push h5 put the king on g4 and you
could be winning even down upon as white
depending on whether you still have the
a file or other thing so h5 is a is a
move but it's a committal move too right
30 seconds
okay 30 seconds for java
wait
now he's back to 30 no he's back to a
minute yeah so okay
yeah it looks like the clock
transmission how about correct how about
king g3 here
why don't we start our king walk now
right we want to at some point get the
king away so king g3 is just step one we
can play h5 later and then go king f2
and king e2 and all that stuff if we
want well the
he likes it i was gonna say the idea at
some point is worth a try because
that that puts a seat of doubt in your
opponent's mind when they have no time
now we know what roger's thinking with
the minute he's like wait a second do i
really need to be worried about this
complicated king walk that's a very hard
move to face in time pressure no
impossible to face the never he moves
his rook to the side c7
i guess we gotta jinx each other
counter play
did somebody order counter pipe best
defense is a good offense that's
actually a really good move as long as
it comes with a paella
and some sangria huh
right now
oh that's actually a huge move i don't
think c5 i wouldn't recommend it too
soon but there are plenty of positions
for sure where you play c5 to get the
activity but i feel like c5 makes your
d61 even more vulnerable so there is
that drawback yeah the moment you play
that white's rook d1
i mean taking you do get the c file but
the d6 pawn immediately under fire there
there's there's also rook a6 yeah you
can attack from various angles by the
way don't play rook a7 here oh
are you kidding me l-o-l-l-o-l
good job of casting a little glance up
now he's provoking d5 and normally i'd
be against playing d5 but in this
specific position i feel like rojava
should seriously consider it but you
know what ferrous wants under d5 he
might look at rook to e1 just keeping
the tension and threatening in many
positions e takes d5 because the e5 pawn
is loose but i could play rock f7
you would make that kind of move okay
the rook slides over to d7 to defend the
d6 pawn but this has been her job of all
game right we keep talking about it he
doesn't want the change he doesn't want
to change anything he's not going to
unless he absolutely has to it makes
sense purusha as masterfully as he's
played he's provoked all these
weaknesses but
jabba is holding on for now if arusha
wins this game though he's just gonna be
feeling so good about his form sometimes
we always say like when you when you're
in a slump
hitting the wall it's games like this
where you literally just beat your head
against the wall and finally broke
through that can get you back on track
and you know who else is watching this
game eagerly even though he's tired
ikaro
because if jabba loses he's gonna be
pretty devastated going to tomorrow's
game yeah i mean 100 move game
you know and then you got to face
so you recently searched rooting for
right yeah totally although
if farouza wins it might put rajava in
the mindset let me just make a draw oh
because java is white he has a little
more control over that and if java would
say won this game now he might be
ambitious right he might say oh i've got
a first taste of victory now i'll get
the white piece against a car or i can
you know fight against him my old
nemesis
but based on how java is played i'm i'm
not sure he's actually lining up d5 or
anything like
that i think
can use that to his advantage i don't
know how but he can use the fact that
java continues to show restraint even
maybe in a moment where he should press
forward so i
at this point
it's like sort of like a logic yes and
that's what he did he's like played d5 i
dare you yeah daring him to play d5
through wanting to chances he's saying
give give them to me baby play d5 give
me a chance
and you know what roger's gonna do
you're gonna say like no no no no no
soup for you no soup for you can you
simon is a i guarantee you for java
plays king g7 or a queen move that
subtly
sits tight
well i think he likes the screen
placement on f6 oh
call the press
unbelievable the move and you know why
partially i think you did it look at
ferrous clock you just burned two
minutes during your job of playing you
fight like you know what in your face
yeah no i mean rook e2 was the movie i
wanted to play with the rook on c7 but
with the rook on d7 i'm a little bit
nervous about black playing d4 right
here
past pawns must be pushed uh-oh in fact
if this queen leaves the f4 square we're
immediately back in business as far as
aggressive ways to attack the wait wait
wait wait wait wait but if rook e2 d4
i might be able to take and after pawn
takes e5
takes takes shake and bake mom helped
queen
before check
oh desperado queen takes h4 that is oh i
didn't see that
that's really and we have a drawn rook
ending drawn game
wow okay wait
so rookie two mm-hmm
well ferrous is down to 30 seconds okay
we've got 30 seconds for purusha
increment or not
that's nothing in this position it's
absolutely nothing it evaporates in a
millisecond he looks at his clock glazes
at the clock down to 20. how does this
move 81. it looks like it should be
moved like 40. i know i was thinking
that same exact thing
he's got to win panicking
he's playing for a win and i think
timor's gonna play two he's gonna allow
d4
i'm not sure that that's advised at this
point but
did fruition make them with eight
seconds remaining
he has 38 seconds eight seconds
making that move he has 38 seconds i
think verusa would rather lose than draw
this game at this point i agree
literally he is going to go all in
so rookie 7 is the other option that's
the more defensive posture
that makes a lot of sense it's hard
though to play d5 soften up the e5 score
and then just kind of shuffle because
like well why did i weaken my heavens
today yeah exactly
but for the move
for the move uh d4 here
after pawn takes pawn takes i mean this
those black pawns c6 becomes a target
the pawns are not connected right of d4
so maybe c takes d4 e takes d4 and a
queen f4 offering a queen trade trying
to get the king in the mix that king
wants to dart right up to e5 and help
out in the end game 19 seconds less than
20 seconds now for java who also sits up
in his chair and peeks over at the time
control peaks at the clock 10 seconds
you got to move
oh my gosh you got to move you lost side
the clock five seconds move four seconds
move three
he had two seconds when he moved he now
has 32 seconds oh
oh my gosh
wow it was very broken
for this he doesn't play our key 7 or d4
so he aims for that f3 pawn okay right
he is protecting e5 because white has a
bigger pawn to keep defending that's a
that's a that's a big move there
h5 or something neutral by purusa would
toss the ball back into her job ups
court 15 seconds
and frugia he brings his king back to g2
so he gives up the age for 10 seconds
with 10 seconds on the clock but he
wants d4 version definitely wants that
move to happen because he's just trying
to get some sort of imbalance but don't
forget h4 is also now hanging i don't
know how that impacts the position yeah
wait
can you take it i mean then ed in the
position opens up and black's king is
the yeah okay one that's going to get
punished
does not want if queen takes h4 you take
e5 and then you take d5 and win e5 so
java puts the king on g8 and does so
with seven seconds on his clock neither
player gains enough by breaking the
tension right now everyone if white
takes d5 and tries to take e5 you lose
with queen takes f3 but if black plays
d4 to try to get a pass pawn takes takes
you ultimately give white more chances
as this structure in majority gets going
so the reason we're seeing the deadlock
is because neither player can improve
their position by breaking in the center
an h5 play to make sure that pawn h4
doesn't fall so you know what's black's
move here probably just keep moving the
king around but you could put in the
wrong sword king g7 for example would
immediately be
and e5
yeah
yeah if king g7 show it real quick if
king g7 takes takes and takes e5 you
can't win anymore because you're pinned
to g7
so king h7 very important puts the king
on the correct square h7
oh no he hasn't moved yet time
he is he's going to wait he goes
okay
with once with two seconds
wow now it's alirez's turn can he find a
way to improve rookie two let's not
sleep on that idea that still exists at
some point in this game guys a move is
going to be made
like the email bar is going to go nuts
because they're look how well they are
maintaining the balance when computers
are so good at humiliating human beings
at chess these days when a blunder
happens these guys have not made a move
that has given an inch at all it's it's
honestly just fascinating how well
they're playing here queen d3
g7 and they might repeat i wonder what
the threat is after right
why did he play that one d3 was
threatening to
take the pawn with discovered check
and
so knight you can move the rook away
rook a2 comes to mind
black is tied down to the g6 square so
there's no pieces hanging but if the
queen were to move away from its defense
of g6 e takes d5 happens and the queen
g6 checks so it's it's a
for black that queen is probably going
to sit around g5 and back to f6 and so
on so i like to move rook a2 just trying
to activate the rook
ten seconds
oh gosh and he's down to seven and
perusia deciding what to do as he goes
he moves with six seconds on the clock
rook to e3
so he freezes queen but where to look at
black's pawn structure now maybe it's
black over okay seven absolutely you
force the white rook back to e2 i think
uh one fun note because we saw it
differently at the end of the time
control the other day robert we talked
about in the increment portion the
players are required to write down the
move every single move no matter how
scary it is
and uh you might see some scribbles on
the score sheets as the game goes on but
players have no time or energy to write
down their move and just want to focus
on what's on the board and look at java
determined to find a movie he's down
under 20 seconds he does not want to
touch his d5 pawn if you push that too
soon after d4 c takes e takes e5 he
moves quit wait up step four goes
through a job but he takes e5 and ggg g6
steps back i guess there's nothing wow
that's a big move to play but there is
nothing there takes takes and check the
king would move to safety and actually
white might regret that whole idea i
think alireza should make a draw i think
you should just go rookie two
and just surrender yeah because
i mean he's got so many weaknesses and
it almost seems like timor is taking
over the initiative yeah queen on a four
is very accurate rookie two rookie two
he does indeed play it oh my gosh he
like almost missed the clock he has
three seconds left when he made the move
but you saw him he took him a couple
slots twice swiper no swiping so queen
will come back to f6 i suppose
but then he can play rook a2 right he
can actually maneuver for a bit yeah he
doesn't have to just concede with the
repetition right now so king h8 is also
a possibility to try to get the king out
of dodge or the queen is queen e3 a kind
of threat that's what i'm wondering
queen e3 to get the queens off the board
is not what java wants i would i would
just put the queen back on f6 yeah and i
think he will nope whoa
once more
he wants to go to h4 no way for a
victory oh my god
who's hungry for a victory someone call
short timid we might have a great king
walker well white can put his king on h3
but then after king g5 the f3 pawn is
going to hang he smells blood with the
young player he absolutely smells blood
he's like he's like one of more i'm
gonna show you he is playing king g5
next yeah king g5 is coming on any move
including queen e3 and for
eight seconds it is nervous
where did that play play queen here
comes gg5 here it comes
for the first time we have a tiny little
edge given to black by stockfish 15.
he's got to make that move quickly
though i would make it within a couple
of seconds yeah to leave himself with a
little cushion get well get the pressure
back on peru play king g5
and you no longer queen trade because
you can't play queen d2 because once the
queen trade happens and black takes on
e4 down going all of white's balance
back down now i feel like he might back
down he's down to 10 seconds g5 raja go
aggressive
five don't play king g7 make a move he's
going to go down g5 with two one second
on the clock oh my gosh
this is unbelievable now how do you
defend the f3 pawn if you're ali rook f2
there's de4 oh my god
gosh that's nerve-wracking though oh my
god no that's a drop
you take this
white is winning
oh
then there's queenie one oh my god
gotta go king h4 and force that draw
yeah you think so king h4 rook h1 check
what about brook a7 oh why can't he go
for the open file
that's a great a7
g5 is hanging out we're okay seven
rookie two ronaldo
is the move to play for the win no he
goes king he's schwartz he's going to
repeat a little bit get some time on the
clock perhaps will timor go for the win
with the rook a7 shot because alireza is
not in a position to not repeat
right any kind of queen moves just d
takes e4
and then white's pawn start falling
although here actually queen d3 d64
might force the draw queen d8 check back
to d2 yeah that's actually a repetition
oh the king walked himself into a
trapped repetition which again is
i don't know who is happy about a draw
here um and anymore
perugia has 30 seconds to figure it out
it feels like an eternity given yeah he
had a minute hold a whole minute
everyone relax chad go get a drink we
played 90 moves of chess these two are
really giving it their all they're
giving the fans a spectacle and right
here right now it means a big decision
for ali raise does he try to repeat and
if he does does team over java throw his
rook over to a7 i don't think he will
you think rojava takes the draw yes
what do you play rookie one one
rajab has a huge choice
play king h4 and accept the repetition
that will ensue note that white has to
play this move everyone because queen g3
check would be winning for black so king
h4 we will likely see a draw if for java
wants more if for java is hungry for
that first victory in three years
now might be the time yeah i'm hoping it
goes wrong i hope he plays it too i want
to see someone with this game rope d7 is
another good try might even threaten d
takes e4 even if you sack the rook that
black queen is going to massacre all of
white's pawns rook d7 actually that's a
devious move rook d-7 has d4 or d takes
e4 is done you point out because at the
very least you would draw by repetition
with all the checks and actually you
might be able to go for less than 20
seconds with every taking seconds it
becomes less likely because you'll have
to adapt yep
every second that goes by
means he's more likely to settle he
plays king h4 holly res apresia will
have no choice the threat of queen g3 is
unstoppable without checking and
repeating moves and look at all the
reasons he looks at his scoresheet
because he does not want the draw he's
thinking can i do something else but at
this point if he doesn't take the draw
he will lose the game so i have a king
g5
there's ah it just doesn't look like
there if you play rookie one
it's not a draw yet because it's black
on move so rajabov can play king h4 and
that would force it where java has one
more chance on rookie one i believe
that scene
uh
that seems correct
yeah
particularly
right now because a rookie one was the
first time this was there was the first
time it was played and rijaba
i think is claiming the draw now
yeah it's obviously our petition with
king h4
he stops the clock
what oh my gosh what an epic ending here
to a
i wanted for java to play rook t7
i wanted the fight to continue so did
farrugia
god versus declined so many repetitions
this game
my gosh these two gave it they're
absolutely all
how they even have energy to talk right
now is unbelievable they've been playing
this game for seven hours
i don't know how we have the energy to
talk we've been commentating for seven
and a half hours
and uh
the draw
means that
both of these players despite the
massive effort here in round a to kick
off the back half of the candidates will
remain windless at this point
in their 2020 true 2022 campaign uh
just look at that that's that's love of
the game right there yeah that's like
they've just played
93 moves they're talking about move
probably 15 right now right or 53 and
somehow they remember where the pieces
were yeah
gosh what a game that was and you know
it's almost unfortunate that it wasn't
for a higher place in the standings yeah
because
that was an absolute brawl a lot of
shuffling a lot of just trying to
improve the position and fruit was close
he's young but he showed great technique
at many points in the game to even
secure a bit of an advantage and rajab
up to his credit you know he
kind of steadied the course he made sure
that he wasn't going to lose the game
and then maybe in a different event a
different time he would have kept
playing this moment but instead accepts
the draw
well
dania niradisky welcome to madrid
couldn't have asked for a better better
better starting better better start
shout out to maria emilianova
miss lobalova
she's known in some circles
i was still on a plane this morning i
can't believe that
and now this is that chandler as well
yeah that's chandler
chandler tall guy with the cam right
there
chess.com's videographer
still talking about it but just poking
that one pawn
something a lot of discussion around the
tension that never broke in this game
that's the thing is that the tension in
the center never quite gave way for
either player
that is an example of perhaps chess
played perfect as a draw ladies and
gentlemen because i'm just fascinated by
the fact that yes there were these many
chances and we were hyped because of
time and the practical stuff guys but
the reality is that eval bar never got
past the fourth rank or the or the third
rank like it stayed within a small
advantage for the entire bleeping game
these guys
were were true gladiators out there and
did not budge an inch no they did not
and i think as we saw frozen poking at
the g4 pawn
i think there was that moment he went
knight to g4 that if he had just pushed
the pawn or kept the knights on the
board maybe he felt he had more winning
chances with more pieces but
neither here nor there because the game
is in the books that fourth and final
game on the round eight pairings that
was a draw
indeed we did have decisive chess
obviously you see in round date if you
just got here richard report won
uh in style not just because of what he
was wearing the style on the board was
much more his style and he got his first
victory here in madrid nepal but she
drew a very quick game versus daily i
think it was in the last century
that's true that's true but tom no
promise you could do a quick game but
really daniel let you talk a little bit
uh quickly i mean ferrugia the draw
there we just saw was epic nakamura's
victory is the talk of the town right
now
it really is and for good reason i mean
that game was
was epic in in many many more ways than
one because
to beat fabio when he's in this kind of
form we talked about it before the round
is ridiculously hard fabio was like a
dragon that kept getting reborn and
reborn and breathing fire even with his
back pushed against the wall but hikaru
never let up did he make mistakes yes
was his technique perfect no
but that doesn't detract from all of the
incredible resources that he found and
the fact that he kept his legs churning
once again like marshawn lynch
even though he didn't show up for the
interview and he might get fined
we'll
with us
but he actually did
show up there we go for the interview
with dina bell and kaya uh she caught up
with the man after the the game of the
day in many respects not just because of
the fine victory was but because of what
it now does to the story line here at
the 2022 feed of candidates let's see
what hikaru had to say about his victory
over fabiano caruana
hikaru congratulations on your win a
very long fight how ambitious were you
approaching today's game in the
beginning
yeah i mean i was just trying to play
normal um but the funny thing is i
actually thought fabiano might play this
so i spent like two hours last night
looking at this uh all these crazy
variations um in this open spanish uh
yeah i thought fabiano had to play e4 or
i thought once he wants c4 it's going to
be very hard to ever get the central
pawns rolling i mean i'm sure the
computer says black is fine but i think
for a human it's very hard
um and then once you had to go e4 i
think positionally it's it's very very
tough to play for black because you just
end up with this dead bishop on d3
that's doing absolutely nothing um
so
probably i mean the the critical moment
was when fabiana played c4 i think our
broadcast team suggested that uh you
might both actually confuse some lines
was there 21 bishop g5 rook d8 and then
rook takes c5 yeah rook takes e5 uh
bishop g5 there's also c4 there i think
though there are a couple tricks um but
let's leave it at that right and uh when
you played the h4 apparently there was
h5 the only solution uh to continue
quality did you consider this one ah so
it's still equal yeah i mean i think
once i get actually once i get bishop g4
i think it's just lost i think once i
get this bishop out on this diagonal it
should be winning um
yeah maybe h5 but i thought i could i
could play some queen g5 here and then
takes g6 knight c6 i mean okay computer
probably just holds it with that without
any trouble but i mean again to human it
looks very hard to play because i have
knight e5 bishop d4
yeah i don't really know why that should
be equal
but computers i guess say it is
and then in the end game there was this
idea putting the rook on h1 and
apparently it would be still very hard
to
to it wouldn't be winning immediately
yeah did you consider that yeah but i
mean okay this is it's insane that i let
it get to this point but i still do the
same thing with knight g2 king g3 bishop
two and i think it's still winning um
practically maybe there's okay maybe
there's some way for a computer to find
something but i think it's technically
lost at that point i thought maybe
rookie 5 instead of rookie 6 was the one
one last try but
again it was a long game and i mean both
of us obviously retired by that point
that was a great show in any case and
now looking at your situation in the
tournament what are your plans so to be
um well uh i i guess i play two more
tomorrow so we'll see what happens how
hard is it for you to receive yourself
from from streaming on the rest days you
mentioned that you miss it no no i mean
i'm gonna stream title tuesday so that's
that's for sure but um
no i mean i think i'm i'm enjoying uh
enjoying the tournament it's been had
some great great long fights um and
there's still quite a few more rounds to
go but if you focus on one thing and
then go back to the other thing
afterwards
all right thanks so much hikaru sure
what a great time to be a chess man hey
kara nakamura going to stream title
tuesday in the middle of the feeding
candidates this is nutty but what great
understanding kakaroko that was
that that was insane how well he
understood what was going on there that
was freaky yeah it was freaky everything
that we talked about it's almost like
he's wearing the earpiece not sure i
mean seriously like and then he like
called the the line that started with
roundok sadwani it's shout out to
roundnock and we showed it but we saw
after c4 were like what's going on so
clearly it shows that the depth that
these 2800 players take in to the
supercomputer process and their seconds
goes a little further than i guess we
can come up with on the fly just just by
attack a little bit then he saw rookie
five in the end
so oh yeah he saw popular's best chances
there right there and just casually
threw it out like it was totally normal
to see that move yeah like it was an
obvious move and he wasn't wrong to also
push back he's like look like rook h1
like
practically speaking he clearly saw this
idea of course he'll see this crazy
bishop of five mating that weird thing
but it was not like that was forced or
anything it was just it was probably
just bobby on his best chance at that
point so
the way hikaru approached that game and
the depth of understanding he had about
that should not be lost on any i don't
think it is but we're sitting here like
eyes wide during the interview like this
guy's a freak yeah they could see us
because we're on camera
this time which i didn't really register
at first but hikaru nakamura we see him
in third place yon napomashi maybe the
big winner of the day despite drawing
his game thanks to hikar i mean hikart
won his game but yon's sitting here a
full point ahead of fabiano and i think
we know where everybody's eyes are going
to be tomorrow yep
yonda palm nishi with six points will be
taking on fabiano caruana with five
points with the black pieces and that's
not to say we won't be watching hikaru
nakamura take on tamer java because he
is now back in the mix uh should he
somehow deliver two victories in a row
uh despite having the black pieces but
what do you do tonight guys if you're
fabiano right first you get dinner take
a breath
but
what do you do in your approach knowing
that there's no
there's no dancing around this tomorrow
you have to play for a win as white
against yonder pawn machine i think one
of the things you do in your preparation
at least i would make sure i know who
he's playing the rest of the way because
yes fabiano needs to catch up a full
point now not just a half point but you
want to see am i the only one who can
stop him and everyone will try their
best but if yon has favorable parents
gets white against the players that he
has a good record against and he's black
against people who maybe aren't pressing
so much in this tournament or struggling
like that could play a part but
ultimately what five minute car want us
to do is win tomorrow's game there no
questions
but what about that other storyline
right with if magnus carlsen doesn't
want to play yonda pamashi does fabiano
want to risk it all and not even finish
in second place
that has to be part of the dynamic
don your answers to both those questions
one what do you what do you have
anything more to add on what you feel
like fabiano needs to do here well i i
think he needs to play a solid opening i
think the most important thing is for
him to play something he's comfortable
with i know it's a cliche but it's
attempting to play hero ball the day
after you lose a really painful game and
i agree with what robert said
you know if this next game ends in a
draw every single player in this field
is capable of beating every single other
player so the tournament doesn't end if
tomorrow's fabi nepo game ends in a draw
if amnesia could lose one of the last
game think about the nerves that he's
going to feel so fabby has to try to
find that balance between yes playing
for a win yes playing ambitiously but no
not doing anything wild
i think he's got to go all in well i
agree but there's also one other matchup
that comes to my mind that fabiano can
be like hey buddy you're my new best
friend alireza frugia gets the white
pieces against yonder palmashi okay and
ali reza is clearly still trying his
hardest in this tournament yeah right
richard report he just beat john
chisholm dude everyone is still
competing even if they're out of the
running they're still trying their best
so i really mean it when i say if i'm
fabiano i actually you know i'm not i'm
going to focus on the chess but somebody
in camp carwana has to look at the next
pairings for yon napamishi because
there's got to be someone in there who
may have a good chance of upsetting him
and ali raza fruga may be that guy he
hasn't been the fruger everyone unfairly
expected him to be perhaps but with the
white piece against john de palma that's
going to be an absolute clash you know
what a storyline it might be if somehow
this does stay within the realm of
fabiano needing help from
from a friend and richard report is in a
position to maybe uh
change his fate
as it would be
in one of the later rounds here uh where
of course report would be black but uh
right now
every one of these topics will be
discussed as we look at
jan napomnishi's second half yeah the
last round black against duda that's not
an easy game not not a game that's not
an easy game at all he drew of course
that game to dingley wren we will have
that updated for you tomorrow but all
the other games as you see
um
they have a lot to talk about and uh
well we don't need to speculate i guess
what would happen anyways in the games
because we have all the drama we could
possibly have and that the person in
second is chasing the person at first
has the only real advantage you can have
in chess which is the first move getting
the white pieces at least to start a
game regardless of what they cook up at
home and we will be here to call the
action tomorrow grand master robert hess
grandmaster daniel naredinsky and yours
truly the guy with the twitch socks
and everyone else in studio in the
palacio de centonia will also be here
that's the spanish broadcast wrapping
things up the live audience has gone
home because night time falls upon
madrid a city
that will not ever sleep though is about
to come to life
and uh we're gonna go get some food
and hope you enjoyed today's broadcast
of round eight of the 2022 feeding
candidates and we will see you for round
nine manana
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you